SENATE TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE
WILL COME TO ORDER AS A SUB
COMMITTEE SO GOOD MORNING AS WE
CONTINUE GOOD AFTERNOON ACTUALLY
AS WE CONTINUE TO TAKE SOME
PRECAUTIONS TO MANAGE ON GOING
CO IN NINETEEN RISKS THE SENATE
CONTINUES TO WELCOME THE PUBLIC
IN ITS PROVIDED ACCESS TO BOTH
IN PERSON. AND TELECONFERENCES
STATION FOR PUBLIC COMMENT FOR
INDIVIDUALS WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY VIA THAT TELECONFERENCE
ORVIS THE PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE
NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED
ON OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE ON THE
LINK TO TODAY'S HEARING AND I
WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TO TASTE
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
844-291-6364 ACCESS CODE. ONE
FOUR ONE ONE ONE FOUR ZERO AGAIN
THAT IS EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO NINE
ONE SIX THREE SIX FOUR. ACCESS
CODE. ONE FOUR ONE ONE ONE FOUR
ZERO- AND I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY IN ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO
IS DESTRUCTIVE MAY BE REMOVED
FROM THE MEETING. SERVICE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS NEEDED WE ARE
HOLDING COMMITTEE HEARINGS IN
THE- STREET BUILDING IN ROOM
TWELVE HUNDRED FOR THE FIRST
TIME I ASK ALL MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEES TO BE PRESENT IN THIS
ROOM SO WE CAN ESTABLISH A
QUORUM. ON THE- THE TODAY'S
AGENDA WE HAVE ABOUT EIGHTEEN
MEASURES AND BEFORE WE HEAR
PRESENTATION ON THE BILL I THINK
WE'RE NOT ESTABLISHING OF WE
RELIGIOUS TED STARTED. SO
ACTUALLY WILL DO IS WILL AGAIN
MOVE FORWARD AS A SUB COMMITTEE
AND WILL BEGIN WITH AGENDA ITEM
. NUMBER EIGHT FILE ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT SB THIRTEEN FIFTY SIX. ARE
YOU UP TO THE CHAIR. WE WERE
GOING TO HAVE OF THE CENTER TO
MOVE FIRST BUT IF YOU LOOK LIKE
TO YOU GUYS CAN WORK THAT OUT IF
YOU'D LIKE TO. I MEAN I'M HERE
OKAY YOU ARE HERE SO WILL
ACTUALLY BEGIN WITH SENATOR
PORTANTINO. WELCOME SENATOR
PORTANTINO THAT'S FILE ITEM ONE
SB NINE THIRTY TWO GENERAL
PLANNED CIRCULATION ELEMENT
BICYCLE AND PEDESTRIAN PLANS AND
TRAFFIC CALMING PLAN SENATOR
PORTANTINO YOU MAY BEGIN THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS ARE
OBVIOUSLY PRESENTING S. B. NINE
THREE TO A BILL WHICH SEEKS TO
SAVE LIVES ON OUR CALIFORNIA
STREETS AND ROADS. I'D LIKE TO
START BY NOTING THAT I WILL BE
AMENDING THE BILL TO ADD A
TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT SUNSET FOUR
YEARS AFTER TWENTY TWENTY FOUR
IMPLEMENTATION DATE TO THE
PRIVATE CAUSE OF ACTION TO ALLOW
TIME TO EVALUATE IT SHOULD USE I
WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR AND
STAFF FOR WORKING WITH MY STAFF
ON THE AMENDMENTS AND- THINK
THAT THAT IS AN APPROPRIATE
THING TO DO SO WE CAN EVALUATE
ITS EFFECTIVENESS. WHICH IS WHAT
WE'RE ALL ABOUT- DESPITE DECADES
OF RHETORIC ON THE NEED FOR SAFE
STREETS SMOKES CALIFORNIA
STREETS HAVE GROWN MORE
DANGEROUS IN RECENT YEARS
ACCORDING TO THE NATIONAL
HIGHWAY TRAFFIC SAFETY
ADMINISTRATION TWENTY TWENTY ONE
SON NEARLY 20% INCREASE IN
TRAFFIC FATALITIES IN THE FIRST
SIX MONTHS. COMPARED TO TWENTY
TWENTY AND TWENTY NINETEEN S. B.
NINE THREE TWO REQUIRES A COUNTY
OR CITY TO INCLUDE IN ITS
GENERAL PLAN A MAP OF THE HIGH
INJURY NETWORK WITHIN ITS
BOUNDARIES AND FURTHER REQUIRE A
COUNTY OR CITY TO IDENTIFY
PRIORITIZE AND IMPLEMENT SAFETY
IMPROVEMENTS. SOME MIGHT ARGUE
THESE IMPROVEMENTS ARE NOT CHEAP
TEMPLATE IMPLEMENT BUT HOW CAN
YOU PUT A PRICE ON SOMEONE'S
LIFE EVEN WITH THAT BEING SAID
WE ARE COGNISANT OF THIS CONCERN
IT IS OUR INTENT THAT THE
LEGISLATURE CREATE AN ANNUAL
GRANT PROGRAM TO AWARD FUNDING
TO A COUNTY AND CITY UPON
COMPLETION OF THESE TRAFFIC
CALMING MEASURES. AS A FATHER OF
TWO YOUNG WOMEN IN THE END A
RECENT ADVERT AVID CYCLIST
MYSELF I'M SADDENED BY THE ALL
TO COMMON TRAGEDIES THAT OCCUR
IN OUR STREETS IT SEEMS LIKE
EVERY WEEK THERE'S ANOTHER STORY
IN THE NEWSPAPER ABOUT A CYCLIST
INJURED OR KILLED. OFF WE ALSO
HAVE TO BE COGNIZANT OF THOSE
PEDESTRIANS WERE RUSHING TO TAKE
PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION SO IT'S
ABOUT PEDESTRIANS AND CYCLISTS
WE'RE IN THE MOTORIST TO WHO
SHARE THE SPACE WE NEED THE
STREETS TO BE SAFE. IT'S ABOUT
TIME THAT SAFETY FOR EVERYONE
USING OUR STREETS ARE CHILDREN
WALKING TO SCHOOL OUR PARENTS
AND GRANDPARENTS TRAVELING TO A
DOCTOR'S APPOINTMENT. ALL NEED
US TO TAKE NOTICE AND TAKE
SOLUTIONS. WE CAN HELP ROUTE
ROUTE REDUCE TRAFFIC VIOLENCE WE
JUST HAVE TO BE BOLD ENOUGH TO
DO IT. FOR THESE REASONS I WILL
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE- TO TEST THE PHONE TESTIFY
ON THE PHONE I HAVE. CLAIRE'S
ANGER VOLUNTEER ADVOCATE FOR
STREETS FOR ALL AND NEWLY
TRUJILLO WHICH STREET RACING
KILLS. WHO IS A ON REGULAR
PUBLIC SAFETY EXTREMELY PUBLIC
PARTICIPANT PHONE LINES AND I
ASK THAT YOU BE ABLE TO PRESENT
AS WELL SO THANK YOU. THANK YOU
CENTER PORTANTINO- MODERATOR WE
HAVE TO OF FOLKS THAT ARE ON
THE- LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE
THIRTY TO PLEASE. THEY LATER.
GOOD AFTERNOON CAN YOU HEAR ME.
YES WE CAN YOU MAY PROCEED.
THANK YOU- GOOD AFTERNOON TO THE
SENATE TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE
. MY NAME IS CLEARED. YOU CAN'T
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. A
CONSTITUENT OF SENATOR
PORTANTINO AND ON BEHALF OF
STREETS FOR ALL. CALIFORNIANS
CANNOT BOTH TALK ABOUT
ADDRESSING CLIMATE CHANGE AND
ENCOURAGING CLEANER MODES OF
TRANSPORTATION I'LL CONTINUE TO
CALIFORNIANS TRYING YOU KNOW THE
DANGER. YEAH TRAFFIC VIOLENCE
CONTINUES TO BE A HEALTH AND
SAFETY CRISIS IN CALIFORNIA
TWENTY TWENTY ONE WITH THE
DEADLIEST YEAR FOR TRAFFIC
VIOLENCE NEARLY TWENTY YEARS
YOUR LOS ANGELES. IN JUST ONE
MONTH AND A HALF SINCE THE LAST
TESTIFIED ON THE BILL IN MARCH
WE'RE READY A LOT EVEN MORE
PEOPLE THE DEATH FROM BEING
STRUCK BY CARS A LOT OF WALKING
OR BIKING. IS LICENSE- AND YOU
DON'T WORK WITH GUILT ONLY TEN
DAYS AGO WELL FRANKLY FOR
CHARITY AND SENATOR PORTANTINO'S
DISTRICT. WE CANNOT UNDERSTATE
THE URGENCY. OF INSTITUTING
SOLUTIONS NOW. I PERSONALLY
THINK OF SOMEONE WHO JUST THE.
CONTINUED REHABILITATION TODAY.
CALIFORNIANS DESERVE TO BE SAFE
GETTING AROUND OUTDOOR SPACE BUT
I FOR OTHER NON CAR BUT- SB NINE
THREE TWO WEBER STATE COUNTY THE
YOU FOR. THE PEDESTRIAN BY
TRAFFIC CALMING MEASURES. WE
ALREADY HOW TO MAKE OUR STREETS
SAFER CITIES AND COUNTIES ACROSS
THE COUNTRY THAT PUT THE EFFORT
INTO INSTITUTING COMPLETE ST
HAVE PROVEN THESE MEASURES TO
REDUCE CRASHES AND FATALITIES.
WE ALSO HAVE THE FIVE COMPLETE
MAKE EVERYONE SAFER PEDESTRIANS
CYCLISTS AND DRIVERS. NO LONGER
WAIT MORE LIFE WE WILL CONTINUE
TO LOSE UNNECESSARILY TO OUR
PRECIOUS THAT'S WHY WE PUT WE
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS
IMPORTANT BILL AND ASK THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR THEIR EYES
UP THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I THINK
SENATOR PORTANTINO YOU HAVE ONE
OTHER- LEAD WITNESS IN AND
SUPPORTS OF S. B. NINE THIRTY
TWO ON THE LINE SO MODERATOR CAN
YOU ENSURE THAT THEIR- OTHER
LEAD WITNESS IN SUPPORT. IS ON
THE LINE PLEASE. THE LINES ARE
OPEN FOR SPEAKERS. AND I DON'T
HAVE A NAME FOR THE OTHER THE-
AND WE MAY HAVE. MOST OF MR
HE'LL. MODERATOR TO HAVE MR HERE
ON THE LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB.
NINE THIRTY TWO. AND IF YOU'VE
CALLED IN AT LEAST. THIS ONE IN
THE ZERO THANK OPEN THE LINE.
DEFECT ON MONDAY. AND THAT ONE
IS OPEN.
OKAY AND I THINK A SENATOR
PORTANTINO IS OKAY IF WITH US
MOVING ON WITHOUT THIS OTHER
LEAD- WITNESS AND SUPPORT TO
THANK YOU MODERATOR- SO WE'VE
CONDUCTED- CONCLUDED THE LEAD
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT SO WE'LL GO
TO THE GALLERY HERE IF THERE'S
ANYONE IN SUPPORT AND PRESENT
AND FOR SB NINE THIRTY TO PLEASE
. C. NINE SO WE'LL GO BACK TO
YOU MODERATOR IF THERE'S ANYONE
ELSE IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE
THIRTY TWO ON THE TELECONFERENCE
LINE. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH
TO COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE
THIRTY TWO YOU MAY PRESS ONE AT
THAT ZERO AT THIS TIME. BUT
AGAIN. IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT IN
SUPPORT. OF SB NINE THIRTY TO.
AT ONE. THE BEST OF. IF YOU
PEOPLE OF MORE THE ONE TIME.
VERY- OF LIGHT ONE OH SEVEN.
YOUR LINE IS- OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THERE- THIS IS OBVIOUS
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF LIKE
CULVER CITY. WORK AND I ALSO
WANTED TO SAY THAT LILY- TO HILO
IS ON SHE THAT SHE IS ON- THE
PUBLIC COMMENT- RIGHT SO WE CAN
GET HER. ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU.
NEXT HIGHLY. ONE THIRTY. MY
MOTHER SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
HELLO. HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME.
YES WE CAN HEAR YOU. HELLO SIR
WE NEED YOUR NAME AND
ORGANIZATION AND THAT- WE ARE
TAKING SUPPORT FOR SB NINE
THIRTY TO AT THIS MOMENT. YES MY
NAME IS FOR YOU LOMBA. HELLO
ORGANIZATION RIGHT FUTURE AND-
I'M FALLING IN FROM DIFFERENT
GOT. HI STROMBUS THIS AND I
THINK IT WOULD IMPROVE- BUDGET
HANFORD SAFETY THANK YOU HI
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU. AND
ONE ONE FIFTIES YOUR LIVE IS A
PLEA. FOR HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES. MARKET HI MY NAME IS THAT
HE NEEDS TO HE GET BACK I AM THE
FOUNDER OF STREET RACING HILL I
AM IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
RECONVENE AND THAT MY DAUGHTER
WITH WAKING PRESSURE OF THEIR-
NARROW STREET AND THE WAY NOT AT
. AND YOU WOULD THINK A HIGH I
REALLY DIDN'T THAT IF THERE-
FROM OF MORE- LIKE THIS BILL
THAT THE WHAT IT SAYS I IT WILL
EVY. AVAILABLE FORTY. SO HOW
CAN THE FOR FORTY CARS TO BE
TRIED BY IT ABSOLUTELY SO OF THE
- AT THE PROBLEM STRIKES IN THIS
ROOM WE NEED HELP. SO IN THE
HAVE A WAITING HE'LL I WILL YOU
FOR THIS BILL. TO STABILIZE
AMONG THE PEOPLE AND- INDUSTRY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MYSTERY
THAT YOUR OTHER LEAD WITNESS IN
SUPPORT SO WE'RE GOING TO THE
NEXT COMMENT PLEASE. ONE ONE
FIFTH NINE YOUR IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. NEARLY YES YOU MAY
PROCEED MEXICO. HI MY NAME IS
MARK OF H. I'M IN STRONG OF THE
MY YOU HAVE FIX OUR ROADS THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THERE ARE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS IN THE- WHERE
SB NINE THIRTY TWO IN SPORT
THANK YOU MODERATOR SO WE'LL
MOVE ON TO ANY LEAD WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION SEEN NONE SO WE'LL GO
TO THE GALLERY IF THERE'S ANYONE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB NINE THIRTY TO
PLEASE COME FORWARD. ALSO
NUMBERS CHRISLEY ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION
OF COUNTIES. REGRETTABLY WITH AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
ON SB NINE THREE TWO. I'M WE'VE
HAD SOME GOOD CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE AND THE
SUPPORTERS AND I THINK WE ALL
REALLY AGREE WITH THE GOALS OF
THIS BILL WE JUST HAVE A
DRAMATICALLY DIFFERENT VISION.
ABOUT WHAT WE NEED TO DO TO
ACHIEVE THEM AND SO. ISSUES THAT
WE'VE OUTLINED IN OUR LETTER OF
OPPOSITION INCLUDED THE NEW
PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION WE
REALLY THINK THAT WILL ACTUALLY
BE COUNTERPRODUCTIVE TO
ACHIEVING THE BILL'S GOALS
BECAUSE OF LIABILITY CONCERNS OF
THE ACTUAL COST. THERE AND-
CITIES AND COUNTIES WANT TO DO
THESE IMPROVEMENTS IF THEY
DIDN'T WNT TO DO THESE
IMPROVEMENTS WE WOULDN'T HAVE A
TWENTY TWO BILLION DOLLAR
DEFICIT. FOR THE EXISTING
COMPLETE STREETS FEATURES THAT
WE PUT IN ON OUR LOCAL STREETS
AND ROADS AROUND THE STATE. WE
DIDN'T WANT TO DO THESE
IMPROVEMENTS WE WOULDN'T HAVE A
MASSIVELY OVERSUBSCRIBED ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM. AND SO I
THINK YOU KNOW WE SHARE THE
VISION BUT WE'RE VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT THE IMPLEMENTATION
DETAILS. AND THE BILL NEEDS TO
BE RE FRAMED AROUND THE
RESOURCES THAT ARE REASONABLY
GOING TO BE AVAILABLE FOR THESE
PURPOSES. THOSE ARE THINGS WE
SUPPORT THINGS WE WANT TO WORK
TOGETHER ON BUT BY HAVING THIS
NEW PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION WE
REALLY THINK WE'RE UNDERMINING
THOSE SCHOOLS AND SO. WITH THAT
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE AUTHOR'S
OFFICE BUT HAVE AN OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION THANK YOU THANK
YOU MISTER LEE. ANYONE ELSE
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB NINE THIRTY TO
PLEASE COME FORWARD. RIGHT C.
NINE AMADA. WILL TAKE IT BACK TO
THE TELECONFERENCE LINE FOR
ANYONE WHO'D LIKE TO. OPPOSE SB
NINE THIRTY TWO. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION A FIFTY NINE THIRTY
TWO. AM EXCEPT ONE AND THAT
THEIR- AT THIS TIME. WHAT BEGAN
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION SB NINE THIRTY TWO.
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AT THAT ZERO.
NINE ONE FIFTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON TURN NUMBER ANOTHER
COMPILED BEHALF OF CITY OF JOSE
. WHILE THE CITY HAS NOT TAKEN
AN OFFICIAL POSITION ON AT THE
NINE THIRTY TWO WE THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR THE READ AND
AMENDMENTS AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUING CONVERSATIONS WITH
VA AT. THE AUTHOR TO ADDRESS THE
CITY REMAIN CONCERNED. THANK YOU
. THANK YOU NEXT COME PLEASE.
FIVE ONE TWENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON TRACY RIGHT WITH THE
WORLD TYLER TODAY CALIFORNIA AND
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER OF THE AMERICAN PLANNING
ASSOCIATION IN IRVINE CALIFORNIA
ALSO WITH THE VISION OF A POST
LIKE MOBILE IN FEAR. SIX NINE
FOUR. AND. NEXT COMMENT PLEASE
MY- RIGHT ONE TWENTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH
YOUR NUMBER IS BEING CALLED ONE-
WITH THE LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA
CITIES REGRETTABLY WITH A OPPOSE
WHAT THE META DATA FOR THE COR
MENTIONED- REASONS OUTLINED BY
THE SECOND AND- THIRD IN THE
TOWARDS WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR
IF YOU WERE TO COME FORWARD
THINKING. WE HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT IN OPPOSITION SB NINE
THIRTY IN THE QUEUE THANK YOU
MODERATOR HAVE CONCLUDED
OPPOSITION NOW WILL ESTABLISH A
QUORUM IT LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE A
SUFFICIENT NUMBER OF MEMBERS
HERE MISTER CHIEF CONSULTANT.
SENATORS GONZALEZ HERE DOLLARS
HERE BATES. FITS HERE ALLEN
ARCHULETA YOUR AGILITY HERE
BAKER. CORTESE YOUR CORTESE HERE
DOLLY DALI HERE DOT. DOT HERE
LIMON MCGUIRE. MELENDEZ IN MAN
HERE NEWMAN HERE NEWMAN HERE
RUBIO. SKINNER BY CASKEY THEY'RE
BY CASKEY HERE WELCOME. EVERCORE
OKAY GREAT THANK YOU MISTER SHE
CONSULTANT WITH ESTABLISHED A
QUORUM SO WE'VE CONCLUDED
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION TO WILL
TAKE IT BACK TO MEMBER SENATOR
MCCASKEY SO THE QUESTION OVER
THE AMENDMENT ON THE PRIVATE
RIGHT OF ACTION IS I UNDERSTAND
THAT THE PRIBADI PEOPLE HAVE A
PRIVATE BY THE FACT UNTIL
JANUARY FIRST TWENTY THIRTY ONE
THE UNDER THE BILL THAT THESE
THESE GENERAL PLANS HAVE TO BE
AMENDED BY JUNE THIRTIETH.
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR WHICH GIVES
THEM EIGHTEEN MONTHS TO MEND
THEIR GENERAL PLAN JUST A NOTE
THAT LA HAS AN AMENDED THEIR
GENERAL PLAN IN FORTY YEARS BUT
MAYBE IN EIGHTEEN MONTHS THEY
CAN GET IT DONE SO UNDER THE
BILL AS AMENDED ON JULY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR EVERYBODY
EVERY BICYCLE INTO. TWO LA OR
ANY CITY THAT HASN'T DONE THE
GENERAL PLAN CIRCULATION IS THAT
. LOW WITH THE MEN. THE
AMENDMENT SUNSETS THE PRIVATE
RIGHT OF ACTION AFTER FOUR YEARS
VERSUS KEEPING IT IN PERPETUITY
RIGHT PROBABLY WOULD BE BETTER.
TO TRIGGER THE FOR YEARS IS
EVERYBODY HAS WITHIN TWO YEARS
TO ADOPT THE PLAN THAT THE
UPDATED PLAN IT PROBABLY AS I
THINK ABOUT IT IT PROBABLY WOULD
BE BETTER TO MAKE THE FOUR YEAR
SPECIFIC TO EACH CITY'S ADOPTION
OF THE PLAN- VERSES A BLANKET.
APPLYING TO EVERY SPEAKERS
DIFFERENT CITIES ARE GONNA BE A
ADOPTING THEIR PLAN AND
IMPLEMENTING THEIR PLAN ON
DIFFERENT SCHEDULES. THAT MIGHT
BE A BETTER APPROACH- BUT
OBVIOUSLY I HAVE NOT DISCUSSED
THAT WITH THE CHAIR SO I'M
STICKING BY THE FOUR YEAR.
SUNSETTHAT WE DISCUSSED. BUT
YOU'RE RAISING APPOINTED TO
STAGGERED IMPLEMENTATION IN EACH
CITY. AND IN. I GUESS THE
PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION IT'S
CONCEIVABLE ON NINETEEN YEARS
AND ELEVEN MONTHS THAT SOMEBODY
DIDN'T GET THE ROAD UNDER THIS
PLAN THIS COULD BE ADOPTED IN IN
EIGHTEEN MONTHS SO THEY WOULD
SELL FOOD YOU'RE GETTING RID OF
THOSE PRIVATE RIGHT AFFECTIONS I
GUESS THE QUESTION IS THAT ONCE
YOU HAVE THE RIGHT. DOES IT
EVAPORATE I MEAN YOU DON'T EAT
IT YOU YOUR COST OF ACTION IS
CREATED BY THE LACK OF.
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE RIGHT
RIGHT EXACTLY SO THAT THE WHOLE
POINT OF IT WAS WE WANT TO. FOR
CITIES TO ADOPT THE PLOT AND WE
WANT TO GIVE THEM THE RESOURCES
TO FIX THE PROBLEM WE WANT TO
GIVE THEM THE DATED WHY DATA
FIVE HOT SPOTS AND THEN WE WANT
TO HOLD THEM ACCOUNTABILITY.
ACCOUNTABLE AND SO TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT THE BEST WAY TO APPLY
THE PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION IS
IMPORTANT I'M AGAIN. I'M FINE
WITH THAT THE CONTRACT WE HAVE
THAT. WE HAVE. TO IT OUT I THINK
IT MIGHT BE BETTER TO STAFF IT
BASS ON A POEM. WE'RE IS
SOMETHING OUT OF THIS WITH THE
AIR BUT- AGAIN I THIS IS FINE
WITH ME- BUT I THINK I DON'T
THINK IT DOES SUNSET SO WILL GO
AWAY AFTER THE FOR. WHAT I WHAT
I'M GOING TO GO. THERE ARE SOME
WHAT I'M CONCERNED IS ONE
CREATE. A RIDE OF ACTION. AND
IT'S ONLY A IT'S CENTER HIM FOR
YEARS I DON'T I DON'T I THINK
THAT THAT MAY BE AN OP. IT MAKE
YOU'LL BE OP OPERATIVE TO THE-
TO THE EXTENT THAT IT'S IN THE
PLAN THEY ADOPTED A PLAN THEY
DID ALL THAT. AND THEY HAVEN'T
CONSTRUCTED THAN THOSE PEOPLE
WOULD LOSE THAT PRIDE RIGHT
FACTION BUT IF IT'S NOT IN THE
PLAN OR THEY HAVEN'T. DONE THE
PLAN THAT WOULD THEY WOULD
INITIATE THAT PRIVATE RIGHT OF
ACTION AND THEN ONCE THAT. IS
ALWAYS THE LIABILITY OF A CITY.
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER WE
EXPLICITLY SPELL IT OUT OR NOT
WE'RE NOT ABSOLVING THE CITIES
OF ANY OF THEIR RIGHTS AND
OBLIGATIONS AND- PUBLIC A RIGHT
TO ADDRESS THAT IF THAT'S YOUR-
YOUR QUESTION. SO OKAY THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE CREATING A UNIQUE ONE
TIED TO THIS THAT WOULD SENSE SO
THAT'S THAT'S THE NEW MONTHS.
MANAGER THE OTHER OPTION THAT I
HAD IS. WE HAVE. EXPENDED A
BOATLOAD OF MONEY AND SO SB ONE
ON I'M- TRANSPORTATION AND WE
HAVEN'T HAD THAT INVENTORY. WHAT
EIGHT ACTUAL TO THIS. YEAR A
WHOLE LOT OF BIKE LANES. GO GO
IN. CAN I'M PEOPLE GETS. A QUICK
BUT THAT'S THAT OKAY. I QUOTE IS
. ON THE JUNE TWENTY THIRTIETH
TWENTY FOUR HOW. AND HOW ARE
CITIES WHO HAVE NOT UPDATED
THEIR GENERAL PLANS IN TWENTY
YEARS GOING TO DO IT IN EIGHTEEN
EIGHTEEN MONTHS AT THE RESOURCES
THAT THEY WOULD NEED TO DO TO DO
TO START THAT CIRCULATE PLAN ARE
GOING TO DIVERT ARE GOING TO BE
DIVERTED FROM ACTUALLY BUILDING
THE BIKE LANE I GUESS SO. YOU
CAME UP WITH THE TWELFTH AT IS
THAT A REALISTIC NUMBER I GUESS
MY CONCERN IS I DON'T THINK THAT
THAT'S A REALISTIC DATE WELL
TRULY I'M OPEN TO DISCUSSING
WHAT ISRAEL I MEAN THERE'S A
COMPANION BUDGET PIECE TO THIS
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
CITY'S PARTICIPATE IN THE GRANT
APPLICATION TO ACTUALLY HAVE THE
RESOURCES THEY HAVE AT THIS MY
GOAL IS NOT TO HAVE A PLANNING
DOCUMENTS TO IT ON A SHELF IS
NOT TO HAVE THIS BE EFFECTIVE SO
. I FOR BUDGETS CHAIR YOU KNOW
I'M I'M HAPPY TO TAKE YOUR INPUT
INTO TIMELINE AND IMPLEMENTATION
AND- AND- YOU KNOW WHAT IF WHAT
YOU THINK MAKES IT STRONGER I
I'D WELCOME YOUR INPUT. ON THAT.
BUT I DON'T WANT SOMETHING TO BE
AN EFFECTIVE AT THE END OF THE
DAY. I SEE PLENTY OF GRAY HERE
AROUND THE TABLE HERE WE'RE ALL
FAMILIAR WITH THE BEST
TRANSPORTATION PLANS THAT WE'VE
BEEN PART OF THAT HAVE NOT BEEN
IMPLEMENTED RIGHT SO I DON'T
KNOW IF I WANT TO BE SUED OVER
IT. I MEAN BUT THAT'S THE- YES.
I SEE WHAT YOU WANNA DO I SEE
THE BIGGER PICTURE I JUST HAD
THOSE CONCERNS MANAGER. YEAH AND
I IF I COULD ADD YOU KNOW WE
WORK WE'RE- STILL DISCUSSING AND
SO WE TALKED ABOUT THE END DATE
IN TERMS OF THE SUNSET BUT YOU
HAVE A GOOD POINT IN TERMS OF
THE COMMENCEMENT DATE YOU KNOW
WHEN WITH THAT ACTUALLY START.
GIVEN YOU KNOW. WHERE CITIES
NEED TO START REALLY RE
EVALUATING REASSESSING THEIR
PLANTS SO WE CAN YES I OBVIOUSLY
I'M NOT GONNA DO ANYTHING
WITHOUT THE CHAIR SUPPORT. I
KNEW ONCE BUT IT DOES MAKE SENSE
THE STAGGERED BASED ON EACH
CITY'S. TIMELINE SO. YES AND
THEN AGAIN THIS JUST- THE
AMENDMENTS ALSO INCLUDE JUST TEN
COUNTIES SO I HOPE RIGHT WENT
DIRECT TO. THE DETAILS ON THAT
IF YOU NEED THAT WE CAN PASS
THAT'S ALSO IMPORTANT THANK
THANK YOU SENATOR DODD. YEAH
COULD YOU COULD YOU REPEAT THAT
WOULD THE TEN COUNTIES WHAT I
DID NOT SEE THAT. YES AND WE
WILL SHARE THAT AROUD I CAN
SEND THIS TO YOU SO THE TEN
COUNTIES ARE ALAMEDA CONTRA
COSTA LOS ANGELES ORANGE
RIVERSIDE SACRAMENTO. SAN
BERNARDINO SAN DIEGO SAN
FRANCISCO AND SANTA CLARA. AND
THOSE ARE THE ONLY ONES THIS
WOULD APPLY TO DIRECT. WELL THAT
MAKES A LITTLE BIT EASIER FOR ME
- BUT THAT SAID I ASSOCIATE BY
COMMENTS WAS CENTER WHICH HOUSE
KEY. YEAH DO WE REALLY WANT TO
INCENTIVIZE PEOPLE TO BE SUING.
YOU KNOW THE COMMUNITIES THAT
THEY RESIDE IN OR THE
COMMUNITIES OF DAY YOU'RE RIGHT
BIKES AND I MEAN THIS IS ALL
TAKE IT WAY TAX DOLLARS FOR
OTHER THINGS WE COULD BE
SPENDING I DO SEE ALSO THAT. THE
NEED FOR COMMUNITIES CITIES
COUNTIES TO THE FULFILL THEIR
GENERAL PLANS TO MAKE GOOD ON
THEIR BIKE PLANT BUT I ALSO DOES
A COUNTY SUPERVISOR SOMETIMES
YOU JUST DON'T HAVE ALL THE
DOUGH. TO DO WHAT YOU NEED TO DO
IN THESE GENERAL PLANTS IT'S SO
YOU MADE A STATEMENT CENTER
PORTANTINO. HEY THERE'S GOING TO
BE. MY REGARDLESS SO WHY DO YOU
HAVE TO HAVE A P. R. A. RIGHT
RIGHT ACTION LISTED IN THE- IN
THIS WILL. TO GO TO YOUR FIRST
POINT. WE'RE GONNA A CREATE A
PLAN B. PROVIDE FINANCING AND
THEN SEE HAVE ACCOUNTABILITY AND
THAT'S THE THIRD PETE THAT'S THE
THIRD STORY. LEG OF THE STOOL IS
TO SPECIFICALLY BECAUSE AS THE
GOOD SEVEN FROM HUNTING
CALIFORNIA MENTIONED. WE'VE ALL
BEEN IN THESE SITUATIONS WHERE
THESE PLANTS SIT ON A SHELF AND
GET US. AND DON'T COULD
IMPLEMENT IT SO WE REALLY WANT
TO USE DATED- IDENTIFY THOSE HOT
SPOTS AND TIE IT TO THE GENERAL
PLAN AND THEN HAVE A HAVE A
HAMMER AND I GET BENNINGER. SO I
GUESS- NOT TO BE ARGUMENTATIVE
BUT AT THE END OF THE DAY. IS
IT'S THE STATE'S INTEREST. TO GO
AND MICROMANAGE TRANSPORTATION
PLANTS IN CITIES AND COUNTIES IN
SHOULD WE BE USING OUR
TRANSPORTATION DOLLARS TO BE
THE- EVEN GIVING GRANTS I MEAN
WE'VE ALREADY GOT THESE GRANT
PROGRAMS EVERYTHING A VERY
SUPPORT OF THOSE PROGRAMS BUT
EXTRA BUDGET. YOU KNOW ITEMS
JUST TO YOU KNOW JUST TO MOVE
THIS POLICY FORWARD BUT THAT'S
LIKE SAYING SHE IS IT THE
STATE'S RESPONSE RESPONSIBILITY
TO CREATE. A BIKE NETWORK I MEAN
YOU SEE ME A BUS NETWORK OR
LIGHT RAIL NETWORK I MEAN WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT MOVING PEOPLE IN
THE MODERN TIMES AND HAVING SAY
ALTERNATIVE MET METHODS OF
TRANSPORTATION HAVING PEOPLE
BIKING WALKING PEDESTRIAN
FRIENDLY COMMUNITIES IS PART OF
CLIMATE REDUCTION I MEAN IT'S
ALL TIED TOGETHER. AS WE MOVE
FORWARD AND I WOULD ABSOLUTELY
IT'S THE STATE'S RESPONSIBILITY
TO MAKE SURE THAT THOSE FOLKS IN
A BIKE LANE OR JUST THE SAFE IS
THE PERSON ON THE BUS SO. I
ACCEPT THAT AND I THINK THAT'S A
GREAT ANSWER TO THE- TO MY
QUESTION BUT I GUESS THE
QUESTION IS IF THE STATE DOESN'T
COME UP WITH A GRANT LET'S SAY
FOR- SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY OR
RIVERSIDE COUNTY. ARE THEY GOING
TO BE HELD HARMLESS TO- YOU KNOW
FOR THIS PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION
BECAUSE IF THEY DON'T HAVE MONEY
TO COMPLETE THE PLAN. AND IN IT
DO WHAT THEY WERE TO DO BECAUSE
LOOK AT. THIS WAS VOTED ON
PRESUMABLY. BY STAKEHOLDERS
GROUPS IN EACH COMMUNITY. AND
ALSO ON TOP OF IT AND THE JORDY
OF THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS CITY
COUNCIL. IT'S SO IT'S NOT THAT
THEY DON'T WANT TO DO IT IT'S
JUST THEY DON'T HAVE THE
RESOURCES. MY ONLY CONCERN ABOUT
THIS BILLS AS PRIVATE RIGHT OF
ACTION. IT'S CENTER UNITE. HAD
NUMEROUS TEXT LAST NIGHT ON THIS
AND- I DON'T KNOW THAT I'M GONNA
BE MOVED AUDIT EXCEPT FOR.
YOU'RE NOT ON MY COUNTIES ARE
INCLUDED SO. THERE MAY BE A
BONUS VOTE HERE SOONER OR LATER
WHO KNOWS. THANK YOU SENATOR
DODD. BY THE WAY DID YOU NOTICE
THAT NONE OF YOUR COUNTIES ARE
INCLUDED. BUT BUT I DO REPRESENT
EVERYBODY OKAY THANK YOU SENATOR
DODD THANK HER AND SHE GOT UP.
THANK YOU OF BEING A FORMER
MAYOR OF THE CITY- IN IN A SMALL
CITY NINE SQUARE MILES WE
IMPLEMENTED THAT THE BIKE PATHS
AND SOME PEOPLE ARE HAPPY WITH
THE JOB OF THE REALLY UPSET.
DEPENDING THE TRAFFIC- AND THE
FLOW OF THE TRAFFIC BUT THE
MANDATE- THE ENTIRE THAT
MEDICARE WHEN YOU READ THAT
LISTEN I HEARD YOU SAY- LOS
ANGELES LOS ANGELES COUNTY IS
EXEMPT FROM THIS NO IS IT LIKE
LOOTED IT IT WILL BE INCLUDED.
WELL LOS ANGELES COUNTY IS QUITE
LARGE IN EVERY CITY IN AT THE- I
MEAN IT JUST A NUMBER OF CITIES.
MY KIDS WOULD BE. THE TO
IMPLEMENT THE PLAN- INTERCOURSE
AS WE HAVE HEARD WE'VE ALL KNOWN
THAT. THERE ARE SOME CITIES THAT
TAKE TEN YEARS FIFTEEN YEARS
EVEN TWENTY YEARS. TO UPDATE
THEIR PLANS IN SOME CASES- I
DON'T KNOW IF THEY ARE EVEN
FORESEE WHEN THAT THEY'RE GOING
TO DO IT. BUT NOW IT'LL BE A
VIOLATION OF LAW. IS THAT
CORRECT. THEY WILL PUT THEM
RESPONSIBLE IF THEY IF THEY AYE
IF THEY ADOPT A PLAN IDENTIFY
THE PROBLEMS AND THEN FAIL TO
ACT THEN THEY WILL BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE ACTIONS
TAKEN AGAINST THEM BUT AGAIN
THAT'S IMPORTANT. THEY HAVE TO
CREATE THE PLAN. IMPLEMENT THE
AND NOT SOLVE A PROBLEM SO
THEY'VE GOT TO UPGRADE THEIR
THEIR- GENERAL PLAN TO INCLUDE
THE BIKES BICYCLE PATHS AND SO
ON. BUT WHERE ARE THEY GOING TO
BE GUARANTEED THEY'RE GOING TO
GET THE MONEY. TO IMPLEMENT SOME
INFRASTRUCTURE ISSUES AND LESS
THEY FEEL THAT IT WILL CALM AND
YOU KNOW FIVE YEARS FROM NOW
WHATEVER IT IS TWO YEARS FROM
NOW. THANKS MY CHANGE AND WE
DON'T HAVE THE MONEY TO GIVE.
THEY'RE STILL IN VIOLATION SO
TWO THINGS A OBVIOUSLY I'M
TRYING TO. USE THIS
UNPRECEDENTED BUDGET SURPLUS TO
HELP IMPLEMENT INFRASTRUCTURE
IMPROVEMENTS B. WERE ALSO TRYING
TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS IS A
PRIORITY FOR THOSE CITIES. AND
YOU KNOW IN OUR AREA WHEN DOES
THE MORE RIDE BIKE TO MORE
COMMUNITIES I GO THROUGH ONE
CITY THAT'S DONE A GREAT JOB AND
I'M I'M GONNA GIVE A SHOUT OUT
TO ARCADIA I DON'T REPRESENT
ARCADIA BUT I WAS RIDING THROUGH
ARCADIA. LAST MONTH AND THEY'VE
USED THEIR RESOURCES AND AN
ENTIRE CITY WIDE BIKE. PLAN
THAT'S YOU KNOW. RIFIC NOW THERE
ARE ADJACENT COMMUNITIES THAT
AREN'T AS GOOD. THE WHOLE POINT
OF THIS IS TO NOT HAVE THOSE
PLANS SIT ON THE SHELF. MANY
CITIES AGAIN MY CITY HAS A SEVEN
YEAR. RESURFACING PROGRAM THEY
PRIORITIZE MAKING SURE THE
STREETS ARE WELL PAVED AND SO
THEY'VE SPLIT THE CITY INTO
SEVEN SECTIONS AND OVER A SEVEN
YEAR PERIOD EVERY SECTION GETS.
NEW SLURRY IN NEWCASTLE I MEAN
THEY'VE MADE IT UP ALREADY SO
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS MAKE
CITIES UNDERSTAND THAT AS WE
MOVE INTO THE- MODERN TIMES AND
MORE MORE PEOPLE ARE. TRADING IN
THEIR CARS ON EBAY LIKES AND
MORE MORE PEOPLE ARE WALKING AND
MORE MORE PEOPLE ARE WORKING
FROM HOME YOU KNOW WE SAW THAT
FOR THE- BACK. GOING ON THAT
WALK. JOB PATTERNS PEOPLE
PATTERNS HAVE CHANGED. AND OUR
PRIORITIES NEED TO CHANGE- WE
WERE BEEN A CAR ROAD CULTURE FOR
A HUNDRED YEARS. WE NEED TO. BE
THINKING ABOUTALTERNATIVE MODES
OF TRANSPORTATION AS WE BECOME
MORE CLIMATE FRIENDLY AND MORE
PEDESTRIAN FRIENDLY AND MORE
LOCALLY. ORIENTED IN OUR
COMMUTER PATTERNS AND SO IT'S A
COMBINATION OF LOCAL RESOURCES
AND PRIORITIES AND THEN THE
STATE OFFICE STEPPING UP WITH
THE RESPONSIBILITY OF THE LEGAL
ACTION IF YOU DON'T DO. I'VE
SEEN MIGHT. TO GET REALLY
EXCITED ABOUT THIS- NOW I'VE NO
YOUR HONOR IN IN SUBCOMMITTEE OF
FINANCING AND SO ON I COULD SEE
PERHAPS THE HELP THAT THE CITIES
WERE LOOKING FOR FINALLY
HAPPENED SO WITH THAT I'LL
SUPPORT THE BILL. THANK YOU. I
THINK I SEE ANY OTHER. SUPPORT
ANYONE ELSE LIKE TO SENATOR DOT.
WITH ALL DUE RESPECT TO THE BILL
AUTHOR- UPON FURTHER REVIEW THE
VOTERS VOTERS GOT AWAY BECAUSE
SACRAMENTO WHICH I REPRESENT
PART OF AND CONTRA COSTA- ON THE
LIST. SO THERE YOU HAVE A MINUTE
TALK TO MAYOR RIGHTS. WELL THANK
YOU FOR THE DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE MEMBERS- WHAT I WILL SAY
IS YOU KNOW IN TALKING TO
SENATOR PORTANTINO OF COURSE I
WAS A LITTLE STRUCK IT FIRST ON
ON THIS ISSUE PRIVATE RIGHT OF
ACTION FOR. TO BEGIN WITH AND
THEN WE IT TO THESE TEN COUNTY
SO THANK YOU WORKING ARKANSAS.
ON THAT- THE QUESTIONS REGARDING
START DATE ARE VERY VALID OF
COURSE FUNDING GUARANTEES WHICH
IS NEVER GUARANTEED IN TERMS OF
STATE DOLLARS IN FEDERAL DOLLARS
FOR TRANSPORTATION. BUT I THINK
IT PROVIDES US AN OPPORTUNITY TO
LOOK AT DEEP NEGLIGENCE IN OF.
THE AND COUNTIES THAT ARE
DEFINITELY NOT. KNOWING REACTING
TO THESE THIS NEED FOR VISION
ZERO FOR. PARK THAT'S I FOR TO
YOU.INTENDING TO DISCUSS NOT
JUST WITH OUR OFFICE ARE TEAM
ALSO WITH MR LEE IN TECH. AND
CITY. THAT GET THIS MOVING SO
WITH THAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO.
THANK YOU FOR RECESSION AND
MANAGER THANK YOU FOR YOUR-
INTEREST IN. AND PRUDENT
COMMENTS AT THERE IS A INHERENT
NEED TO DO THIS AND THERE'S AN
INHERENT RESPONSIBILITY THAT
COMES WITH IT BOTH FROM THE
STATE LEVEL AND A LOCAL LEVEL
AND WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
CENTER PORTANTINO WE HAVE A
MOTION ON SB NINE THIRTY TWO.
SENATOR MAN. SO CENTER IN THANK
YOU FOR THE MOTION MISTER CHIEF
CONSULTANT CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. WITH ONE SB SEVEN
THIRTY TO THE MOTION IS DUE PASS
AS AMENDED AND WE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
SENATORS GONZALEZ HI GONZALEZ I
BATES. BATES NO ALAN. ARCHULETA
ARCHULETA I BAKER. CORTESE DOLLY
DELANO DOT. LIMON LIMON HIGH
WIRE MELENDEZ MEN ARE MEN HI
NEWMAN NEWMAN HIGH RUBIO.
SKINNER WHY CASKEY WILK. FIVE
TWO OKAY WE HAVE FIVE TO LEAVE
THE BILL ON CALL THANK YOU
SENATOR SENATOR WAS A WELCOME AG
YOU'RE HERE TO PRESENT FILE ITEM
THREE SB TWO. FIFTEEN WE CAN
THANK. MICHAEL THIS. THANK YOU A
CHAIR MEMBERS- I'D LIKE TO-
BEGAN FIRST OF ALL BY ACCEPTING
THE AMENDMENTS THAT- OF COURSE
WE- IS A PROPOSED TO THE SENATE
ENERGY UTILITIES AND
COMMUNICATIONS I THANK THE
COMMITTEE. FOR WORKING WITH US
ON THAT BOB THIS BILL SB TEN
FIFTEEN. IS AN EFFORT TO ENSURE
THAT OUR BUSIEST COMMERCIAL LAND
PORT OF ENTRY THE ULTIMATE
SALANTER OF ENTRY IS NOT
OVERLOOKED IN OUR STATE'S
EFFORTS BENSON ZERO AND NEAR
ZERO. VEHICLE CHARGING THIS IS.
OTHER IMPORTANT. INFRASTRUCTURE
RESOURCE FOR OUR STATE IT'S A
MAJOR PORT OF ENTRY ANDAS WE
SPEAK TODAY REALLY THERE ARE
NONE THERE IS NO INFRASTRUCTURE
TOOK TO SUPPORT OUR ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES ELECTRIC
VEHICLES- AND FRANKLY WHEN YOU
HEAR THAT MANY AUTO
MANUFACTURERS ARE NOW PROJECTING
OUT INTO THE FUTURE THAT THEY
WILL NO LONGER. EVEN MANUFACTURE
GAS VEHICLES. OR PETROLEUM BASED
CO COMBUSTION VEHICLES. THAT
THEY WILL COMMIT THEMSELVES TO
ONLY RENEWABLE ENERGY. THE RACES
ON IN OUR STATE TO TRY AND
PROVIDE THAT INFRASTRUCTURE
ACROSS THE STATE TO SUPPORT THE
NEW THE VEHICLES OF THE FUTURE.
TEN FIFTEEN WERE FUNDING FOR NEW-LIGHT MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY ZERO
MISSION AND NEAR ZERO EMISSION
INFRASTRUCTURE TO THE STATE'S
BUSIEST COMMERCIAL LAND PORT OF
ENTRY DEAL TIME MAY SELECT ONE
OF ENTRY. FROM THE CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAMMER
FEDERAL MONIES FOR THE PURPOSE
SO- THIS BILL HELPS ENSURE THAT
STATE EFFORTS TO FUND ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLE CHARGING
TECHNOLOGY. WILL ALSO BE
DIRECTED AT THE ULTIMATE SUPPORT
OF ENTRY IN ADDITION TO OTHER
SPOTS AROUND THE WORLD AND
OUTSIDE COMMENTED THIS IS-
CALIFORNIA HAS SOME OF THE MOST
TRAVERSED PORTS OF ENTRY ALONG
THE BORDER. AND THIS WILL HELP
US TO ACHIEVE OUR GET CLOSER TO
OUR STATE SCHOOLS TO PROVIDE
THAT INFRASTRUCTURE TO PROVIDE
FOR THOSE VEHICLES. GREAT THANK
YOU SENATOR WESSEL- SO YOU HAVE
IN YOUR LEAD WITNESS IN SUPPORT
S. B. FOR SB TEN FIFTEEN IS
ALEXANDER I'M YETI TO RUN
MEDITATE ON YES OKAY- SHE'S WITH
THE- TIME MAY START CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE MODERATOR SHE'S ON THE
COASTLINE. MISTER CALDERON
MISSED THAT ON. YEAH. WE HAVE AT
LEAST FOUR THOUSAND FIVE ROUGHLY
EVERY SPECIAL. I THINK THAT THE
NUMBER OF BLACK. YEAH OKAY THAT
ON ITS LITTLE BIT HARD TO YOU.
OR. REPORT OF A THREE. NO RATE
WE HAVE IF. IT'S OKAY YOU'LL-
PRACTICE IN OUR PART OF IT THAT
THE PROPOSED PART. RBC YEAR THAT
THE MARKET WILL TAKE CARE OF
THEIR INCOME AT THE THAT WE THAT
NOT THE CASE THEY ARE VERY
UNIQUE CROSS BORDER AREA OKAY
THANK VERY MUCH EDITOR WEST THAT
BECAUSE OUR BRAVE I'VE.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS READ
OUT US ON BEHALF OF THE ELECTRIC
VEHICLE CHARGING ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT HERE IN THE
GALLERY. C. NINE SO WE'LL TAKE
IT BACK TO THE TELECONFERENCE
LINE MODERATOR ANYONE ELSE IN
THE QUEUE WOULD LIKE TO SUPPORT
SB TEN FIFTEEN. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR IF ANYONE IS IN SUPPORT OF
SB TEN FIFTEEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE
NO LINES IN SUPPORT PLEASE
CONTINUE. THANK YOU AND THERE IS
NO- LEAD ITNESS IN OPPOSITION
SO WE'LL TAKE IT BACK TO THE
GALLERY ANYONE IN THE GALLERY
HERE WHO'D LIKE TO OPPOSE SB TEN
FIFTEEN PLEASE. SEE NON
MODERATOR WILL TAKE IT BACK TO
YOU FOR ANYONE WHO'D LIKE TO
OPPOSE SB TEN FIFTEEN PLEASE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR IF ANYBODY
WOULD LIKE TO QUOTE SB TEN
FIFTEEN PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND THERE ARE
NO LINES IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
CONTINUE. GREAT THANK YOU ANYONE
ELSE- SO WE'LL TAKE BACK TO THE
DIETS AND SENATORS MEMBERS WOULD
LIKE TO. DISCUSS SENATE TO LET
UP. YES THANK YOU. CENTER I'M
HOPING THAT IN THE FUTURE AT THE
AMENDMENT MIGHT ALSO INCLUDE
FUEL CELL HYDROGEN BATTERIES
BECAUSE THAT IS PART OF THE
FUTURE AS WELL BECAUSE THIS BILL
PERTAINS TO THE FUTURE. BUT
WOULD YOU WALK ME THROUGH-
HYPOTHETICALLY IF THIS WERE TO
HAPPEN WHERE WOULD THIS THE
INFRASTRUCTURE BE TO ACCOMMODATE
PEOPLE COMING IN OR GOING OUT OF
THE BORDER- WHICH HOPEFULLY
WOULD INCLUDE HYDROGEN FUEL CELL
BATTERIES AS WELL. SO GENERALLY
THERE ARE FACILITIES IN AROUND
THE BORDER THAT- SUPPORT- THERE
ARE- SOME PARKING LOTS THERE ARE
SOME. AREAS WHERE PEOPLE CAN
VISIT OR PICK UP PASSENGERS.
EVERY OF WHETHER YOU'RE COMING
IN THROUGH THE- THROUGH THE
MEXICO OR ENTRY INTO THE U. S.
THERE ARE CERTAIN FACILITY SO
THE IDEA IS THAT. THIS BILL
WOULD. DIRECT THE OF. THE
WORKING THE PC IN THERE IT'S
REALLY A COMMISSION- I'M FROM
SOUTHERN I'M BLANKING ON THE
NAME IT'S THE CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM. THAT
ALREADY EXISTS IN THERE THEY
WORK ON- CREATING ASSESSMENTS OF
THE REALLY THEY WOULD GO DO A
VISIT. AND LOOK AT AND ANALYZE
THE BEST LOCATIONS TO GET YOU
KNOW THE BEST OF BANG FOR THE
BUCK- AND NOT RULING OUT OF.
SOME SOME REAL STORY HAVE FUEL-
VEHICLE FUEL OF. AND KIND OF A
TRUCK STOP AGHAST OR SOMEWHERE
THEY COULD CITE IT WHERE PEOPLE
COULD STOP. AND FUEL UP. AND SO-
THIS BILL DOESN'T SPECIFY
SPECIFIC LOCATION BUT IT
DISTRICTS INSTRUCTION DEPARTMENT
TO MOVE FORWARD AND FIND NOT
ONLY THE RESOURCES BUT THE
LOCATION AND PROGRAM AND AGAIN I
WOULD APPRECIATE THE WORDING
FUELCELL ENERGY OR FUEL CELL A
HYBRID BATTERY SAYS AS PART OF
IT WELL AM I ONE OF THE SPOT THE
SPONSOR OF THE BILL OF SALE TIME
IS A CHAMBER OF COMMERCE. AND
THEIR- REALLY INVOLVED IN ALMOST
EVERY ASPECT OF PLANNING THE-
TIE MESA COMMUNITY PROVIDING
SUPPORT TO- TIME BASIC
COMMUNITIES LARGELY A COMMERCIAL
INDUSTRIAL AREA WITH SOME
EXCEPTIONS THERE ARE SOME
HOUSING BUT IT'S MAINLY IF YOU
CAN IMAGINE LIKE A CITY OF
COMMERCE TYPE OF. AREA IT'S A
IT'S A PART OF THE CITY OF SAN
DIEGO IN THE COUNTY OF SAN DIEGO
THAT'S LARGELY COMMERCIAL
INDUSTRIAL MANUFACTURING- TIME
MESA CHAMBER AT BEEN A IMPORTANT
ELEMENT AND HELPING TO PLAN AND
DEVELOP THIS AREA SO THEY I
THINK THEY'LL BE A VERY
IMPORTANT STRETCH STAKEHOLDER AT
IDENTITY IN THE RESOURCE AND
BEING. TO TRY TO MAKE SURE THAT
IS NOT SURE I THINK A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO START
LOOKING FORWARD- TO PROTECT OUR
ENVIRONMENT AND- A MOVE IT AT A
PROPER TIME THANK YOU CENTER
ARCHULETA AND YOU KNOW WHETHER
MAKES UP I JUST WANNA THANK YOU
AS WELL SENATOR WES AFFIRMING
REALLY STRATEGIC AROUND ARE OUR
BUSIEST PORTS WHICH HAVE THE
HIGHEST EMISSIONS THANK YOU
BRING WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE BY
JUST SIMPLY ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
TODAY THANK YOU GREAT THANK YOU
SO WE'VE GOT TO A MOTION BY
SENATOR TO LEAD ON SB. TEN
FIFTEEN MISTER CHIEF CONSULTANT
CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS PASS AMANDA AND WE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. SENATORS
GONZALEZ I CONSULT BY BATES.
ALLEN ARCHULETA ART ARCHULETA
BAKER CORTESE. DOLLY DOLLY NOW
DOT DOT I. LIMÓN. LIMON AYE
MCGUIRE MELENDEZ MAN MAN I
NEWMAN NEWMAN I FEEL SKINNER BY
CASKEY WILK. SIX ONE THREE SIX
ONE LEAVE THE BILL ON CALL THANK
YOU SENATOR WESSEL SO WE'LL MOVE
ONTO YOUR NEXT BILL FILE ITEM
FOR SB ELEVEN SIXTY NINE STATE
ROUTE ONE TWENTY FIVE TOLL ROADS
THANK YOU- AND CHAIR MEMBERS- SB
ELEVEN SIXTY NINE IS A BILL THAT
SEEKS TO RETIRE THE SOUTH BAY
EXPRESS EXPRESSWAY STATE ROUTE
ONE TWENTY FIVE LOCATED IN THE
SOUTHEAST SENEGAL- PORTION OF
THE COUNTY. OF OR THE SOUTHEAST
PORTION OF SAN DIEGO COUNTY.
THIS THIS TOLL ROAD WAS
ACTUALLY- THE PLANNING STARTED
IN THE NINETIES WHEN. WHEN
NINETEEN NINETIES WHEN. THE
STATE WAS SPEAKS SEE SIGNIFICANT
. UP BUDGETARY SHORTFALLS IN
ACTUALLY THROUGHOUT THE PROCESS
OF THE BUILDING OF THIS ROAD THE
STATE HAS ALWAYS HAD. BUDGETARY
PROBLEMS. OF THROUGH THOSE YEARS
IT WAS A PRIVATE COMPANY IN
AUSTRALIAN COMPANY THAT CAME IN
AND INVESTED SEVEN HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS TO BUILD THIS
ROAD AND IT WASN'T IN BUSINESS
VERY LONG FROM THE DAY IT
OPENED. THE USER SHIP- MOST OF
BECAUSE A LOT OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING CONSCIOUS COUNTRY IN THE
SOUTHERN PART OF SAN DIEGO
ESPECIALLY THESE COMMUNITIES ON
THE SOUTH A SOUTHERN PART OF THE
COUNTY. ARE OFTEN THE
COMMUNITIES OF THE MOST
SUCCESSFUL OF PROVIDING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR THE
PEOPLE OF SAN DIEGO SO. BUT
THERE REALLY WASN'T THE ECONOMIC
BASE ESPECIALLY DURING- DURING
EACH ADULT TOUGH ECONOMIC TIMES
TO SUPPORT THE WHOLE. BUT THEY
SOUTH BAY HAS GROWN ENORMOUSLY.
AND NOW HAS A MILLION PEOPLE
LIVING IN THE SOUTH BAY. THEY
ARE IF YOU ADD THE BILL TO
VILLAGE BUSIEST. LAND PORTS OF
ENTRY AT THE BORDER. AND IF YOU
ADD THE BUSIEST TRUCK TRUCK.
TRUCK CROSSING. IN THE
CALIFORNIA BORDER. YOUR SEEN HOW
LIMITED FREEWAYS IN THE SOUTH
THEY ARE REALLY NOT ENOUGH TO
SUPPORT. UP THAT THE COMING AND
GOING TO THE PEOPLE OF THAT
REGION SO THIS IT'S SAD TO GO
DOWN THE FREEWAY FIVE. DURING
RUSH HOUR DURING ANYTIME OF THE
DAY AND SEEN JUST LOTS OF
TRAFFIC AND THEN GETTING ON THE
ONE TWENTY FIVE AND SEE THAT
IT'S COMPLETELY EMPTY. AND IT'S
JUST A RESOURCE- THE OFF SEVEN
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR RESOURCE
THAT IS NOT REALLY. SERVING THIS
THE NEEDS OF THE SOUTH BAY IN
THE ECONOMY OF THE SOUTH BAY IN
THE OVERALL ECONOMY OF
CALIFORNIA. BECAUSE THIS THESE
CORRIDORS ARE SO IMPORTANT TO
GOODS MOVEMENT. SO THIS BILL
LOOKS TO ANALYZE THE
POSSIBILITIES. OF WHAT THE STATE
CAN DO TO TAKE OVER THE
OPERATION OF THIS HIGHWAY AS IT
SHOULD HAVE ORIGINALLY. TO
SUPPORT THE GROWTH OF THE HOUSE
THE SOUTH BAY TO SUPPORT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING THE SOUTH BAY
THE ECONOMY OF THE STATE. BUT
THE STE THE STATE COULDN'T DO AT
THE TIME BECAUSE OF ITS LIMITED
BUDGETARY- THE PROBLEMS SO-
WE'RE GONNA. I APPRECIATE THE
SUPPORT OF THE CHAIR AND
ALLOWING ME TO. CONSIDER THIS
AND THEN IT BRING THIS TO THE
ATTENTION OF CALTRANS THE STATE
AS A WHOLE. TO REALLY LOOK AT
THE IMPORTANCE OF THIS HIGHWAY
TO THE OVERALL STATE OF
CALIFORNIAN WHY. IT NEEDS TO
BECOME PART OF THE REGULAR PLAN
FOR MOBILITY IN THE SOUTH BUT
FOR THE PEOPLE OF SOUTH BAY AND
FOR ALL OF CALIFORNIA MANASSE
FOR YOUR SUPPORT. I HAVE WITH ME
I THINK OF THE MAYOR OF CHULA
VISTA. MERRY SALAS AND- BE
CHÁVEZ TO DIRECTOR OF
ENGINEERING BILL BY IT ARE I
BELIEVE ARE ON THE LINE TO-
SHARE SOME COMMENTS. THANK YOU
SENATOR WEST SOME WE HAVE MEREKA
CSI LASTS FROM THE CITY OF CHULA
VISTA I'M A CO HOST LINE
MODERATOR. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENATOR WENT THOUGH FOR
INTRODUCING S. B. ELEVEN FIFTY
NINE I MERRY SALAS THE MAYOR OF
THE CITY OF CHILDREN THAT. THANK
YOU TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE.
THIS BILL IT'S AN IMPORTANT STEP
TOWARD THREE WITH PAUL ON THE
ONLY ROAD. THE ONLY FILL ROAD
AND EAGLE COUNTY. IT'S IMPORTANT
RECOGNIZE THE EFFORTS THAT
CREATED THE SOUTH THE
EXPRESSWAY. IT WAS AN INNOVATIVE
PUBLIC PRIVATE PARTNERSHIP THAT
BROUGHT TOGETHER FUNDING TO
DEVELOP THIS IMPORTANT REGIONAL
ROADWAY. BUT IT WAS NOT SUPPOSED
TO BE A TOLL ROAD FOR AFTER. HE
CITY PARTNER WITH A CALIFORNIA
THANK CALTRANS. TWO THOUSAND
THREE BUT CHILDREN THE DEDICATED
TWO HUNDRED AND SEVENTY ACRES OF
RIGHT OF WAY TO THE STATE FOR
THE DEVELOPMENT. OF THE S. R.
ONE TWENTY FIVE. THE COUNTRY
WITH CRITICAL TO THE- PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIP TO BUILD THE TOLD.
THE TEN MILES SOUTH TAKE. OPENED
IN TWO SEVEN THIS HIGHWAY
SECTION RUNS FROM- TIME MESA
ROAD NEAR THE EIGHT ROUTE NINE
OH FIVE STATE ROUTE FIFTY FOUR.
IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT CONNECTED TO
THE UNIT THE NEW U. S. MEXICO
BORDER CROSSING UNDER
CONSTRUCTION IN THE EAST- TIME
MAY FIFTH IS EXPECTED TO OPEN.
IN. TWENTY TWENTY FOUR. IN TWO
THOUSAND SAN TOOK THE ADVANTAGE
OF A GREAT OPPORTUNITY TO BUY TO
TWELVE ROAD. FINANCIAL BUT THE
IMPACT OF REMOVING THE TOLLS IN
THE FUTURE YEARS. METASTATIC
COULD REDUCE THE NUMBER OF
ADDITIONAL LANES PLAN FOR
INTERSTATE EIGHT OH FIVE THROUGH
THE SOUTH BAY. THE SOUTH BAY. IS
CURRENTLY THE ONLY HOPE OF TOLL
ROAD CAN GET THE ACCOUNT. AS A
RESULT RATHER THAN REDUCING
CONGESTION ON OUR FREEWAYS. WE
HAVE CREATED CONGESTION ON OUR
LOCAL STREETS AS DRIVERS
MANEUVERED TO INTERSTATE FIVE
FOUR ANDERSON OR EIGHT OH FIVE
FOR THEIR DAILY COMMUTE. IN THE
SOUTH EXPRESSWAY HAS NOT
PROVIDED TRAFFIC RELEASED
PROJECTED. WE HAVE CREATED
SOCIAL IN EQUITY AND
ENVIRONMENTL JUSTICE CHALLENGES
. WE HAVE COMMUTERS DRIVING
LONGER DISTANCES TO AVOID CALL
TOLL JOBSEEKERS CONCERNED ABOUT
THE ADDITIONAL COST OF WORKING
AT THE BUSINESS LOCATED OFF TOLL
ROADS AND INCREASED GREENHOUSE
EMISSIONS THE PRODUCT FREEWAYS
AND CITY STREETS. AND IT DOES
NOT JUST CHILDREN THE BURDEN
RESIDENTS THROUGHOUT THE SOUTH
THEY ARE NEGATIVELY AFFECTED BY
PAYING TOLLS TO GET TO AND FROM
WORK SCHOOL SHOPPING AND OTHER
ACTIVITIES. THE SOUTH EXPRESS
WITHOUT POLL WOULD REDUCE. BY
DIVERSIFYING TO MEET. AND A TOLL
FREEWAY EASTER CHILLED THE
FEDERAL ALSO INCREASE TOLL FREE
FREEWAY IN THE FINANCIAL WITHOUT
WILL ALSO INCREASE ACCESS AMONG.
INDUSTRIAL. COMMERCIAL AND
RESIDENTIAL AREAS. WE APPRECIATE
PRESS COMMITTEE CONSIDERING THAT
THE PORT LEGISLATION I URGE YOU
TO PASS HIS OUT OF COMMITTEE SO
WE CAN CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
RELEVANT STAKEHOLDERS AS A
SENATOR AND OTHER PARTNERS BURKE
FIVE CREATING CONSENSUS. IN THIS
DIEGO REGIONAL TRANSPORTATION.
AT WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
I. BOATS BUT SB ELEVEN SIXTY
NINE THANK YOU THANK YOU MAYOR
SALAS- NEXT WE'LL MOVE ON TO
BILL BY IT THE CITY OF CHULA
VISTA ON THE COAST LINE AS WELL. THANK YOU MA'AM CHAIRED A
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND THE HUESO-
THE OPPORTUNITIES BE DONE AT
ELEVEN. NINE AM ABOUT THE VALUE
OF THE DIRECTOR OF ENGINEERING
FOR THE CITY TO LOOK AT THE-
INVOLVED WITH THAT ABOUT ONE
TWENTY FIVE FULL PROJECT. THAT
TO. MY TWENTY NINE YEARS OLD
PLAN WITH HELP FROM THE FIFTH
ELEVEN DOWN HERE IN THE AREA
DURING. THE PUBLIC PART OF
PARTNERSHIP BUT THAT WAS TO THE
FACILITY THE FACT THAT- THE TOLL
. THEY'RE THEY'RE GONNA. BUT A
LACK YEARS HERE AT THE CITY FEEL
THAT THE- TO YOU KNOW MY IT STOP
. AGREEMENT ALL INVOLVED- ISRAEL
TWENTY FIVE NO DIFFERENT THAN.
OTHER ROADWAYS THAT MAKE UP THE
PILING UP. THE TOLL ROAD. ACTION
OF THAT BUT ONCE WE FIVE PLANNED
KNOW THE NAY FREEWAY. THANK YOU
FIFTY NINE HOWEVER- MENTIONED
EARLIER. IN ONLY BE THOU WAS
CLEARLY BECAUSE OF A LACK FUNDS
. AND OTHER GROUPS PRIORITY THE
STUFF WOULD NOT LIKELY BE FOR
MANY YEARS. SO THROUGH THE
LETTER- THE STATE IT POP. FOR
PUBLIC PRIVATE PARTNERSHIP. AND
THE FUN CONSTRUCTION OF A ROAD
EARLIER THE IT IS- ALLOWING TO
COLLECT TOLD CENTER AGREEMENT
FRIENDS. THE THIRTIETH WHICH
PART OF THE A LEVEL TWENTY FIVE-
OUT EVEN TO THE- OF ACQUIRING
JONES EIGHT OF THE RIGHT OF WAY-
THAT WOULD BE JUST FUTURE OF THE
PROJECT. UPPALA THAT BUT THREE
FIVE YOU KNOW THE GUY BUILT TO
ENACT A RESIDENTIAL THANK OF THE
SPECIAL THAT THE- MAJOR
INDUSTRIAL AREA FOR THE TWO OF
THE THAT. AND PRIMARY NINE
EFFECT BEFORE PREVENCI- ATTEND-
AND- TO THE RESTAURANT WE WILL
TRANSPORTATION NETWORK. AND
MISSED OUT THEY DID ONE OF THE
FACT IN THE DECISION. MADE AS A
PART IN THAT GET ACTIVATIONS
FRENCH OF. AGREEMENT TOWLEROAD.
THE ELIMINATION OF TUMORS. IT
SHOULD BE A ONE PLAN PRIOR PHI
FOR THAT. ON THE NINETY TWO
MILLION FUNDS AND THAT OUT THE-
IS STATING FIVE WITH THAT YOU TO
HELP. FIVE TWENTY FIVE.
THAT IS REALLY UNPARALLELED
HIGHWAYS AND LOOKS LIKE HE'LL
NEVER MATERIALIZED SO TODAY.
SHOW THAT THE STREET IS THE
DIFFICULT WE IMPACTED WITH
TRAFFIC THE MORNING OUT TWO
YEARS. SOMETIMES ON WEEKENDS OF
PRIVACY HAS LEFT IN THE- ELECT
TO TAKE THE EIGHT OH FIVE OF THE
FIVE WHICH ARE FREE RELATED
MONTEL. SO THESE. UNFORTUNATELY
WHAT THE PRICE FOLDER AND
OPERATE EXPERIENCE STOP EXPRESS
EXPRESSWAY. AT THE PUBLIC OUT
THAT- CONTINUED TO UNDERPERFORM
. THE DEVELOPER THAT. BOTH
EFFORTS STRATEGIC PARTNERSHIP.
DROVE THE BUILDING OF THE FOR
THE NATIONALLY. STILL IS AN
IMPORTANT STEP FOR THE USED TO
TEACH EFFORT I THINK YOU TO
REMOVE THE GOAL THE BETTER
TRAFFIC. HELLO OUT THE AND THE
SOCIAL NETWORK WITH BUT WERE
PREVIOUSLY. FOR WORKING WITH
THEM VALLEY I'M GONNA TO ASK YOU
TO WRAP UP HERE THEY YOU VERY
MUCH. CAN JUST HAVE YOU WRAP UP
YOUR COMMENTS THANK YOU. THIRTY
WHICH IS ARE WE ARE. SUPPORT THE
OUT OF COMMITTEE BUT WE CONTINUE
TO WORK. HUESO OTHER ETHICAL
DISTRICT. THAT THE TOP OF MY
TWENTY FIVE TO PROPER. LEGAL WE
HAVE TO VOTE ON AT THE ELEVENTH
. NINE THANK YOU FOR TEST MISTER
BY THANK YOU FOR MUCH WE THINK.
OUR LEAD TEST. AND SO WE'LL MOVE
IT BACK THE GALA. ARE THERE ANY
WAY. WHO LIKE TO TELL. AND HERE.
SB ELEVEN SIXTY NINE. C. NINE
WILL IT BACK TO TELECOM. LINE A
MODERATOR DO YOU HAVE ANYONE IN
THE LINE WHO'D LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT. OF S. B. C. ELEVEN
SIXTY NINE PLEASE. THANK YOU
MADAM AND GENTLEMEN IF WOULD
LIKE TO COME. WORK OKAY THE
HOBBIT SIXTY NINE. YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AT THEN ZERO THIS TIME. THE
TICKET IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT
THAT THE COURT AT THE OLYMPICS
NINE. YOU MAY PRESS ONE. AT THE
ZERO. FIVE ONE SEVEN SIX. YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON FOR FIFTEEN
ADDRESS HELLO WITH FIVE
RECLINING FEATURE SET THEORY
ENVIRONMENTAL ORGANIZATION AND I
AM CALLING IN TO SUPPORT ALL OF
THE BILL COULD IMPROVE I CAN
PEDESTRIAN SAFETY SB NINE THREE
TWO. AS WELL AS THE C. TEN
FIFTEEN VEHICLE CHARGING A CORK
AND FORK TWENTY SIX FOR
NONPROFIT CORPORATIONS ALLY WITH
GOVERNMENT AID THEM EVEN JUST ON
AT ELEVEN SIXTY NINE AT THIS
POINT YOU HAVE A SUPPORT. FOR
THAT BILL BY CHANCE. I'M NOT
ACTUALLY NOT SURE WHAT THAT ONE
BUT I'M SUPPORTING A LOT. HELP
DO WITH THE ENTIRE OKAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH RIGHT NOW-
MODERATOR WE ARE IN SB ELEVEN
SIXTY NINE THAT IS FILE ITEM FOR
MY SENATOR WESSEL D. OF ANYONE
ON THE LINE WHO IS IN SUPPORT OF
THE- BILL PLEASE. NINE NINETY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO NAPKIN COMMITTEE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME TODAY MY
NAME IS OF THE FACT TELL YET I
AM THE DIRECTOR OF PHILANTHROPY
FOR CHRISTMAS. AND WE ARE VERY
MUCH IN SUPPORT AT S. B. ELEVEN
SIXTY NINE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AGAIN. THANK YOU NEXT
COMMENT PLEASE. WE HAVE NO FOR
THE COMMONSENSICAL OF S. ELEVEN
SIXTY NINE THANK YOU MODERATOR
SO WE'LL TAKE IT TO OPPOSITION
THERE'S NO ONE- AS A LEAD-
TESTIFY ARE IN OPPOSITION ANYONE
IN THE GALLERY WHO'D LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB
ELEVEN SIXTY NINE. SEEN NONE
WE'LL TAKE IT BACK TO THE
MODERATOR ANYONE WHO'D LIKE TO
OPPOSE SB ELEVEN SIXTY NINE ON
THE LINE PLEASE. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN.
IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION TO THE SP OF LEVIN
FIFTY NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE.
AND THEN ZERO FIVE. BUT TO GET
IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT YOU'RE A
POSITION OF S. B. ELEVEN FIFTY
NINE. ONE AND THEN THERE. YOU
HAVE TO ACCOMMODATE OPPOSITION
ELEVEN SIXTY NINE THANK YOU
MODERATOR SO WE'LL TAKE IT BACK
TO THE DYESS ANY SENATORS
MEMBERS WOULD LIKE TO DISCUSS SB
ELEVEN SIXTY NINE. SENATOR
DOLLY. I'M OVER HERE TEASING
WOMEN OUT SO. THE COMPANY THAT
BUILT THE TO THE TAXPAYERS TO IS
ARE THE TAXPAYERS OR THE OR THE-
WHO'S ON THE HOOK FOR THE- THE
MAINTENANCE AND- SO CAN YOU GIVE
ME A LITTLE BACKGROUND HISTORY
ON WHAT. WHAT WILL HAPPEN WITH
THE WITH THE PEOPLE THAT BUILT
THE ROAD IN. WELL THE COMPANY
THAT BUILT THE ROAD THE LOSERS
WERE THE INVESTORS RIGHT THEY
INVESTED SEVEN HUNDRED MILLION
HOPING THAT THEY COULD- GET A
PROFIT OF THIS THEY COMPLETELY
WENT OUT OF BUSINESS- THEY SOLD.
THEY PUT THE TOLL ROAD UP FOR
SALE THERE WERE NO TAKERS SO-
SANDAG WHICH IS THE PLANNING
ORGANIZATION MATHS AND YOU'LL
FIND A WAY. TO PURCHASE SAID
THEY'VE BEEN OPERATING AT. AND
INITIALLY IT THE GOAL IS ALWAYS
TO MAKE IT EVEN WHEN IT WAS
BUILT ORIGINALLY THE IDEA WAS
THAT EVENTUALLY WOULD BECOME A
PUBLIC HIGHWAY. SANDAG ONLY MADE
POSSIBLE THAT THAT COULD HAPPEN
SOONER. THERE IS A BOND THAT
THEY RAISED THAT WITHOUT BOND-
IT IT HAS CERTAIN IMPROVEMENTS
WILL NEED TO BE MADE INTO THE
OFF HIGHWAY GOING FORWARD THAT
IS ALREADY FOR THE MONETARY
BUDGET IT. IT'S ALREADY THERE
MONIES THERE. IT ALSO INCLUDES
MONEY FOR MAINTENANCE. SO TO THE
EXTENT THAT THE STATE COULD COME
AND LOOK AT HOW THEY CAN
SUPPORT. EITHER UP. CLOSE- SHE-
THE PERIOD OF CLOSURE COULD COME
ON COME ON LINE A LOT SOONER IS
A FREE AYE WAY. OR AT LEAST HELP
IN A WAY TO SUPPORT. REDUCING
TOLLS SO THAT MORE PEOPLE CAN
AFFORD TO USE IT- ANYTHING LIKE
THAT WOULD WOULD BE A WIN IN
TERMS OF THIS REGARD TO THIS
BILL LEAVES IT. OPEN SO THAT
THAT CAN BE CONSIDERED AS THOSE
OF THIS BILL WILL NOT
AUTOMATICALLY. ATTACH A
TRANSLATE INTO THAT BUT IT IT
WILL. HOPEFULLY BREAK MAKE THIS
A PRIORITY FOR THE STATE. AND
IN. THAT IN A WAY THAT WON'T
DISRUPT. THE COUNTIES AND
CONTINUED INVESTMENTS INTO THEIR
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURES.
ONE MORE QUESTION SO THROUGH WAS
AT SANDAG THAT FLOATED THE BONDS
AND FOR THE YES TOOL YES OKAY.
AND THE STATE WON'T BE ON THE
HOOK FOR THAT NOT. I MEAN THE
IDEA IS THAT THE STATE COULD-
REYES EITHER SOME FUNDS TO PAY
INTO THAT OR- PAY INTO KIND OF
REDO HELPING TO REDUCE THE BOND
OR EVEN PAY OFF THE BOND. ABOUT
CURRENTLY IS STILL A TOLL ROAD
YOU HAVE TO PAY TO BE ON IT'S A
TOLL ROAD AND LIKE S. AS
MENTIONED IT'S REALLY NOT
PERFORMING. TO ITS INTENDED.
GOALS THAT'S UNDERPERFORMING IF
IT IF THIS I MEAN FOR THE MATCH
IN THE VALLEY OF THE STATE THE
STATE DIDN'T HAVE TO INVEST
SEVEN HUNDRED MILLION IN
BUILDING A HIGHWAY THAT WAS
ALREADY WITHIN THE STATE'S.
RESPONSIBILITIES AND I MEAN THE
FACT THAT THEY WENT TO PRIVATE
ROUTE JUST BASICALLY REDUCE THE
COST BY HALF AND NOW E'RE
LOOKING AT. NOW THE COST BEING
HALF OF THE HALF AND SO. WE'RE
EXPLORING. THE POSSIBILITY. THE
STATE FINALLY MAKING TRUE TO HIS
PROMISES AND- OPERATING THIS AS
INITIALLY INTENDED. GREAT THANK
YOU SENATOR DOLLY. SENATOR
BATES- SENATOR HUESO I'M STILL A
LITTLE CONFUSED WE HAVE A NUMBER
OF TOLL ROADS IN ORANGE COUNTY
AS YOU'RE AWARE AND IT'S ALWAYS
ABOUT TO THE COST OF TOOLS GOING
UP TO ACTUALLY MEET THE BOND
DEBT REQUIREMENTS IN THS
SPECIFICALLY SAYS THAT THE BOND
IT WILL BE A HUNDRED AND FORTY
THREE POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLARS- AS OF THAT DATE. IT
DOES NOT HAVE PROJECTED THEY
WOULD HAVE THE FUNDS AVAILABLE
TO RETIRED THE BOND OUT AT THAT
TIME SO TOOLS WOULD HAVE TO
CONTINUE TO PAY OFF THE BOND
DEBT OR THERE MIGHT BE ASSUME BY
THE STATE TO PAY THAT OFF AND
THOSE WOULD BE TAXPAYER DOLLARS
CRAMPED. BECAUSE YOU'RE GONNA
TAKE THE TOLLS ARE WHICH IS THE
PURPOSE OF THE BILL TO ENCOURAGE
TRANSIT INTO ACROSS THAT. TO
LISTEN TO ENCOURAGE SENATE-
CALTRAIN NOT IT'S NOT A
STATUTORY CLOSURE. YEAH BECAUSE
THAT I THINK THAT PART IS THE
PROBLEMATIC PART THAT THE STATE
DOES ACCEPT RESPONSIBILITY FOR
RETIRING THE BONDS AND FOR THE
WOULD HAVE TO MAINTAIN THE ROAD
ALSO BECAUSE THERE'S A CONTRACT
THERE RIGHT. OKAY AND JUST TO
PROVIDE SOME CLARIFICATION YOU
ALSO REPRESENTS AN EAGLE YU
KNOW SEND YOU JUST HAVE TOLD
THAT THIS IS THE ONLY ONE AND IT
THE DIFFERENCE- OUGHT WHEN I WAS
ON THE COASTAL COMMISSION AND
WE'RE LOOKING AT SOME OF THE
HIGHWAY PROPOSAL'S. TOLL
PROPOSALS TO ORANGE COUNTY WHEN
I'VE SOUGHT SEEN THE ALIGNMENTS
LIKE THE- WHAT IS IT THE SEVENTY
THREE THAT'S THE TOLL ROAD THAT
CUTS THROUGH. THE ARGUMENTS WERE
OF THOSE HIGHWAYS WERE MORE
INTENDED TO CUT- THE- ELIMINATE
EASE A BURDEN ON TRAFFIC AND TO
CREATE SHORTER ROUTES TO HELP
PEOPLE GET THERE FASTER IN THIS
THE CASE OF THIS- FREE WITHOUT
WASN'T. THE INTENDED PURPOSE
THIS FREEWAYS INTENDED PURPOSE
WAS TO PROVIDE SUPPORT TO QUITE
A BIT. OF NEW DEVELOPMENT THAT
REALLY WENT OUT AND. EASTER
CHÁVEZ TO. EXPONENTIALLY IN THIS
HIGH. WAS REGION INTENDED
PROVIDE SUPPORT FOR ALL THAT
HOUSING AND IN SOME AREAS YOU
HAVE VERY DENSE HOUSING. AND
THEN YOU ALSO HAVE THE TRUCK
CROSSING IN OTAY MESA WHICH ALSO
HAS GROWN EXPONENTIALLY SINCE
AMOUNT NINETIES THAT TRUCK ROUTE
CROSSING. USED TO BE INSIDE THE
C. THEIR OWN IT WAS MOVED EAST
WHICH PROVIDES PROVIDED AN
ADDITIONAL BURDEN. TO THE
STREETS OF THAT AREA SO. BUT
THERE'S A QUITE A BIG
DISTINCTION WITH THIS HIGHWAY
AND THE ONES IN ORANGE COUNTY
AND THAT'S WHY WE'RE ARGUING
THAT INITIALLY THE STATE WOULD
HAVE BUILT THIS ONE WAY OR
ANOTHER BUT DURING ALL THOSE
TOUGH ECONOMIC TIMES. THE STATE
CAN MEET ITS OBLIGATIONS YEAH
THAT WAS THE SAME IN ORANGE
COUNTY. THEM OKAY THANK YOU WE
HAVE NO OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS TO COMMUNITY IN A
MOTION ON THE OF THIS BILL SB
ELEVEN SIXTY NINE PLEASE SENATOR
DODD THANK YOU MISTER CHIEF
CONSULTANT CAN YOU PLEASE R. I
APOLOGIZE SENATOR WEST SO WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE FOR GOT THAT
OPTION FOR YOU I THINK THE MOST
IMPORTANT- A POINT THAT WAS MADE
THAT IS THE ONLY TORRANCE AND IT
WILL COUNTY AND IT'S REALLY AN
AREA THAT HAS GROWN. UP MUCH
MUCH MORE THAN ANY OTHER PART OF
THIS WOOD COUNTY NOW PROVIDING
OF OUT OF A POPULATION OF ONE
MILLION PEOPLE AND THE MOST
IMPORTANT POINT THE OLIVERS THAT
WE CAN REDUCE VEHICLE TRIPS THE
DISTANCE THE VEHICLE TRAVEL
WE'RE ALSO GOING TO BE HELPING
TO REDUCE CONTAMINATION CARE
IMPROVE AIR QUALITY JUST IMPROVE
THE QUALITY OF LIFE AND HELP THE
STATE MEET ITS IT'S-
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
OBLIGATIONS ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS THANK YOU THANK YOU
SENATOR WEST SO NOW WE'VE GOT
THIS MOTION BY SENATOR DODD
MISTER CHIEF CONSULTANT EMAIL
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE. THE MOST
IS DUE PASS AND REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
SENATORS GONZALEZ HI GONZALEZ I
BATES. ALLEN ARCHULETA. BAKER
CORTESE DOLLY PARTON DOLLY I GOT
DODD HI LIMÓN. LIMON I AM
ACQUIRE MELENDEZ MEN ARE MEN AYE
NEWMAN. RUBIO GRACEFUL RUBIO AYE
SKINNER WHY CASKEY WILK. SIX SIX
ZERO SO LEAVE THE BILL ON CALL
THANK YOU SENATOR WESSEL MOVE
ONTO YOUR LAST BILL FILE ITEM
FIVE SB ELEVEN EIGHTY ONE A USED
TIRE SALE AND EXPORT. THANK YOU
OF THIS BILL- ELEVEN EIGHTY ONE
SIX TO STRENGTHENED CALIFORNIA'S
TRACKING SYSTEM WITH REGARDS TO
TIRE FLOWS FROM CALIFORNIA AND
OTHER STATES. INTO BACA
CALIFORNIA SO NOT A THIS IS A
BILL THAT I'VE BEEN WORKING ON
WITH THE GOVERNMENT'S ABOUT
CALIFORNIA. AND OF THE ART OWN
DEPARTMENT OF RECYCLING- THIS
BILL AIMS TO REDUCE A LOT OF
THESE USED TIRES FROM ENTERING
THE ENVIRONMENT A LOT OF THEM
COME- ARE ARE THESE USED TIRES
ARE SOLD IN MEXICO THEY WIND UP
IN THE ENVIRONMENT THEY ACTUALLY
COME IN. TO THE QUAN A RIVER
VALLEY THE NEW RIVER THE L. MORE
RIVER THEY- AND UP IN THE
PACIFIC OCEAN AND WE SPEND.
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS CLEAN UP
THESE TIRES AND WE HAVE TO FIND
A BETTER WAY TO MANAGE THE
TRADING OF THESE TIRES ACROSS
THE BORDER. AND THIS BILL WILL
CREATE A PROGRAM. THAT WOULD DO
THAT- THE- CLARIFICATION
LANGUAGE ON THE AMENDMENTS THE
ADDING AMENDMENTS STRESSED THAT
THE ONLY IMPACTS SALE OF
INDIVIDUALS USED TIRES NOT USED-
VEHICLES BEING SOLD WITH USED
TYRES. SO- LIKE. MANY WHO-
WHOLESALERS- THERE'S JUST- CAL
THAT'S THE LANGUAGE STRESSES
THAT THIS ONLY IMPACTS THE SALE
OF YOU INDIVIDUAL USED TIRES NOT
THOSE THAT ARE COMING WITH A
VEHICLE JUST CLARIFYING LANGUAGE
SYSTEM WHICH I MEAN A LOT OF
TIMES THESE VEHICLES COME IN BY
THE TRUCKLOADS- THEY CROSS THE
BORDER AND THEY ARE FUNCTIONALLY
NOT USEFUL TIRES THAT ARE RESOLD
AS TIONAL TIRES AND IMPACT. ON
THE NATIONAL IN ENVIRONMENT IS
IN LENORE MISS AND AS I
MENTIONED MOST OF THESE TIRES
INTO COMING BACK AND THROUGH THE
ENVIRONMENT THROUGH
ENVIRONMENTAL MEANS SO- THIS IS
AN IMPORTANT BILL. THAT WILL
ADDRESS SUCH AN ENORMOUS PROBLEM
THAT WE'RE HAVING ALONG THE
BORDER AND OUR PACIFIC OCEAN I
ASK THAT. YOU SUPPORT OR WORK ON
THIS BILL TODAY. THANK YOU
SENATOR WESSEL AND YOU DO NOT
HAVE ANY- OF FOLKS IN SUPPORT
THAT OUR LEAD WITNESSES. AND OR
ON OPPOSITION BUT WE'LL TAKE IT
TO THE GALLERY IF THERE'S ANYONE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. ELEVEN EIGHTY
ONE PLEASE COME FORWARD. SEE NON
MODERATOR WILL TAKE IT TO THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE FOR ANYONE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. ELEVEN EIGHTY
ONE. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR IF
ANYONE WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF. SB ELEVEN EIGHTY ONE
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. GLORIA LINE NUMBER
NINETY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY
NINETY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.%
OKAY I'LL JUST BE ONE MOMENT FOR
OUR NEXT CALLER A RELEASE TEST
NINE ONE.
I WANNA GO TO LINE ONE SEVENTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES WE CAN'T. I WOULD IS
MISTER OVERSTAYS BENDIGO COUNTY
POLICY COORDINATOR FOR SURFRIDER
FOUNDATION OUR MISSION IS
PROTECTED THROUGHOUT THE WORLD'S
FIRST RATE BEACHES FOR ALL
PEOPLE FOR OUR ACTORS THAT.
SURPRISED AND DEEPLY INTO IN
ADDRESS TRAN POLLUTION ISSUE AND
IF YOU WANT TO. AND HAS
ADVOCATED BRING WATER SOLUTIONS
IN AND AROUND THE BORDERS DECLAN
INCLUDE FY THING THAT NOT UNTIL
TO RECOVER AND REMOVE FIFTY TWO
HUNDRED DERELICT HIRED IN ONE
DAY WE MUST BE MORE TO LIMIT THE
NUMBER OF EXPIRED CALIFORNIA ACT
WORKS BACKBONE. AND THAT WOULD
BE DO YOU WANT RIVER VALLEY
EXPORTING OUR WAY MEXICO
UNETHICAL AND JOB ALTHOUGH
LATEST BE FIRED MICHAEL WHICH
INCLUDES ARE I THOUGHT CHANNEL
THAT TO THE WATERFALL CRISIS-
STILL THE U. S. B. FOR MORE THAN
HUNDRED A YEAR- PATTERSON AT THE
ELEVEN EIGHTY ONE AT STEPS
ATTENTION AND FUNDING WE HAVE TO
WAIT IF YOU WANT TO RALLY WE
WILL COMPLETE WORK BETTER FASTER
. LIMIT NOT OF WASTE PRODUCTS
THAT ARE UP BY FLOW AND PEOPLE
ARE NOW TO RESTORE WE RESPECT
THEIR THERE'S AT THE ELEVENTH
THANK THANK YOU AND WE'LL TAKE
THAT AS YOUR WITNESS AND SOME-
WESSEL ANY ELSE WOULD LIKE
TESTIFY IN THE TELE LINE FOR SB. ELEVEN ONE.
SO WE'LL TAKE IT TO THE GALLERY
ANYONE ELSE WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB
ELEVEN EIGHTY ONE. C. NINE SO
WE'LL GO BACK TO THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE ANYONE WHO'D
LIKE TO TESTIFY. IN OPPOSITION
TO SB ELEVEN EIGHTY ONE PLEASE.
THANK YOU COULD LIKE TO TEST AT
TESTIFIED IN OPPOSITION OF SB
ONE ELEVEN EIGHTY ONE PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND THERE ARE NO LINES INTO
PLEASE CONTINUE OKAY THANK YOU
SO WE'LL TAKE IT BACK TO MEMBERS
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FOR
MEMBERS. SEEN NONE CAN WE
ENTERTAIN A MOTION ON S. B.
ELEVEN EIGHTY ONE PLEASE. THANK
YOU SENATOR RUBIO SENATOR WAS SO
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE THANK
YOU JUST APPRECIATE YOUR AYE
VOTE TODAY THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MISTER SHE CONSULTANT CAN YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE MOTION
IS DUE PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
SENATORS GONZALEZ HI THE DALLAS
AYE BATES. BATES AYE ALLEN.
II DOLLY. DALY I DOT. THE DOT I
LIMÓN THE MODI MCGUIRE MELENDEZ
MEN IN HIGH COMMITMENT TOWARD
GOALS RUBIO AYE RUBIO AYE
SKINNER- WHITE HOUSE SKI WILK.
EIGHT ZERO OKAY EIGHT ZERO WILL
LEAVE THE BILL ON CALL THANK YOU
CENTER MANAGER MEMBERS ALL RIGHT
SO- I BELIEVE SENATOR UMBERG AT
THIS POINT IS CHAIRING A
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE HEARING AND
I BELIEVE SENATOR TO RASO IS
ALSO IN THAT COMMITTEE HEARING I
SHOULD I SHOULD BE AND SO MOVING
ON TO US SENATOR DOLLY WHO WILL
BE PRESENTING ON BEHALF OF
SENATOR GROWTH. FILE ITEM EIGHT
SB THIRTEEN FIFTY SIX PLEASE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS-
PRESENTING AB OR SB THIRTEEN
FIFTY SIX ON BEHALF OF CENTER
GROVE- SHE SUGGESTED THAT WE
TAKE THE FOR YOUR SUNSET AND
LEGISLATIVE REPORTS WHICH CENTER
GROVE WILL ACCEPT TODAY IN ORDER
TO MOVE THIS BILL FORWARD.
SENATE BILL THIRTEEN FIFTY SIX
INCREASES THE MAXIMUM ALLOWABLE
GROSS WEIGHT OF FUEL HAULERS
FROM EIGHTY THOUSAND POUNDS. TO
EIGHTY EIGHT THOUSAND POUNDS TO
MATCH THE INCREASED WEIGHT
ALLOWED FOR. OTHER TRUCKERS
UNDER THE GOVERNMENT UNDER
GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE ORDER NINE
DASH NINETEEN TWENTY ONE.
CALIFORNIA'S PORTS HAVE SICK
EXPERIENCE INCREASED. YEAR OVER
YEAR LEVELS OF CARGO VOLUME
DESPITE EFFORTS BY ALL THE
SECTORS OF SUPPLY CHAIN THE
COVERT NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS
DRAMATICALLY IMPACTED THE GOODS
PUTS SYSTEMS- CALIFORNIA AND
NATIONALLY. IT IS ALSO
HIGHLIGHTED THE FOR. FRAGILITY
OF FOODS MOVEMENT SECTOR AND
SUPPLY CHAIN FOR EXAMPLE THE
PORTS OF LOS ANGELES AND LONG
BEACH HAVE BEEN HANDLING AN
UNPRECEDENTED NUMBER OF SHIPS
ARRIVING AT THE SAME TIME
DISRUPTIONS IN TRANSPORTATION
AND WAREHOUSE AVAILABILITY. HAS
SLOWED THE OFFLOADING AND OF
CONTAINERS IN THE CAN AND
CONTRIBUTED TO THE BACKLOG.
GOVERNOR NEWSOM ANNOUNCED ON
NOVEMBER SEVENTEENTH TWENTY
TWENTY ONE THAT CALTRANS WOULD
BE ISSUING TEMPORARY PERMITS
ALLOWING. TRUCKS TO CARRY
HEAVIER LOADS UP TO EIGHTY EIGHT
THOUSAND POUNDS- BETWEEN THE
PORTS OF LONG LOS ANGELES AND
LONG BEACH AND OTHER STATEWIDE
PORTS AND DISTRIBUTION CENTERS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE SB THIRTEEN
FIFTY SIX. WE'LL TAKE THE
GOVERNOR'S TEMPORARY EXEMPTION
APPLY IT PER PERMANENTLY TO ALL
FUEL TRUCKS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
CALIFORNIA NEEDS LONG TERM
SOLUTIONS THAT WILL NOT ONLY
REDUCE EMISSIONS AND HELP
ALLEVIATE CONGESTION ON. IT ALSO
REDUCED DRIVERS IT TAKES TO
TRANSPORT FUEL. ANOTHER ISSUE
THAT SB THIRTEEN FIFTY SIX WILL
HELP ADDRESS IS THE UPCOMING
FIRE SEASON CALIFORNIA'S
DEVASTATING FIRE SEASONS
INCREASED. INCREASES IN THE LATE
EVERY YEAR SB THIRTEEN FIFTY SIX
WILL HELP FUEL HAULERS TRANSPORT
MORE FUEL WHICH WILL EIGHT
FIREFIGHTERS AS THEY BATTLE THE
DESTRUCTIVE BLAZES THAT HAVE
WRECKED HAVOC ON OUR STATE. THE
GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE ORDER IS
NOT THE ONLY EXEMPTION THAT
ALLOWS INCREASE GROSS WEIGHT FOR
TRUCKS ON OTHER ROADS THERE ARE
ALSO OTHERS. OTHER EXEMPTIONS
THAT EXCEED THE MAXIMUM. LIMIT
FOR EXAMPLE. TRANSPORTING LOGS
ARE ALLOWED TO EXCEED THE
FEDERAL LIMIT FOR THE TANDEM
AXLES OF THIRTY FOUR THOUSAND
POUNDS BY FIFTEEN HUNDRED POUNDS
BETWEEN SEPTEMBER FIFTEENTH AND
MARCH FIFTEENTH. EACH YEAR
COTTON TRUCKS THAT MEET CERTAIN
CRITERIAS ARE ALLOWED ADDITIONAL
SIX THOUSAND POUNDS THE FEDERAL
LIMIT. FOUR THOUSAND POUNDS FOR
TANDEM AXLES. YOU HAULERS WILL
BE ALLOWED TO SAFELY USE THE
SAME EXEMPTIONS THE SUPPLY
CHAINS CRISIS COUPLED WITH
DRAMATIC INCREASES IN FUEL
PRICES THIS YEAR AND WITH THE
FIRE SEASON FAST APPROACHING.
CRITICAL THAT THE STATE DO WHAT
WEEK WHAT IT CAN TO MAXIMIZE
EFFICIENCIES AND REDUCE COST SB
THIRTEEN FIFTY SIX WILL PUT INTO
LAW THE GOVERNOR'S EXEMPTION
ALREADY RECOGNIZE THAT FUEL
HAULERS CAN SAFELY INCREASE THE
GROSS WEIGHT ALLOWED ON
CALIFORNIA'S WROTE. MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
OF THIRTEEN FIFTY SIX TODAY.
WITH ME HERE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT AS PRESIDENT CEO OF ****
PETROLEUM TRANSPORT INC
CONSTITUTION THE CONSTITUENT OF
CENTER GROVE'S. ANY SPONSOR OF
SB. THIRTEEN FIFTY SIX. THIS IS
. DESCRIPTION MOTO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA TRUCKING ASSOCIATION.
THANK YOU AND THANK YOU SENATOR
DOLLY SO WE'LL START WITH MR
MAHER'S JOURNEY MARE'S ****
PETROLEUM TRANSPORT. WELCOME.
FOR TAKING THE TIME TO HEAR ME
TODAY MY NAME IS JEREMY MERS
WITH **** PATROLLING MORE OUT OF
BAKERSFIELD CALIFORNIA AND I'M
GONNA BE SPONSORING THIS BILL
THIS IMPORTANT MAJOR WILL HELP
FUEL HAULERS- TRANSPORT VITAL
RESOURCES THROUGHOUT THE STATE
BOB AN ADDITIONAL EIGHT THOUSAND
POUNDS OF FUEL. THE TRUCKING
INDUSTRY OR THE WHEELS OF
AMERICA. KEEPING EVERYTHING
MOVING. IF YOU TAKE EVERYTHING
OUT OF THIS ROOM THAT WEHOLD ON
A TRUCK. WOULD BE STANDING IN AN
EMPTY LOT NAKED. WITHOUT FUEL
DELIVERY EVERYTHING STOPS ALL
THE CARS ALL THE TRUCKS. ALL THE
SHIPS IN THE PORTS AND ALL THE
PLANES IN THE AIR. THE POLICE IN
THE FIRE DEPARTMENT EVEN WORSE
THE MILITARY. IT BE HELPFUL FOR
FUEL HAULERS TO BE ABLE TO CARRY
MORE FUEL- THIS 10% INCREASE IN
WEIGHT WOULD ALLOW US TO DEEP
DECREASE TRUCK. ROAD ROUGHLY.
PERCENT THIS WOULD ALSO PRODUCE
CONGESTION ON THE ROADWAYS.
HIGHER LOAD CAPACITY WILL GIVE
US THE ABILITY TOP OFF THE TANK
THE GAS STATE REDUCE THE NUMBER
OF TIME. WE HAVE TO TURN TO THAT
SAME STATEMENT. WHICH AGAIN THIS
IS ALL BROKE DESTINATION. IN
CERTAIN CIRCUMSTANCE THE STATE
ALREADY HOLD TO EXCEED THE
EIGHTY THOUSAND POUND LIMIT FOR
EXAMPLE GOVERNMENT ISN'T ALLOWED
VEHICLES MOVING CONTAINERS IN
AND OUT OF THE PORTS. VEHICLES
TRANSPORTING LOGS AND I'M MUCH
OF. DRYBULK CARRIERS OF OFF OF
THE ALSO BEEN GIVEN AXLE WEIGHT
RETENTION TO GO 10% OVER THEIR
AXLE WEIGHTS. FUEL OUR SHOULD BE
ALLOWED HAVE THIS. ASSEMBLY SB
THIRTEEN FIFTY SIX WOULD TAKE
GOVERNMENT'S- GOVERNORS
TEMPORARY EXEMPTION AND APPLY IT
PERSONALLY TO ALL FUEL TRUCKS TO
THE STATE BY ALLOWING THIS
CHANGE THE BILL WILL HELP THE
STATE IMPROVE ITS SUPPLY A FEW
TIMES AND- DURING COHEN. FIRE C.
BY. LIKE IN COLONIAL PIPELINE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
MERECE AND WE HAVE MISTER
SHIMODA WELCOME. THANK YOU
JUERGENS ALL'S IN MEMBERS-
KRISHNADAS CALIFORNIA TRUCKING
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
THIRTEEN FIFTY SIX ALONG WITH
OUR MEMBER CARDS FOR TROLLING.
OVER THE PAST YEARS IN RESPONSE
TO THE COVENANT DAMAC SURGES IN
DEMAND FOR TRUCKING SERVICES AND
- PARK. WEIGHT PER. OKAY IS.
TANNER YES THIRTEEN FIFTY SO
WHAT ARE SIMILAR FLEX FOR
HAULERS OF FUEL SOLELY WHILE
TRAVELING ON NON INTERSTATE
ROUTES NATIONALLY THE AMERICAN
TRUCKING ASSOCIATIONS ESTIMATES
THE TRUCKING INDUSTRY NEEDS
APPROXIMATELY EIGHTY THOUSAND
HERE TO ACCOMMODATE WRITTEN IN
INDUSTRY GROW. THAT'S IT MOTOR
CARE THANK WAGES AT FIVE TIMES
HISTORIC RATE OFFERING FIVE
FIGURE SIGN ON A REFERRAL
BONUSES IN FULL BENEFIT PACKAGES
TO ATTRACT. HOURS IF YOU DOLLARS
ARE UNIQUELY IMPACTED BY THESE
ISSUES THEIR ARE. RESPECT TANK
TRUCK DRIVERS ARE TO CARRY
MULTIPLE- CDL ENDORSED. C. C.
THREE CESSNA THE FIRM WITH LOW
BEING UNLOADING PROCEDURE AND
TANKS. ESSITY IS FURTHER
IMPACTED BY SHORTAGES NEW AND S.
LAYS COULD RIP PARTS DO TO
SUPPLY CHAIN ISSUE. ANOTHER
TWENTY ONE K. REGISTER BECAUSE
XBOX OR EXPECTED TO LEAVE THEM
ON JANUARY FOR. FINAL DEADLINE
FOR CLUBS POSTURAL KICKS AND ALL
SAID THE STABILITY IN SB
THIRTEEN FIFTY SIX ONE SURE THAT
MOTORISTS THIS THOSE IN ROLL IS
MORE WOULD BE OFF ON INNER. ARE
SUPPLIED WITH. IN THE CHALLENGE
ARE- COMMITTEE. THANK YOU MISTER
SHIMADA SO IF CONCLUDED OUR LEAD
WITNESSES AND- SUPPORTS OF S. B.
THIRTEEN FIFTY SIX SO WE WILL-
TO GET BACK TO THE GALLERY FOR
ANYONE WHO'D LIKE TO. NO MONEY.
WE ARE FOR THE CALIFORNIA FUEL
IT CAN BE A LIGHTS SUPPORT THANK
YOU ANYONE ELSE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT SB
THIRTEEN FIFTY SIXTY NINE
MODERATE WILL TAKE IT BACK TO
THE TELECONFERENCE LINE FOR
ANYONE LIKE SERVE AS THE FIFTH
EXPERT. I AM. LIKE. FOR FIFTY
SIX PLEASE PRAY ONE AT TIME.
THERE ARE NO LIGHTING Q. PLEASE
CONTINUE. THANK YOU- SO WE'LL
MOVE ON TO A LEAD WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO SB THIRTEEN FIFTY
SIX AND WE HAVE- LET'S SEE HERE
WE HAVE TO HAVE ANY. ONE ON FILE
. SHE OKAY WE HAVE SHANE GUSMAN
WITH THE TEAMSTERS THAT IS HERE
I DON'T KNOW IF THERE WAS A
LEAD- TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION
FROM EVE OF PUT IN BUT GO RIGHT
AHEAD THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR FOR
YOUR INDULGENCE CHANGE. OF THE
COUNCIL AND THE AMALGAMATED
TRANSIT UNION- OUR PRIMARY
CONCERNS WITH THIS BILL ARE
AROUND SAFETY- WE HAVE LONG
OPPOSED BILLS TO MAKE TRUCKS
HEAVIER LONGER BECAUSE THE
REALITY IS IF YOU HAVE YOUR
TRUCK IS HARDER TO STOP HARDER
TO MANEUVER AND IN THIS INSTANCE
YOU'RE DEALING WITH A CARGO THAT
IS THE MOST DANGEROUS CARGO WE
HAVE ON THE- WE FOUND ALL THE-
WE HAVE. YET FIRST- BECAUSE OF
ACCIDENTS WITH THESE TRUCKS
MAKING THEM HEAVIER 10% HEAVIER
IS REALLY NOT THE ANSWER IN OUR
VIEW- AND PUTS FOLKS THAT SHARE
THE HIGHWAY WITH THESE
INDIVIDUALS AND IN EXTREME
DANGER I WOULD ALSO SAY THAT
MUCH HAS BEEN SAID ABOUT THE
GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE ORDER
EXPANDED. TO THEY'RE DOING
THAT'S NUMBER ORDER WHERE
THERE'S READ PERCENT WHERE THE
EAST PERMITTED THIS IS EVERYONE
GETS TO DRIVE THE TRUCK- PERMIT
A THE TOP TEN IN. SAID THE MOST
INTEREST WE ON THE ROAD.
IT'S NOT YOU KNOW A 100% OF THE
TIME- AND THEN YOU KNOW LASTLY
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT AN INDUSTRY
THAT IS- YOU KNOW. RAKING IN THE
PROFITS AT RECORD LEVELS RIGHT
NOW- AND IT'S KIND OF IRONIC
THAT THEY WOULD COME TO THE
LEGISLATURE TO ASDA- PRESENTER
SAID REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF
DRIVERS- IN OUR VIEW WHICH
REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF DRIVERS
EXTRA EXPENSE OF- THOSE SHOWING
HIGHWAYS AND WE ARE JOURNAL
ABOUT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER CRESSMAN- DO WE HAVE
ANYONE ELSE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
OPPOSE S. B. THIRTEEN FIFTY SIX
PLEASE COME FORWARD HERE IN THE
GALLERY. RIGHT SEE NOT OUR
MODERATOR WILL TAKE IT BACK TO
THE TELECONFERENCE LINE FOR
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO OPPOSE
THE BILL SB. THIRTEEN FIFTY SIX.
SPEAKING OF. SB THIRTEEN FIFTY
SIX PLEASE ONE THEN AT THIS TIME. AND THERE ARE NO LINES IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE CONTINUE OKAY
THANK YOU WILL TAKE IT BACK TO
MEMBERS SENATOR MAN. THANK YOU
SENATOR FOR BEING IN THIS BILL
FOR. THANK YOU CENTER FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD- OUR
ANALYSIS HAS QUITE A BIT OF-
DISCUSSION ABOUT THE COSTS AND
RISKS ASSOCIATED WITH INCREASING
THE WEIGHT. ALLOWED PER COMPUTE
PETROLEUM FUEL TRUCKS- IT
DOESN'T HAVE ANY DISCUSSION OF
THE NEED FOR IT AND SO I WAS ONE
IF YOU CAN'T TO. OR YOUR
SPONSORS TO DISCUSS- ANALYZED
BILL THAT NOW. WHAT PROBLEM
TRYING TO SOLVE. WELL LET ME
JUST THEM I'M THIS BILL BEHALF
OF THIS GROW- YOU KNOW I TAKE A
I'M THE ONLY I BELIEVE THE ONLY
MEMBER OF THIS LEGISLATURE THAT
OWNS A TRUCKING COMPANY. AND HAS
A CLASS ONE LICENSE AND HAS ALL
THE REGULATORY ENVIRONMENT YOU
HAVE TO DO TO OPERATE A TRUCKING
BUSINESS. AND WE ARE SHORT. THE
ONLY THING TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
DRIVERS IN CALIFORNIA NUMBER
ONE. NUMBER TWO OUR COST OF
GOODS IS SKYROCKETING IN
CALIFORNIA I DON'T KNOW ANYBODY
THAT HASN'T BEEN TO THE GROCERY
STORE DALY. YOU'LL PUMP TO FIT
WOULD HAVE A CRISIS ON OUR HANDS
AND PEOPLE CAN'T AFFORD TO LIVE
IN CALIFORNIA THIS BILL ATTEMPTS
TO DO. AND THE SENATOR BROUGHT
FORTH. SHE WOULD TAKE A SUNSET
ON THIS BILL. AND TO TRY TO GET
IT OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE. YOU'RE
ALL GONNA MAKE A DECISION TODAY
WHETHER WE CAN ALL. YOU KNOW 10%
MORE. AND YOU CAN TALK ABOUT
FUEL BEING YOU KNOW. THE
DANGEROUS WHAT'S IT IT'S
DANGEROUS BUT IT'S NOT AND I IS
10% MORE OF THESE TRUCKS ARE
MADE TO HOLD OUT WAIT THEY CAN
HOLD THAT WEIGHT IN OTHER
STATES. THEY HOLD LONGER LOADS.
AND LOADS AND THEY'RE QUITE
FRANKLY HELP ON THE ENVIRONMENT
AND SAVING GETTING GOODS TO
THEIR TO THEIR CONSTITUENTS. AT
A CHEAPER RATE. AND SAVING THE
ENVIRONMENT SAME TIME WITH THE
SHORTAGE AND WE'RE PRICES WE
DON'T HAVE ENOUGH TRUCKS THAT'S
WHAT'S DRIVING UP THE COST OF
FUEL- CAPPELLETTI. SO THIS BILL
THIS BILL IS BROUGH. TO TRY TO
SOLVE A- WE CAN'T GET OUR GOOD
STORE WE WANT AND WE WANT TO
JUST ADD THIS. TO THE OTHER
COMMODITIES THAT THE GOVERNOR.
QUITE FRANKLY SEE WHAT WHAT
COMES IN THOSE CONTAINERS.
THERE'S CHEMICALS IN SOME OF
THOSE CONTAINERS THAT COME FROM
CHINA. THEY HAVE. PESTICIDES AND
HERBICIDES AND ALL THAT IN THERE
WE HAVE TO WAIT A RATE ON THOSE
WHAT'S THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
NOW AND HOW. DO YOU. I THINK
THIS IS. I'M WITH DEFERRED TO
MAYBE SOME OF THE- THE FOLKS
THAT WERE HERE THURSDAY THAT
WOULD ADD MORE TO IT BUT- I MEAN
. I DON'T KNOW WHAT YOU'RE NOW
SUCCESS. OKAY DOES THAT CONCLUDE
YOUR QUESTION LINE OF
QUESTIONING SENTIMENT THANK YOU
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS. WELL
THERE'S NO OTHER QUESTIONS I
WILL ALSO WEIGH IN AND I DO HAVE
DEEP CONCERNS AS WELL I'M OF
COURSE FOR ALL OF THE- WITH THE
OPPOSITION RAISED OF COURSE
WHERE WE CURRENTLY HAVE A LOT OF
NEED IN TERMS OF OUR ROADS AND
BRIDGES. AS WE'RE DISCUSSING
RIGHT NOW THE LEGISLATURE
DISCUSSING WHAT TO DO WITH THIS
MAJOR DEFICIT- WITH OUR ROADS
IMPRESSION BRIDGES THAT WE DON'T
HAVE ENOUGH MONEY TO PAY FOR
WE'RE ADDING TEN PERCENT- MORE
WITH THIS BILL AND ISN'T PRINT
WITHOUT THE AMENDMENTS. MAKE
THIS TEMPORARY EXECUTIVE ORDER
PERMANENT NOT BASED ON AN
EMERGENCY STATEWIDE THAT
PROVIDES BLANKET AUTHORITY FOR
CALTRANS- WITHOUT CALTRANS
OVERSIGHT- I'M ALSO CONCERNED
BECAUSE MANY OF THESE
COMMUNITIES. REPOR THE PORT OF
LONG BEACH I'M GLAD YOU YOU
STATED THAT IN YOUR IN YOUR
WELCOME ON YOUR OPENING REMARKS
MANY OF THOSE COMMUNITIES CANNOT
TAKE 10% ARE OF. TRUCK TO HELP
WITH HAVE YOUR LOW SO THAT IS A
I WILL BE OPPOSING THE BILL AT
THE TIME AND- I LOOK FORWARD TO
YOU KNOW WORKING WITH SENATOR
GROVE SHOULD SHE HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS BUT- I WILL
LEAVE IT AT THAT NAY JUST I
THINK YOU FOR YOUR- COMMENTS ON
THE LAST. AND QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. CANADA'S PRESUMABLY
YOU'VE BEEN NEGOTIATING AND SHE
JUST YOU HAVEN'T COME TO COURT
THAT'S CORRECT OKAY ARE AND LIKE
TO THE BILL OKAY CENTER BATES
MOVES THE BILL MISTER CHIEF
CONSULTANT CAN YOU PAY CAN I
CLOSE MY APOLOGIES PLEASE CALL-
I WOULD JUST LIKE TO. SAY THAT.
YEAH I THINK BILL IS GONNA HAVE
A TOUGH GET OUT TODAY BUT- THE
GOVERNOR PUTTING TOGETHER AN
EXECUTIVE ORDER TO DO. TO DO%
CARS BY TO DO THAT BECAUSE I
TWENTY FIVE THERE'S ALL KINDS OF
LEGISLATION COME THROUGH THEIR
TO RATIFYING THAT. SO I THINK I
THINK THAT THERE'S THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO DO THE RIGHT-THING FOR CALIFORNIA THE COST
OF. OF GOODS ARE SKYROCKETING IN
THIS IS QUITE FRANKLY BECAUSE OF
WE DON'T MOVE STUFF INTO. MORE
CHEAPER MORE EFFICIENT WAY. SO
AND WE HAD ONE OPPOSITION. WE
HAD WE HAD THE OPPOSITION WAS
HERE THAT STATED THAT YOU KNOW
AND WE'RE SHORT EIGHTY THOUSAND
DRIVERS. IN AMERICA AND SO I
WOULD ASK FOR AYE VOTE AND IS A
COMMON SENSE BILL IT CAN SUNSET
IN FOUR YEARS AND WE CAN TALK
ABOUT IT AGAIN BUT RIGHT NOW
WE'RE IN A CRISIS. WE'RE A
CRISIS OF INFLATION. AND I THINK
WE SHOULD TAKE A CLOSE LOOK AT
THAT WERE THE SHORTAGE OF A WORK
FORCE IN THIS SECTOR. SO THANK
YOU. MISTER CHIEF CONSULTANT CAN
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED AS AMENDED
AND WE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS SENATORS
GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ NOW BATES.
BATES HI ALAN. ARCHULETA BAKER.
CORTESE. DOLLY ALL RIGHT DOLLY I
DOT. LIMON LOW KNOW WHERE WIRED
L. MELENDEZ. MEN NEWMAN. RUBIO
SKINNER. WHY CASKEY WILK. TWO
THREE OKAY TWO THREE WILL LEAVE
THE BILL ON CALL THANK YOU
SENATOR DOLLY. NEXT WE WILL MOVE
ON TO FILE ITEM SIX SB ELEVEN
NINETY SIX BY SENATOR UMBERG
WELCOME SENATOR I'M BURKE. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS AND
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR FOR YOUR
WORK ON THIS PARTICULAR BILL. SB
ELEVEN NINETY SIX IS A DISTRICT
BILL THAT HAS NO OPPOSITION
SUPPORTED BY LOS ANGELES AND
ORANGE COUNTY BUILDING TRADE
CITY OF ANAHEIM ANAHEIM CHAMBER
WHAT THIS BILL DOES THE DENTIST
BILLS ACTUALLY TO INCREASE
TRANSPORTATION FUNDING FOR
ANAHEIM IN. A NET INCREASE FOR
ORANGE COUNTY. ANAHEIM
TRANSPORTATION NETWORK KNOWN AS
ETIENNE HAS BEEN OPERATING FOR
TWENTY YEARS IN ANAHEIM IN THE
SURROUNDING ORANGE COUNTY
COMMUNITIES- PART OF THIS BILL
MOVES FORWARD. WITH IT END OF
TRANSPORTATION NETWORK THAT THE
GOVERNING BOARD IS ELECTED BY
THE ANAHEIM CITY COUNCIL AND
MAYOR MUCH ALONG THE LINES OF
THE LONG BEACH OF TRANSPORTATION
NETWORK MODEL. EVERY YEAR OVER
NINE POINT FIVE MILLION FOR SOME
REASON VISITORS YOU EIGHT TEN TO
CONNECT WITH JOB CENTRES THEME
PARKS AND SPORTS VENUES AS WELL
AS A FIRST AND LAST MILE
CONNECTION TO ARCTIC WHICH IS
THE- PROVIDING ACCESS TO
METROLINK AND- AMTRAK. DESPITE
BEING AN IMPORTANT
TRANSPORTATION PROVIDER ETIENNE
IS CURRENTLY NOT ELIGIBLE FOR
STATE TRANSIT OPERATIONS
FUNDING. APPROVAL ETIENNE'S
ELIGIBILITY TO. RECEIVE S. T. A.
REVENUE- FUNDS CONSISTENT WITH
POLICIES APPLICABLES TO ALL
OTHER PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION
OPERATORS. BUT S. T. A. REVENUE
BASED FUNDING IS CRITICAL FOR A
TEN TO MEET THE TRANSIT NEEDS OF
THE COMMUNITY IT SERVES TO MEET
FUTURE NEEDS AND TO REMAIN
COMPETITIVE EIGHTEEN TO
REPRESENT MY TEAM. FIFTY TWO- I
URGE AN AYE VOTE WITH ME TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT- DIæN CUTLER
OF THE ANAHEIM. TRANSPORTATION
NETWORK INCHING GOOSE MON WITH
THE CALIFORNIA TRENT TEAMSTERS.
A PUBLIC AFFAIRS COUNCIL RIGHT.
THANK YOU SENATOR UMBERG SO WILL
ENTERTAIN YOUR FIRST LEAD
WITNESS AND SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK A CHERUB GONZALEZ AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COME AND SPEAK TO
YOU TODAY AND THANK YOU SENATOR-
BURKE FOR YOUR SUPPORT AND
LEADERSHIP IN MOVING THIS
LEGISLATION FORWARD- AS MEN AND
THAT WE'VE BEEN IN OPERATION FOR
OVER TWENTY YEARS AND WE'RE
PROUD OF THE VITAL
TRANSPORTATION. THIS SUB. IN
GARDEN GROVE ONE OF OUR AND
ORANGE. SINCE TWO THOUSAND SIX
EIGHTY ON HAS BEEN RECOGNIZED AS
THE PUBLIC TRANSIT OPERATOR BY
FEDERAL TRANSIT ADMINISTRATION.
AND WERE SEEKING THE SAME REMEDY
AT THE STATE LEVEL WITH FEDERAL
INVESTMENT AND INVESTMENT AT THE
STATE CAPITOL ALL INVESTMENT
PROGRAMS. ACN IS ON ITS WAY
THROUGH FULL LOOK TO VACATION
WELL IN ADVANCE OF GARMENTS UP
GOALS OF TWENTY THIRTY FIVE.
WE'RE CURRENTLY 60% ELECTRIFIED
AND WERE LOOKING TO GET AN
ARBITER FLEET OF EIGHTY TWO
BUSES MEETING THE ZERO EMISSION
BUS REQUIREMENTS. FOR OF TAKE
DISPLAY IN ORDER TO BRING EQUITY
AND FAIRNESS TO THE JONES.
OPERATING FUNDING PROCESSES WERE
PLANNED TO USE THE ALLOCATED
NINE HUNDRED NINETY THOUSAND
DOLLARS TO PROVIDE VITAL SERVE.
OUR COMMUNITIES TO EXPAND ACCESS
TO JOBS AND OTHER OPPORTUNITIES
BY A RESIDENT IN A HIGH AND THE
ROOTS ARE ROUNDING CITIES. WITH
SENATORS OR SHIP WE'RE LOOKING
AT THE WELL ESTABLISHED MODEL BY
LONG BEACH TRANSIT TO
ACCOUNTABILITY TO OUR BOARD. THE
STATE. POLICE OF THE- RENT AND
I'M- WITH THAT WE'RE HERE TO AND
IF. AND AGAIN THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT WITH THIS LEGISLATION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- IS CUTLER
AT NEXT WILL BRING FORWARD MR
GOSTIN AGAIN THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMISSION
GUSMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS PUBLIC
AFFAIRS CAN. AND ON BEHALF. TWO
THOUSAND PLUS MEMBERS IN
CALIFORNIA AND IN PARTICULAR OUR
MEMBERS AT LOCAL NINE FIFTY TWO
WHICH REPRESENTS THE DRIVERS AT
EIGHTY AND- THEY ARE. EXTREMELY
HAPPY THE DRIVERS WITH A. T. AND
IN THE LOCAL- ATN HAS STEPPED IN
TIME AND AGAIN TO- REAL. DRIVERS
THROUGH STE TIMES AND BE A HAPPY
TO LEND OUR SUPPORT TO AT AND IN
PARTICULAR THIS FUNDING
OPERATIONS FUNDING IS REALLY
WHAT GOT STOOD LIGHTS ON IT AND
PAY THE DRIVERS AND MAY. THE HEY
JENNIFER L. IF AND WE SUPPORT
THAT AND URGED THANK YOU. OKAY
YOU MISTER CRESSMAN WILL IT TO
THE LAW FOR ANY ELSE WOULD TO
TESTIFY IN SO. OF SB NINETY SIX
TO WHAT PLACES THANK YOU IF YOU
WOULD TO FIND SUPPORT OF ELEVEN
NINETY SIX. PRESS ONE BEEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. WE'LL GO TO LINE
ONE NINETY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE ONE NINETY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. OKAY WE'LL GO TO LINE
ONE EIGHTY EIGHT GO AHEAD. LEFT
OVER. YES HELLO. HI MY NAME IS
RICARDO AMERICAN CRYSTAL AND WE
SUPPORT BILL ELEVEN. NINETY SIX.
THANK YOU LINE ONE NINETY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS
CHRISTINA DAWSON WITH VISIT
ANAHEIM AND WE SUPPORT BILL
ELEVEN NINETY SIX. YES WHAT A
LINE ONE OH THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YOU GOT. YEAH NINE ONE OH
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN HI MY
NAME IS JAMES SOLD I'M WITH YOU
ID WE SUPPORT THIS BILL FAILS.
LEVINE ONE FOURTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THE FIRST WIN WITH THE
ANAHEIM CHAMBER OF COMMERCE AND
WE'RE IN SUPPORT OF FIFTY ELEVEN
NINETY SIX. CLEAR THAT ANAHEIM'S
FOURTH THANK YOU I NINETY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NO QUESTION.
NORMAL OKAY WITH YOU THERE'S
LOCAL NINE FIFTY TWO IS PART OF
LEVEL NINETY EIGHT WE REPRESENT
PRIVATE. MOTION HEY AT AT EIGHT
- AND WE LOOK AT. THE FILM THANK
YOU LIKE. THANK YOU LINE NINETY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS
KATHY THAT WHERE HIGHWAY CLUB-
AND WE ARE AT IN OF F. B.
UNLEAVENED. SIX THERE ARE NO
OTHER LAW INTO COURT CAN. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU MODERATOR- NOW
WILL TAKE IT TO THE GALLERY
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO SUPPORT
SB ELEVEN NINETY SIX PLEASE COME
FORWARD. RIGHT C. NOT. BE
ALREADY DONE THAT MY APOLOGIES
SO WE'LL GO ON TO OPPOSITION-
THAT WE DON'T HAVE ANY FORMAL
OPPOSITION- REGISTERED SO WE'LL
GET TO THE GALLERY FOR ANYONE
ELSE WOULD LIKE TO. DEFINE
OPPOSITION TO S. ELEVEN NINETY
SIX. C. NINE. YOU ALSO ANYONE
WITH TEST IN OPPOSITION TO S.
ELEVEN NINETY SIX PLEASE. SB
ELEVEN NINETY STATE IS ONE THEN
ZERO THIS TIME. THERE ARE NO
LINES IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
CONTINUE. OKAY THANK YOU SO WITH
INCLUDED SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION
WILL TAKE IT BACK- TO THE DIETS
FOR ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS BY
MEMBERS SENATOR NEWMAN THANK YOU
ENSURE THAT YOUR NUMBER YOU WE
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT THIS BUT SHE
MET WITH THE SHOULD BE-
SUPPORTERS. AT THE CONCERN AMONG
THEM. IN ENTITIES THAT THE
CURRENT LAN WOULD STILL ALLOW IT%
BE ELIGIBLE FOR OTHER FUNDS- FAR
IN EXCESS OF THE AMOUNT SOUGHT
AND MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT.
YOU EITHER MADE A MANAGER
WILLING TO MAKE ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS TO MAKE TO RENDER THAT
CLEAR. THAT'S CORRECT. WE SHOULD
THAT THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU SENATOR NEWMAN RIGHT SEE NO
THAT NO OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS- SENATOR- BURKE I ALSO
JUST WANT TO SAY AB I THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD I DID
HAVE- DEEP YOU KNOW CONCERNED
THIS. IMPACT. YOU KNOW JUST
BECAUSE MORE OF A FLURRY BETWEEN
THAT TRANSIT AGENCIES BUT I KNOW
YOU'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH EIGHTEEN AT AND- CTA WHICH
MIGHT MY CHIEF COULD NOT ONE OF
MY CONSULTANTS HAVE BEEN HAVE
BEEN WORKING- WITH YOU ONE AND
TO ENSURE THAT WE I'M ENSURE
THAT THERE'S COHESIVENESS FACT
FOR YOU THOUGH WITH THAT I WAS
THE BILL AND I DON'T CAN
ENTERTAIN MOTIONS THAT ARE NEW.
MISSION YOUR BILL SEARCH CONSULT
CALL THE ROLL AND WE ALLOW YOU
TO CLOSE MY I THANK YOU I
REASONABLE THANK YOU MISTER
CHIEF CONSULTANT YOU MAY NOW GO
UP A LITTLE. THE MOTION IS DUE
TO. AND WE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE APPROACH. SENATORS
GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ I BATES. ALAN
HI ALAN HI ARCHULETA. THAT
PARTULA HI BAKER BAKER HI
CORTESE CORTESE HI DOLLY. DOT
DODD I LIMON. MCGUIRE MCGUIRE
AYE MELENDEZ MAN FIVE MEN AYE
NEWMAN NEWMAN AYE RUBIO HI RUBIO
HI SKINNER. BY CASKEY WILK. IN
ZERO EIGHT TEN ZERO WE WILL KEEP
THE BILL ON CALL THANK YOU
SENATOR- BURKE OUR RIGHTS AND
NOW WILL MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM
SEVEN S. B. TWELVE TWENTY SIX BY
SENATOR TO RUSSELL.
SURE OKAY THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
OUR COLLEAGUES I ALSO WANT TO
THANK THE CHAIRMAN- THE
CONSULTANT THE STAFF FOR ALL OF
THEIR HELP IN GETTING THROUGH TO
THIS GREAT BILL S. B. TWELVE TWO
OF TWELVE TO SIX IS THE BILL BE
TO MEETING THIS ZERO EMISSION
GOALS BY FACILITATING PUBLIC
PRIVATE NONPROFIT PARTNERSHIPS
THROUGH JOINT POWERS AUTHORITY
STRUCTURE THAT IS MEANT TO
CREATE AND FINANCE GREEN PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECTS CALIFORNIA IS A LEADER
IN THE GLOBAL EFFORT TO ADDRESS-
THAT M. IMPACTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE. I INCLUDING VERY
AMBITIOUS- EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS
GOALS BUT IN ORDER TO MEET THOSE
GOALS THE STATE HAS FOCUSED ON
REDUCING TRANSPORTATION BASED
EMISSIONS WHICH ARE THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT SOURCES THESE BIRDS
HAVE INCLUDED ESTABLISHING UNDER
. VEHICLE PROGRAM AN EXAMPLE TO
SEND THE PERCH OF ZERO EMISSION
CARS TRANSPORTATION IS THE
SINGLE LARGEST CONTRIBUTOR TO
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS IN
CALIFORNIA TO REDUCE GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS AND FIGHT CLIMATE
POLLUTION THE STATE NEEDS TO
MAKE ALTERNATIVE FORMS OF
TRANSPORTATION MORE ACCESSIBLE
AND CONVENIENT. THEIR TWO
PRINCIPAL PROBLEMS FACING THE
STATE OF. INTENT TO PROMOTE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT OF PROJECTS FOR
EXAMPLE THE FIRST AND LAST MILE
A PROBLEM WHICH IS THE DISTANCE
THE COMMUTER NEEDS TO TRAVEL
FROM A TRANSIT STOP TO THEIR
FINAL DESTINATION OR VICE VERSA.
UGH AND SECOND DESPITE THOUSANDS
OF CALIFORNIANS UTILIZING PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION NEARLY HALF OF
CALIFORNIA'S POPULATION DOES NOT
HAVE ADEQUATE ACCESS IN RESPONSE
TO THESE PROBLEMS LOCAL ENTITIES
HAVE LOOKED INTO NEW IDEAS AND
TECHNOLOGIES LOS ANGELES SERVED
AS THE PRIME HUB OF THIS
TRANSPORTATION INNOVATION. WELL
SEVERAL PROUD OF PROPOSED AND
THEN TO WIN OUT AND OUT LOS
ANGELES INCLUDE DAILY STREET CAR
THEY REAL M. MONORAIL PROJECT A
PROPOSALS THE NONPROFIT AND
PHILANTHROPIC SECTOR HAS BECOME
HEAVILY INVOLVED. THEN OPERATE
BIG. THE MEN DOMINATED PUBLIC'S
LIKE HOUSING AND SOCIAL SERVICES
BUT NOT YET IN PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION. SAME ENTITIES
HAVE BEEN ADVOCATING ACCESS TO
PUBLIC TRANSIT SO PHILANTHROPIC
INVOLVEMENT IN TRANSIT HAS
MAINLY BEEN IN THE FORM OF FINE
FUNDING ADVOCACY WORK AND THAT'S
AN IMPORTANT ROLE BUT-
ENGAGEMENT FROM THE
PHILANTHROPIC AND NONPROFIT
SECTOR IS GOING TO HAVE TO
ACHIEVE MEANINGFUL CHANGE THEY
CAN MOVE FROM STRICTLY ADVOCACY
TO A DIRECT ROLE IN THE PROJECT.
OF CALIFORNIA JOINT POWERS
AUTHORITY LAW AUTHORIZES TO MORE
PUBLIC AGENCIES BY CONTRACTUAL
AGREEMENT TO JOINTLY EXERCISE
ANY POWER COMMON TO THE
CONTRACTING PARTIES. THERE'S NO
NEED THERE IS A NEED TO FOSTER
COLLABORATION AMONGST WILLING
AND ABLE TO TEASE TO PROVIDE THE
CRITICAL GOODS AND SERVICES FOR
WHICH THERE ARE PRIVATE SECTOR
AND NOT. ENTITIES OF WITH ME
TODAY ARE THREE NORTON EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF FAST LINK DTLA AND
THEN WE GO WHERE THAT CLIMATE
RESOLVE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU CENTER THE RUSSELL WE
HAVE- MS HILLARY NORTON FOR FAST
FROM FASTING DTLA ON THE LINE
CAN WE START WITH HER MODERATOR
PLEASE. HI I'M ON THANK YOU THIS
NORTON PLEASE GO AHEAD- THANK
YOU I'M SO EXCITED TESTIFY ON
BEHALF OF. SENATOR BARACK THOSE
WONDERFUL BILL. ACTUALLY IN MY
ROLE AS EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FAST
WITH EACH YEAR LAKE BUT ALSO AS
IT UP CALIFORNIA TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSIONER WELL COMMISSION
HASN'T TAKEN A POSITION ON THIS
YET THIS IS ALSO PART OF HOW
YOU'RE GOING TO DELIVER. MORE
ZERO EMISSION INFRASTRUCTURE IN
NEW AND INNOVATIVE WAYS I WANT
TO COMMEND UNDERGIRD LOW FOR
LIVING TOGETHER COMMUNITY- GOOD
. PROJECT LABOR GROUP AND ZERO
EMISSION MOBILITY NON. ARE CLOSE
TO THE- WE ARE PART OF THE COULD
MEAN AND WE KNOW HOW TO DELIVER
PROJECTS AND THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO ESTABLISH SOME OF
THE STUFF WITH FORTY INITIATIVE.
TO MAKE SURE THAT COMMUNITIES OF
NEED THAT ARE BEING SERVED BY
PROJECT AERIAL TRAM AND THE ONLY
THREE CAR AND SO MANY OTHERS OUT
. THE RIVER TO IN A WAY YOU
INNOVATIVE IT IS- HUH. AND IT
CREATES THE JOBS THE WAY TO THE
PROJECT LABOR. I YOUR SUPPORT
FOR THIS WONDERFUL BILL THANK
YOU.
PLEASE. GOOD AFTERNOON SURE
CONTROLLERS AND MEMBERS OF THE
SENATE TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE
MY NAME IS THE PARTICULAR
THURMOND THE LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTOR FOR CLIMATE RESULT
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION WHO FOR
THE PAST DECADE HAVE BEEN
WORKING TO ADOPT LOS ANGELES
CLIMATE CHANGE. OUR MOST
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES FROM POOR
AIR QUALITY I AM GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF SENATOR DEDUCTIBLES BILL SB
TWELVE TWENTY SIX. IN LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR THERE ARE
THREE THINGS THAT INHIBIT THE
DEVELOPMENT OF GREEN
INFRASTRUCTURE. ONE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS LIMITED ACCESS TO
DOING. TO LIMITED CAPACITY UP
FROM NONPROFITS TO APPLY FOR
GRANTS AND IF THIS GOVERNMENT.
IN THREE AN INABILITY FOR
PRIVATE CAPITAL TO REACH LOW
INCOME COMMUNITY. THIS BILL
ADDRESSES ALL THREE DEFICIENCIES
BY ALLOWING COLLABORATION AMONG
PRIVATE PUBLIC NONPROFIT
PARTNERSHIPS. SB TWELVE TWENTY
SIX- JUST THAT I'D LIKE TO MAKE
THREE POINTS FIRST CURRENT LAW
DOES NOT ALLOW PUBLIC AGENCIES
PRIVATE AND VIEW THE NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS THAT DR SPRING.
AND EXPERTISE. FOR JOINT POWERS
REPORT THE PURPOSE FACILITY ZERO
TRIP BETWEEN SYSTEM. SECOND THE
STATE IS WILL SHORT OF ITS GOAL
METER ALREADY AND GAS REDUCTION
. THIS IS ANOTHER TOOL IN THE
TOOL THAT WILL PROMOTE- DISH.
EMISSIONS REDUCTION. SB TWELVE
TWENTY OVERCOMES EXISTING
CARRIERS LIKE PUBLIC AGENCY NOT
BEING ABLE TO ACCESS PRIVATE
CAPITAL COMPETE BUT- NONPROFIT
ENTITIES LATIN GOVERNANCE
STRUCTURE AND CAPACITY COMPETE
OR GO TRANSPORTATION CAUGHT.
PRIVATE ENTITIES WITH WE OFFER
THESE PROJECTS NOT HELPING
EXCITING. AND FIFTY FRIENDS. SO
WHEN WIN WIN THAT ADDRESS THE
SHORT. FOR PRIVATE PUBLIC NON
WORKING. LAST WEEK AB TWELVE WE
CIRCLE OFFICE TO ADDRESS THE
MOST SIGNIFICANT SOURCE THE
EMISSIONS IN THE TRANSPORTATION
SECTOR. BEING OUT GREEN PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
THE LOWER GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS IMPROVE AIR QUALITY
AND IMPROVE THE QUALITY OF OUR
PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION. THANKS
GONZALEZ YOUR CONTINUED
LEADERSHIP MEMBERS OF THE SENATE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR ATTENTION ON THIS
MATTER I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR ARTICLE ON SB TWELVE TWENTY
SIX. THANK YOU MISTER WEBSTER-
SO WE'LL NOW WE'LL TAKE IT TO
THE GALLERY FOR ANYONE ELSE
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF. SB TWELVE TWENTY SIX PLEASE
COME FORWARD. HER MILE ABOVE A
CAL STAR IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT HERE
IN THE GALLERY OF SB TWELVE
TWENTY SIX. R. DIGER NOW WITH
UCLA SUPPORT OKAY WELL THEN
WE'LL GO TO THE TELECONFERENCE
LINE WONDERFUL. YOU JUMPED RIGHT
AHEAD I LOVE IT OKAY- THAT
MODERATOR TO HAVE ANYONE ELSE IN
THE QUEUEWHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB TWELVE
TWENTY SIX. THANK YOU IF YOU'D
LIKE TO PASS THE PIPE MYSTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SB TWELVE TWENTY SIX
LEAST. ONE THEN ZERO. OTTOLINE
ONE THIRTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD
. HI MY NAME IS CHRIS REED- I'M
FROM THE BAY AREA CLEAN AIR
COALITION AND I'D LIKE TO- SAY
THAT WE SUPPORT THE FOR OUR
HEALTH EMPLOYMENT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ME JUST A MOMENT OUR
NEXT PERSON. NINE ONE EIGHTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AFTERNOON SHARE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS CHRIS WHAT
THE NUMBERS IN THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY BUSINESSFEDERATION IN
SUPPORT OF AT EIGHT FORTY FIVE
SIX THANK YOU. I AM SURE THERE
ARE NO FURTHER LINES IN SUPPORT
PLEASE CONTINUE. OKAY THANK YOU.
ARE NOW WILL TAKE IT TO THE
OPPOSITION THERE IS NO ONE
REGISTERED- AS LEAD OPPOSITION
FOR THE BILL SO WE'LL- ASK
ANYONE HERE IN THE GALLERY WOULD
LIKE TO OPPOSE SB TWELVE TWENTY
SIX. C. NINE. MODERATOR WILL
TAKE IT BACK TO YOU FOR ANYONE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO OPPOSE SB
TWELVE TWENTY SIX PLEASE. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR IF YOU'D LIKE
TO. SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OFS. E.
TWELFTH TWENTY SIX PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND ZERO. NICENO LINES IN
OPPOSITION YOU MAKE. THANK YOU
NOW WE'LL TAKE IT BACK TO THE
DICE FOR ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS BY MEMBERS. SENATOR
NEWMAN. AND I'M JUST REAL QUICK
LIKE YOU DID THIS IS A GOOD BILL
I'D LIKE TO. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
ME INCLUDES A CO AUTHOR IF SUCH
AT SUCH A TIME WHEN I'D LIKE TO
MOVE THE BILL WHEN THE JUDGE.
THANK YOU SENATOR RUBIO. SIMILAR
COMMENTS FIVE- ALSO A CO AUTHOR
AND I LIKE TO ALSO JUST THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING IT
FORWARD DOWN AND HE'S ALREADY.
THANK YOU. GREAT SENATOR. ALAN
I'D LIKE TO BE ADDED AS QUOTE AS
WELL THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THIS.
THAT ARCHULETA YES I DO LIKE TO
BE A CO AUTHOR NICK WITH
KNOWLEDGE VIA THE AUTHOR YOU
KNOW WITH WITH THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE IN LOS ANGELES. THAT USE
TRANSPORTATION EVERY SINGLE DAY
THE HARD WORKING PEOPLE HAVE GOT
TO GET FROM POINT A TO POINT B.
WE'VE GOT TO GET THEM- TAKEN
CARE OF AND I THINK THIS IS WHAT
THIS DOES. GIVE THEM AN
OPPORTUNITY TO PARTICIPATE IN
WHAT WE'RE ALL TRYING TO
CALIFORNIA PRESERVE ARE ARE ARE-
GOOD QUALITY CARE AND MAKE IT
BETTER. AND IT WHATEVER WE CAN
DO TO BRING IN. THE HARD WORK
BETTER RIGHT HE'S BUSES AND
TRANSPORTATION I THINK IT'S A
GREAT START AND I'M JUST SO GLAD
YOU PUT IT ON THE TABLE. I WILL
BE VOTING FOR IT AN APOLOGY. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU WE HAVE A MOTION
BY SENATOR NEWMAN AND SENATOR.
SENATOR BATES ARE QUICK QUESTION
I NOTICED IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS THAT. THE MOMENT DID
REMOVED FROM THE ABILITY TO
ISSUE BOND DEBT IS THAT ACCURATE
. I'M SORRY CENTER THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS DID- REMOVE THE
AUTHORITY TO ISSUE BOND OUT FOR
THIS KIND OF A GPA OF SACK KRAFT
BECAUSE I THINK THERE WAS A
CONCERN ABOUT. ABOUT THAT WITH
YOU KNOW NOPE RIGHT OVERSIGHT
BASICALLY THAT'S RIGHT THEN THE
OTHER AUTHORITIES THAT ARE
GRANTED TO- GPAS BETWEEN TO
PUBLIC AGENCIES INCLUDE
OVERSIGHT OF A SEQUEL ISSUES
BROWN AFTER ALL OF THAT. THAT
DOES REMAIN BECAUSE THERE WOULD
BE A PUBLIC PARTNER IN THIS IS
THAT CORRECT AS FAR AS I.
UNDERSTAND YES. OKAY YES THANK
YOUNG DID YOU KNOW THAT I. YES
ON BOTH OF THOSE QUESTIONS NO
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
SENATOR THAT ALSO WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE WELL THANK YOU ALL FOR
YOUR COMMENTS APPRECIATE- YOUR
US SIGNS OF SUPPORT AND WITH NO
OPPOSITION I ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU THANK YOU- MISTER
CHIEF CONSULTANT CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SENATORS GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ I
BATES NOT VOTING TODAY. WE GOT
TO DO A LITTLE RESEARCH ALLEN.
ALLEN AYE ARCHULETA AYE
ARCHULETA AYE BAKER. AYE BECKER
AYE CORTESE. AYE CORTESE AYE
DOLLY. DOT DODD AYE LIMÓN.
MCGUIRE ACQUIRE HIGH MELENDEZ
MEN MEN HI NEWMAN NEWMAN HI
RUBIO RUBIO HIGH SKINNER BY
CASKEY WILK. TENS OF ZERO LEAVE
THE BILL ON CALL THANK YOU
SENATOR THANK YOU COLLEAGUES
OKAY AND WHILE WE'RE WAITING FOR
ANOTHER AUTHOR AND I BELIEVE WE
HAVE A FEW AUTHORS ON THIS- THE
DIESIS WELL WE'LL GO AHEAD AND
TAKE THE CONSENT CALENDAR- SO IF
WE CAN. TAKE A MOTION ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR LIVE THERE
ANOTHER DOG THANK YOU- SO MISTER
CHIEF CONSULTANT AND THESE ARE
ITEMS CONSISTING OF ITEM TO SB
NINE FIVE WESSEL I AM NOT S. C.
R. NINETY SEVEN ELSE AND ITEM
TEN S. C. R. NINETY EIGHT
MCGUIRE WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR DODD MISTER CHIEF
CONSULTANT CAN YOU PLEASE CALL.
ALL ON CONSENT NUMBER ONE
CONSISTING OF S. B. NINE EIGHTY
FIVE THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. SENATORS
GONZALEZ HI GONZALEZ I BATES. I
KNOW CONSENT WELL CONSENT ALL
RIGHT BATES HI HELEN HI ALAN AYE
ARCHULETA AYE PARTULA AYE BECKER
. BAKER HI CORTESE CORTESE HI
DOLLY. DOT DOT HI LIMON WHERE
MCGUIRE HI MELENDEZ MEN MEN AYE
NEWMAN NEWMAN AYE RUBIO RUBIO
HIGH SKINNER BY CASKEY WILK.
ELEVEN ELEVEN ZERO OKAY ELEVEN
ZERO ON THAT CONSENT CALENDAR MY
APOLOGIES CONSENT CALENDAR ONE
WILL BEJUST FOR SB NINE EIGHTY
FIVE THE SECOND CONSENT CALENDAR
WILL CONSIST OF THE TWO- NAMING
IS STR NINETY SEVEN AND S. T. R.
NINETY EIGHT SO WE'LL HAVE TO
TAKE A SECOND TO A ROLE ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR NUMBER TWO FOR
THOSE TWO NAMES AS WE'VE DONE IN
THE PAST. MISTER CHIEF
CONSULTANT CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. YOU CAN'T CONSENT
CALENDAR ON CONSENT CALENDAR TWO
CONSISTING OF S. C. R. NINETY
SEVEN AND S. C. R. NINETY EIGHT.
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I BATES. BATES
AYE ALLEN. ALAN HI ARCHULETA
ARCHULETA HI BECKER BAKER HI
CORTESE CORTESE I. AND DOLLY.
DOT DODD HI LIMÓN MCGUIRE
MCGUIRE HI MELENDEZ MAN MAN I
NEWMAN NEWMAN AYE RUBIO RUBIO
HIGH SKINNER WHY CASKEY WILK.
OKAY ELEVEN ZERO ON THAT CONSENT
CALENDAR NUMBER TWO THANK YOU
MEMBERS OKAY SO WE GOT THROUGH
THAT SO NOW WE'LL MOVE ON TO
FILE ITEM ELEVEN SB NINE
SEVENTEEN BY SENATOR PACKER.
THERE'S A LOT. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS OPTION PERCENT S.
B. NINE ONE SEVEN THE SEAMLESS
TRANSIT TRANSFORMATION ACT
MOTORSHIP MOTIVATION IS STILL
SIMPLE REALLY WE SHOULD HAVE A
WORLD CLASS TRANSIT SYSTEM IN
THE BAY AREA RIGHT NOW THERE HAS
THE SECOND WORST CONGESTION IN
THE COUNTRY- NEXT LOS ANGELES
AFTER BESTING BILLIONS OF PUBLIC
TRANSIT RECENT DECADES ONLY 4%
OF ALL BEER CHIPS ARE MADE WITH
TRANSIT. IN RECENT YEARS EVEN
PRIOR TO CODE RIDERSHIP ACROSS
ALL TRANSIT SYSTEMS HAS FALLEN.
UGH CHOOSE A QUALITY DROP BUSES
STUCK IN TRAFFIC LONGER
TRANSFERRING THIS FREQUENCY AS
FAR FROM A SEAMLESS SYSTEM.
RIGHT NOW IT'S TOO HARD TO GET
FROM POINT A TO POINT B. MANY
HAVE TO PAY TRANSFER PENALTIES
SUCH A PAINT JOB LIKE EXTRA
DOUBLE FARES FROM MOVING FOR
ENTRANCE SYSTEM TO ANOTHER-
RIGHT I SHOULDN'T HAVE TO
NAVIGATE THROUGH THE LOOKING GO.
BETTER MAPS BETTER SCIENCE MARC
CONNECTIONS BETWEEN BUSES TRAINS
LIHT RAIL AND- FERRIES. OTHER
REGIONS AROUND THE WORLD HAVE
TACKLE TRANSIT FREIGHT
FRAGMENTATION WENT FROM. SEATTLE
TO LONDON TO GERMANY AND WE'RE
NOT TRYING TO REINVENT THE WHEEL
THE SOLUTIONS DO EXIST. SO THIS
TAKES UP THIS BILL TAKES A MAJOR
STEP FORWARD TO INSTITUTIONALIZE
THE SEAMLESS AND RESILIENT
TRANSIT SYSTEM IN THE NEAR TERM
. TO REPORT A CONVERSATIONS
WE'VE BEEN HAVING FOR YEARS- AND
FROM THE BILL AND SOME STRUCTURE
AROUND INTEGRATION. READ THE AD
HOC WAY PROGRESS IS MADE UP
UNTIL NOW. SO THE BILL TO FIRST
STANDARDIZED WAYFARING AND
MAPPING. SO WE NEED A
COMPREHENSIVE REGIONAL TRANSIT
MAP RATHER THAN CURRENTLY TWENTY
SEVEN DIFFERENT WAY FINDING
SYSTEMS. NO MAPS AND SIGNAGE IS
VERY MADE IT MAKES IT HARD FOR
WRITERS TO KNOW HOW TO MAKE
CONNECTIONS SECOND. REAL TIME
TRANSIT DATA TO IMPROVE THE
RIGHT EXPERIENCE WRITERS KNOW
WHEN THE NEXT BUS IS ARRIVING
ACTUALLY AND WHAT I COULD SEE
THAT BUS LOOKS LIKE. THIRD WHAT
IF I CONNECTED NETWORK PLANNED
TO FOCUS OUR INVESTMENTS TO GET
BUSES MOVING FASTER. MTC WHAT
THE CLUB FORMS TARGETS FOR KEY.
A ROADS IN OUR NETWORK AND
PROPOSED SOLUTIONS FOR CAN'T
TRAFFIC CONGESTION. FOURTH AN
INTEGRATED FARE STRUCTURE. THIS
MUST INCLUDE NO COST TRANSFERS
ACROSS THEME AND LOCAL TRANSIT
AGENCIES. ANY THE CURRENT
TRANSFER PENALTY THAT REFER TO
THAT MANY PEOPLE PAY. BY VIRTUE
OF HAVING TO PAY DOUBLES AND A
TRIPLE AFFAIRS METAL LEFT OF
THEIR- RESPECTIVE TRIP. SEGMENTS
MUST PROPOSE A COMMON REGIONAL
FARE FOR REGIONAL SERVICE. AND
PILOTING A MULTI AGENCY PASSED
PRODUCT DOESN'T OCCUR BY DAY
PASS AND GET ACCESS TO ALL BAY
AREA TRANSIT. THESE POSSIBLE
IMPORTANT WORK OF THE MTC FARE
INTEGRATION TASK FORCE. UP AND
HE'S ALREADY IDENTIFIED ALLOCATE
A PORTION OF THAT FUNDING.
THEY'LL BE NEEDED TO IMPLEMENT
THE PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL. A
BILL AND BACKSTOPS TO ENSURE NO
AGENCIES WILL BE ASKED TO GO
SIGNIFICANT. UNFUNDED MANDATES.
WE WORKING EXTRA CLOSELY MTC IN
THE TRANSIT AGENCIES. THANK YOU
OVER THE FIRST ROUND OF
AMENDMENTS ADDRESS NUMBER
CONCERNS IDENTIFIED WE'RE CLOSE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THEM. AROUND
THE FAIR CITY PROVISIONS THE
BILL AND I'M COMMITTED TO FIND
GET INTO PLACE FOR THE FEEL
COMFORTABLE. WITH THINGS OR
STRUCTURE TO PRESERVE THE SHERRY
DUTIES. I THANK COMMITTEE STAFF
TRANSITION STEP OF LEADERSHIP
AND ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS WHO
SPENT MANY MANY MANY HOURS
WORKING THROUGH THESE ISSUES
WITH US. LOOK FOR TO CONTINUE
THAT DISCUSSION. TESTIFYING
TODAY IN SUPPORT WHEN LITVAK SB
P. PUBLIC POLICY VERY COUNCIL
AND REBEKAH LONG. ACTING
DIRECTOR LEGISLATION A PUBLIC
AFFAIRS FIRM TO SEE. THANK YOU
SENATOR PACKARD US SO WE'LL
START WITH- WHEN LIFT BACK ON
THE COASTLINE WITH THE AREA
COUNCIL PLEASE. GOOD AFTERNOON
CARE GONZALEZ ASSEMBLY MEMBER MY
NAME IS WHEN I WENT BACK AND THE
SENIOR VICE PRESIDENT OF PUBLIC
POLICY AT THE BARE COUNTS ALL.
WE ARE PLEASED TO CO SPONSOR SB
NINE ONE SEVEN THE SCENE WITH
TRANSIT TRANSFORMATION ACT THEIR
COUNCIL FOUND IN PART OVER
SEVENTY FIVE YEARS AGO AND WE
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENTS THAT
ARE CRITICAL TO THE BAY AREA
INCLUDING REGIONAL MEASURE
THREE. AND MEDICARE ARE ARE.
MOMENT OF. TRACK AND THE TIE HAS
COME CHANGE THE WAY WE THINK
ABOUT TRANSIT POLICY. OVER THE
PAST YEAR THE COUNCIL HAS
CONDUCTED THE MONTHLY SURVEY
TRACKING EMPLOYER ATTITUDES
ABOUT RETURNING TO THE OFFICE.
OUR FINDINGS SHOW THAT 70% OF
EMPLOYERS ANTICIPATE EMPLOYEES
WILL BE BACK IN THE OFFICE THREE
DAYS A WEEK OR FEWER. EMPLOYERS
ANTICIPATE THAT TWO THIRDS OF
EMPLOYEES WILL BE IN THE OFFICE
ON ANY GIVEN DAY. ABOUT ONE
QUARTER OF THE WORKFORCE FOR
MAIN FOR REMOTE AND 50% OF
EMPLOYERS THINK THAT THEIR
EMPLOYEES WILL OPERATE ON
NONTRADITIONAL WORK HOURS AS OUR
SURVEY DATA SHOWS PATTERNS HAVE
SHIFTED AND NOW OUR TRANSIT
SYSTEM MONTH QUICKLY ADAPT. FOR
ITS VERY SURVIVAL. TO ATTRACT
RIDERS TRANSIT MATH BETTER SERVE
A GREATER RANGE OF TRAVEL TRAVEL
PATTERNS NOT JUST COMMUTE
TRAFFIC PART OF THIS IS MAKING
TRANSIT MORE SEAMLESS USER. IN
CONNECTED AT OUR REGION THE
STRATEGY THAT THEIR INTEGRATION
WAY FINDING AND SERVICE
INTEGRATION FOR UNANIMOUSLY
AGREED TO AND ARE REGION'S BLUE
RIBBON TASK FORCE AND PRIOR
PULLING COMPLETED BY NPC
INDICATES THAT THESE POLICIES
ARE OVERWHELMINGLY. POPULAR
AMONG THE PUBLIC. I NINE ONE SO
IS CRITICAL BECAUSE THE HOLDS UP
ALL. DELIVER ON THE GOALS AGREED
TO AND ARE REGION'S TRANSIT
RECOVERY PLANNING AND MAKES
TRANSIT AGENCY PARTICIPATION
MANDATORY. WITHOUT SB NINE ONE
SEVEN OUR REGION WILL BE VERY
CHALLENGED IN DELIVERING AN
INTEGRATED SYSTEM AND ANYONE
AGENCY COULD HOLD UP THE
PROCESS. THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO ANSWERING
YOUR QUESTIONS. THANK YOU OUR
NEXT MOVE ON TO REBEKAH LONG
FROM- THE METROPOLITAN
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION MTC
ALSO ON THE COASTLINE MISS LONG
. GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU
CHAIR GONZALEZ FLETCHER BATES
AND MEMBERS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK TO YOU TODAY AND TO
CENTER BACKER FOR ALTERING THIS
BILL MY NAME IS REBECCA ON ON
THAT ACTOR LEGISLATION. PAIRS
THAT YOU SEE THE REGIONAL
TRANSPORTATION PLANNING AGENCY
FOR THE NINE COUNTY SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA. AND HE'S HE
SUPPORTS SB NINE SEVENTEEN WHICH
WE BELIEVE WILL HELP THE BAY
AREA CONTINUE THE SIGNIFICANT
PROGRESS WE'RE MAKING TOWARD A
MORE INTEGRATED AND WRITER FOCUS
TRANSIT SYSTEM. SB NINE
SEVENTEEN IS A TRULY BOTTOM UP
BILL IT'S PROVISIONS CAN BE
TRACED DIRECTLY TO THE
RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE BLUE
RIBBON TRANSIT RECOVERY TASK
FORCE. THAT WOULD CONVENE BY MTC
AND MAY TWENTY TO PAY RESPONSE
TO THE DRAMATIC LOSS OF
RIDERSHIP DO THAT CORRECT
NINETEEN THE TASK FORCE WAS
CHARGED WITH IDENTIFYING
TRANSFORMATIONAL CHANGES. NEEDED
TO ATTRACT MORE RIDERS TO OUR
TRANSIT SYSTEM. NOT TO
PREPAYMENT LEVELS BUT THE SCALE
NEEDED TO HELP ACHIEVE OUR
REGION. OUR WATER ROCK SCIENCE
WHAT RIGHT MOST ONE IS THE THAT
FASTER LARA. EASIER TO NAVIGATE
AND MORE AFFORDABLE WITH SIMPLER
FARES. SB NINE SEVENTEEN FOCUSES
ON THESE KEY WRITER PRIORITIES
WHILE ACKNOWLEDGING NOT
SUFFICIENT RESOURCES WILL BE
ESSENTIAL TO SUCCESSFUL OUTCOMES
AND IT BUILDS UPON AND HE'S HE'S
EXISTING AUTHORITY IN A MANNER
THAT REQUIRES COLLABORATION AND
CONSULTATION WITH OUR PRINCE
AGENCY PARTNERS. AS THE BILL
MOVES THROUGH THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS TO CONTINUE DIALOGUE IS
CRUCIAL TO CRAFTING A FINAL BILL
THAT WILL HAVE A MEANINGFUL
IMPACT AND HAVE THE SUPPORT AT
THE KEY AGENCIES IN CHARGE OF
ITS IMPLEMENTATION. IN CLOSING
I'D LIKE TO THANK CENTER BECKER
AND HIS STAFF FOR THEIR TRULY
COLLABORATIVE EFFORT AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FAIR EITHER.
THANKS THANK YOU MISS LONG. OKAY
SO WE'VE CONCLUDED OUR LEAD
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE
SEVENTEEN SO WE'LL TAKE IT TO
THE GALLERY ANYONE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB
NINE SEVENTEEN PLEASE COME
FORWARD. C. NINE. A MODERATOR
WILL TAKE IT BACK TO YOU ANYONE
ELSE WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SB NINE SEVENTEEN
JUST NAME AN ORGANIZATION PLEASE
. THANK YOU IF YOU'D LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT SB NINE
SEVENTEEN HE'S PRESS ONE ZERO.
MOTIVO ONE FORTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MATT ROBINSON ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY COUNTY ASSOCIATION OF
GOVERNMENTS OF SAN DIEGO WE
ACTUALLY REPORT IN CONCEPT
POSITION ON THIS BILL AND LOOK
FORWARD TO SENATOR PACKARD
CONTINUED TO WORK WITH REGIONAL
STAKEHOLDERS IN ORDER TO ACT TO
FINALIZE TO FILL SO. THANK
MOVOTO LINE ONE FORTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON I NEED A WIDER OR WELL
WITH A OR P. AND ON BEHALF OF
THE OR THE IT'S BEEN THREE
MILLION MEMBERS OF THE BOARD SB
NINE SEVENTY AND- IF YOU WILL
FOR A LINE. TO- SET PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THIS IS YOUR LIFE
CRACKLE. CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THE ALAMEDA COUNTY DEMOCRATIC
PARTY AND STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU WILL FOR OUR LIVES ONE
THIRTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
LINE ONE THIRTY FOUR THANK YOU.
VERY I THINK THE CRITICAL RETOOL
WITH THE BAY AREA CLEAN AIR
COALITION AGAIN AND I JUST
WANTED TO SAY WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE NINETY SEVENTEEN
BECAUSE IT WOULD GREATLY IMPROVE
BETH TRANSIT THANK YOU. NEXAVAR
LINE TWO OH NINE. GOOD AFTERNOON
SURE MEMBERS MY NAME IS RYAN JOY
CALLING ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIAN
BEACH IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
NINE SEVENTEEN THANK YOU. THANK
YOU WILL BORDERLINE TO A LATIN.
HI THIS IS LAURIE WELLS AT THE
MARIN COUNTY BICYCLE COALITION
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOUR
BOTTOM LINE ONE THIRTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS A
CAREER SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
TRANSFORM AS A CO SPONSOR OF THE
BILL WE ARE INTRAPARTUM UNITED
AND THE U. S. ARMY RIGHT NOW
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ALL PLACE
YOUR LINE I'M TIRED OF. MY ONE
EIGHTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
CAN YOU HEAR ME. HOW CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES I CAN. ALL RIGHT
ELEVEN- WITH FRIENDS OF HEALTH
RATING- IN THE BAY AREA- FINALLY
IN SUPPORT OF S. B. NINE ONE
SEVEN IF YOU HAVE A REGIONALLY
WORKING AT. A FIFTY. IF YOU WERE
A LINE. TO TWELVE- HI THIS IS
NICK RASCH- I'M FROM THAT PART
BE- ASSISTED IN THE RESCUE
COMPANY BERKELEY AND TALK FOR.
THANK YOU BYE ONE SIXTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. JONATHAN CAST
DIGGING ON BEHALF OF- IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU LINE TWO ONE
THREE TWO THIRTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. OF THE FIFTY IN CHRISTMAS
POLICY DIRECTOR AT IN THE AREA
WE ARE EXPOSED ON PURPOSE BUILT
IN STRONG OR THANK YOU AT. NINE
SEVEN EIGHT. THANK YOU LINE ONE
NINETY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO THIS IS MARLENE UNTIL YOU
REPRESENTING MY LOOK TOGETHER
AND- PARK WHICH ARE BASED ON THE
PART AND WE'RE IN SUPPORT OF SB. NINE SEVENTEEN. THANK YOU.
ZERO EIGHT. HELLO THIS IS ADAM
HALL REPRESENTING ASSOCIATED
STUDENTS TRANSPORTATION
SOLUTIONS OF PANELISTS THE
UNIVERSITY NOW WE ARE ALSO
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
FOR ALL. THANK YOU LINE ONE
FIFTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I WON
FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NEARLY YES- THANK YOU MY NAME IS
REALLY MISS THAT LOOKING BACK ON
THE SHIP REPORT CARD WORKED AT
ARTHUR ASHE IF YOU SEPARATE HI.
THANK YOU Q. TEN. YOU CAN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YOU WILL GO TO LINE TWO NINETEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO BERMAN
EVERY. YES WE CAN HEAR YOU WERE
TAKING NAME AN ORGANIZATION
PLEASE IN SUPPORT OF S. B. NINE
ONE SEVEN PLEASE. YEAH THIS IS A
HARD LEVEL- I AM WITH A PART OF
FOR MY FUTURE CALLING IN FROM
RICHMOND CALIFORNIA. I STRONGLY
SUPPORT SB NINE SEVENTEEN AS THE
POLITICAL. THANK YOU IN OUR SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA THANK YOU
THANK YOU SIR. IN NINETY TWO
TWENTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
THIS IS NECRO A LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST WITH- THREE FIFTY BAY
AREA ACTION FALLING IN SUPPORT
OF- NINE ONE SEVEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU LINE TO FIFTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS CAN'T
THE CHRONO DIRECTOR PROGRAMS
RESOURCE NORTH BAY AREA FALLING
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AT THE NINE
ONE SEVEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU
LINE ONE OH TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD
. HELLO YOU'RE YOU'RE NOT
REPRESENTING IRAQ IN ORDER AT
THE NINE. CLINTON THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR THERE ARE NO FURTHER
LINES INTO COURT YOU MAY
CONTINUE THANK YOU MODERATOR AND
WE DO HAVE ONE OTHER- LEAD
WITNESS AND SUPPORT WITH
CONCERNS- THAT IS A MISS AMANDA
CREW WAS WITH S. US DISCO BAY
AREA RAPID TRANSIT IS SHE ON THE
LINE. MODERATOR IN KICKING ONE
MOMENT. YES I'M HERE OKAY MISS
CHRIS PLEASE GO AHEAD. FOUR
EIGHT GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS MY NAME IS AMANDA CREW
LINED THE LEGISLATIVE MANAGER
FOR THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA
RAPID TRANSIT DISTRICT ARE. THE
BART BOARD HAS ADOPTED SUPPORT
IF AND THEN IF THEY SPEND ON SP
NINE ONE SEVEN. DISTRICT COURT
BUILDING FACTORED AND
RECOMMENDATIONS WITHIN THE
TRANSIT TRANSFORMATION ACTING
PLAN. THE CARE COORDINATION AND
INTEGRATION STUDY. A BELIEVE
THAT STILL REASONABLE STANDARDS
AND FINE WINE AND BEANS. AND
THAT OPERATORS ARE ABLE TO MEET
WITHOUT PLACING. UNDUE PENALTIES
FOR NONCOMPLIANCE. EARLY MARCH
ART ALONG WITH OTHER OPERATORS
HAVE FOR HELLO. WITH
THUNDERBIRDS OFFICE UNTIL
AMENDMENT AND WE'VE HOW THE
REVISED LANGUAGE ADDRESSES EARLY
CONCERN REGARDING THE CONNECTED
NETWORK PLAN BACK IN WAY FINDING
REQUIREMENTS. STANDARDS FOR REAL
TIME TRANSIT INFORMATION AND THE
WITHHOLDING OF ST FRANCIS WITHIN. FIVE APART THERE REMAINS
AROUND I THOUGHT HAVE BEEN IN
THE TRANSIT FARE STRUCK. WHICH
WE HAVE AT THE AUTHOR.
APPARENTLY WRITTEN AT THE ONE
SEVEN WHAT EFFECT REMOVE THE
VILLAGE FIRST TRANSIT OFFER.
THAT AIRS INSTANCE THIS IS
ALREADY EMPTY. OUR LIKE MANY
REGIONAL EIGHT DEPENDENT ON
THEIR REVENUES UNDER OPERATE
INCOME BUDGETS. WITH US CONCERN
THAT DECISIONS GUARDINO RECENT
FAIRS FACT WILL BE MADE BY AND
YOU OTHER THAN OUR FOR. IT'S A
GREAT ACCOUNTABILITY BETWEEN
EMPATHY AND THE AGENCIES
PROVIDING TRANSIT SERVICE. IT'S
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES MAY
FLEXIBLE. WORSE FOR READ IT THE
LACK OF AVAILABLE AND BEYOND THE
BILL A THREE YEAR PILOT. WELL WE
UNDERSTAND AND IT'S DECISION
MAKE PROCESS THANK TRANSIT UP
AND BUT WE HOPE YOU CAN WORK
WITH THIS. AND THE STATE AND
AGENCY. OTHER WAYS TO ADDRESS
THESE GOVERNMENT THE CARD. WE
APPRECIATE THIS CONTINUED
WILLINGNESS TO RECEIVE OPERATOR
IN. AND THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE THAT. ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU MISS CRUZ SO WE'VE CONCLUDED
OUR WITNESSES AND- OFTEN
SUPPORTIVE SB NINE ONE SEVEN SO
WE'LL MOVE ON TO OPPOSITION- TO
SP NINE ONE SEVEN WE DON'T HAVE
ANYTHING ANYONE REGISTERED
FORMALLY BUT- IS THERE ANYONE
FROM THE GALLERY WHO WOULD LIKE
TO OPPOSE SB NINE ONE SEVEN
PLEASE. YES PLEASE COME FORWARD. JUST GIVE ALL COMING AFTER THE
GOLDEN GATE BRIDGE
TRANSLATIONALLY DISTRICT AND THE
NAPA VALLEY TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITY WE LIVE IN OPPOSE
POSITION WE HAVE A SUPPORTIVE
ABOUT IT AND WE SHARE THE
CONCERNS EXPRESSED BY PART AND
WE LOOK FORWARD TO GETTING TO
WORK WITH CENTER BACKGROUND.
VERY MUCH THANK YOU SO ANYONE
ELSE WOULD LIKE TO- SUPPORT WITH
CONCERNS OR OPPOSE AT THIS TIME
C. NONE US ALL GO BACK TO THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE MODERATOR DO
WE HAVE ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
OPPOSE SB NINE ONE SEVEN PLEASE
. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR IF YOU
WISH TO A QUOTE SB NINE ONE
SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. OKAY JUST A MOMENT THANK YOU.
NINE ONE FORTY ONE YES GO AHEAD
. YEAH THANK YOU SHARE IN
MEMBERS MY NAME IS CHRIS PEOPLE
I'VE BEEN INVOLVED IN BAY AREA
BRANDISHES ABOUT THAT HERE- ON A
BAY AREA AND THE BOARD FOR
TWENTY FOUR YEARS. AND I'M
SPEAKING TODAY ON MY OWN BEHALF-
I. TAKE THE POSITION OF YOUR
COULD OPPOSE THE BILL AND WHAT
AMENDED. IT TRIED TO DO SOME
GOOD THINGS BUT IT DOES NOT
PROVIDE LONG TERM FUNDING TO
GOOGLE. AND IT DOES NOT
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT SOME
COMMUNITIES ARE SUPPORTIVE OF
TRANSIT BOTH IN TERMS OF GAS. IN
IN TERMS OF LAND USE THAT IS
AFFORDABLE BRANDS THAT OTHER
COMMUNITIES. PROVIDE I'M AT BUT
NO LAND USE SUPPORT IN MANY
COUNTIES PROVIDE NEITHER LAND
USE THAT FOR. NO MORE- FINANCIAL
SUPPORT- THEN I HAD TO HAVE SOME
CONCERNS ABOUT IT HE HE AS
AHRENSBURG DOES DETERRENT BURKE
WITH A GATE AND BROUGH. MTC AND
THE STATE- AND STATE AND THE
THAT ARE PEOPLE WORE WHITE AND
RED. OKAY THANK YOU SIR WE WILL
TAKE THAT AS A WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION AT THIS POINT SO MOVE
ON TO ADDITIONAL OF FOLKS WOULD
LIKE TO OPT- JUST FINE
OPPOSITION TO SB NINE ONE SEVEN
PLEASE MODERATOR. THERE ARE NO
FURTHER LINES IN OPPOSITION OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SO WE'VE
CONCLUDED SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION
WILL TAKE IT BACK TO MEMBERS FOR
DISCUSSION. ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS- CENTER CORTESE MOVES
THE BILL SENATE ARCHULETA ANY
QUESTIONS YES I'D LIKE TO MAKE
SOME COMMENTS FROM THE TIMES
THAT I'VE BEEN IN SAN FRANCISCO
NO DOUBT. THERE'S DENSITY
THERE'S TRAFFIC THERE'S PEOPLE
TRYING TO GET. DOW AND I THINK
THIS IS A GREAT BILL BECAUSE IT
OPENS THE DOOR- TO
TRANSPORTATION ISSUES ACROSS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IT MENTION
LOS ANGELES IN YOUR OPENING
COMMENTS AND IT TOO HAS ITS
PROBLEMS AND I THINK WITH THIS
IT GIVES THE PEOPLE WHO GO TO
WORK EVERY SINGLE DAY THAT THAT
WHAT I'VE BEEN TOLD SHE TOLD AND
LEARNED THAT YOU MIGHT HAVE TO
BE A HERE TO FOR HER TO TRY FOR
BUT I'M TO GET TOWORK- THAT
BLUE. POLICE HAVE HAD TO PAY
THREE OR FOUR TIMES. FOR
TRANSFERRED THIS WILL ELIMINATE
THAT. AND THE SECOND THING THAT
SEAN PORTENT IS THE CONFUSION
FROM POINT A TO POINT B. YOU'VE
ADDRESSED ALL THAT SO I SEE NO-
NO ISSUE BUT TO GO FORWARD. THIS
IS A GREAT OPPORTUNITY TO BRING
IT THE METROPOLITAN TRANSIT
COMMISSION AND EVERYONE IN SAN
FRANCISCO TOGETHER AND I'M
HOPING THAT THEY GOT ALL
TOGETHER AND WORK THINGS OUT BUT
HERE'S A HERE'S A QUESTION I
HAVE. BECAUSE EACH AND EVERY
TRANSFERRED- BRING REVENUE COST
COST COST HAVE YOU BEEN ABLE TO
ADDRESS THE LACK OF. I'M VERY.
PATIENT AGENCIES AND HOWARD THE
DUCK IT HOW IS IT GOING TO BE
MADE UP. THANK YOU YEP A BIG
PART OF WHAT WE'VE BEEN WORKING
THROUGH AND- YOU KNOW THE CARD
FOR SOME THINGS LIKE WAY FINDING
FOR INTEGRATION ARE GONNA COST
MONEY WE DON'T HAVE TO CAN BE
PROHIBITIVELY EXPENSIVE BUT- THE
KICK AND PROCESS IMMEDIATELY SO
WE CAN ACCURATE ESTIMATE OF WHAT
SOME OF THINGS ARE GOING TO COST
TO NTC THE OPERATE CAN. BE
PRETTY I.
THANK YOU MANAGER. THANK YOU
CENTER ARCHULETA WE HAVE A
MOTION BY SENATOR CORTESE US
SENATOR BACK OR WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE JUDGES PRESIDE THE
CALLERS AND I COME FROM AT YOU A
WHOLE THAT THIS YEAR WE'RE GOING
TEST INTEREST INFRASTRUCTURE BUT
WE EITHER COME SAYS. REACHED IS
SKETCHED AND CHEN WE CAN. GET
MUCH FOR ANY. MUST WEAR PRIVATE
. THANK MISTER CONSULTANT CAN
YOU CALL THE ROLL. THE MOST IS
DUE PASS RE REFER TO THE CAN ON
A PER. SENATORS GONZALEZ HI IT'S
ALL I BATES. BATES HI ALAN.
ALLEN HI ARCHULETA ARCHULETA
BAKER BY BAKER I CORTESE CORTESE
I DAHLE. DOT LIMON MCGUIRE
MCGUIRE AYE MELENDEZ IN ARE MEN
HI NEWMAN NEWMAN AYE RUBIO
SKINNER BY CASKEY WELCOME. NINE
ZERO NINE ZERO LEAVE THE BILL ON
CALL THANK YOU SENATOR BAKER.
OKAY SO NOW WE'LL MOVE ON. I THE
NEXT THREE WILL BE BY SENATOR
ALAN A FILE ITEM TWELVE WILL
START WITH THAT ONE FIRST SB
TWELVE SEVENTEEN REGIONAL FOR
CLIMATE AND RESILIENCE SENATOR
ALAN. THANK YOU SO MUCH MEDICARE
MEMBERS ASOKORO TO CARB THE
STATE WILL NOT ACHIEVE. ITS
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
REDUCTIONS NECESSARY TO MEET
MANDATES FOR TWENTY THIRTY
BEYOND WITHOUT. PAYING JUST HOW
COMMUNITY. FIND IT IN. FOR B. B.
AWAY AND FAMILIAR WITH FACTORED
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT- THE
LEGISLATURE- AND GOVERNOR PROVED
THAT SENATOR NOW MAHER STYLE SB
THREE SEVENTY FIVE WHICH
REQUIRED CARB TO SIT PHD. P.
WE'RE- T. MUCH PLANNING IT'S A
MAJOR PROBLEM ORGANIZATIONS
AROUND THIS SO MPO. IS REQUIRED
TO CREATE A SUSTAINABLE
COMMUNITIES STRATEGY WITHIN
THEIR TRANSPORTATION PLAN- WITH
TACTICS FOR REDUCING EMISSIONS
THROUGH CHANGES AND MANDY. HOW
BEING IN TRANSPORTATION THIS. I
BUT WE SEE THAT EMISSIONS FROM
THE TRANSPORTATION AND- FIVE
SEVEN TRANSPORTATION SOURCES
CONTINUE TO RISE DESPITE
INCREASES AND- DECREASES. SO MPO
HAVE DEVELOPED SOME INNOVATIVE
STRATEGIES BUT THEY'RE PLANNING
DOCUMENTS ALONE ARE NOT CHANGING
DEVELOPMENT A LOCAL LEVELS THIS
BILL SEEKS TO SUPPORT THE COPS
AND PROSPER. TO ROLL OUT A
PRETTY- MINISTER G. M. GETTING
BUT PEOPLE. ROGER X. HI THE
PROJECT ACTUALLY BE. ALL THEN
WILL WE SEE THE REAL WORLD G.
SHE REDUCTIONS THAT SB THREE
SEVENTY FIVE HAD HI INVISION.
KEEP THIS BILL BOX AND HOW. ARE
WE CAN SEE THIS COMMUNITY STAR.
AT THE UP PROCESS NUMBER YOU
IMPROVE ECONOMY THE STATE
REGIONAL AND LOCAL LEVELS IN
FACT EIGHT. THREE ADDRESSING THE
DISCONNECT BETWEEN THE LOCAL
DECISION SHAPING REGIONAL GROWTH
AND ABOUT THE STATE CALLS REALLY
. HOUSING EQUITY THE ENVIRONMENT
AND THE ECONOMY. WE'VE CONVENED
. IN AN EFFORT TO FIND SOLUTIONS
TO IMPROVING THE SUSTAINABLE CAN
PROGRAM IT FOLKS HAVE BEEN BY
MISS BASE NOW THAT IT'S BEEN A
DIFFICULT AREA TO DO WORK. I'M
THE I'M GRATEFUL TO ALL
STAKEHOLDERS. WHO'VE BEEN VOTER
SO MUCH TIME TO THE DISCUSSION
VOTING THIS CASE YOUR AS WELL.
TO CREATE AN S. IN THIS PROCESS
THIS IS COMMITTED MAKE PROP IN
THIS AND CAN GIVE. REAL
EFFECTUATE SB THREE FIVE.
AWESOME WE CAN GET. ALLEN AND I
KNOW TO WORKING. CLOSELY WITH
SOME CHRIS. PHYLLIS ALSO I THANK
YOU BOTH FOR YOUR CONTINUED
WORK- AND WE DON'T HAVE ANY LEAD
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION BUT WILL. TO THE GAL
FOR ANY ONE WHO. BY IN SOME. OF
OKAY THIS. OKAY. I WOULD AMOUNT
TO HALF OF THE ELECTRIC VEHICLE
CHARGING ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. ONE WHAT
THE- LINE ANYWAY I'D LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB TWELVE
FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE. THANK YOU I
COULD TESTIFY INSUPPORT OF SB
TWELVE FIFTY EIGHT PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THE TIME MY APOLOGIES AS
WELL SEVENTEEN I KEEP SAYING
FIFTY. IT'S BEEN A LONG DAY
TWELVE EIGHTEEN. OKAY OKAY AND I
. BARELY FIFTY EIGHT. WE'LL GO
TO LINE CUTE TWENTY TWO GO AHEAD
. YES I'M IT THE S. B. TWELVE-
THIS IS NICORETTE ALLEGES AND
WITH THREE FIFTH BAY AREA BACK.
IN ORDER WELL SET. THANK YOU
NINETY TWO NINETEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YEAH THIS IS A PARTY LINE
VOTE FROM RICHMOND CALIFORNIA
WITH THE RIGHT DEPARTMENT
FUTURES- OF COMING OUT IN STRONG
SUPPORT OFFICE BE. FOUR SEVEN.
THANK YOU. HE TWENTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS ROGER DICKINSON FOR
CIVIC WELL FORMERLY THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMISSION I AM A
SUPPORT CONCEPT THIS VISION
LOOKING FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
WORK ON. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
WILL GO TO ONE THIRTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD WITH. THANK THE
CLEAN AIR COALITION IN SUPPORT
OF SB TWELVE SEVENTEEN THANK YOU
. THANK YOU THERE ARE NO FURTHER
LINES IN SUPPORT CONTINUE
READING CHAIR THANK YOU
MODERATOR- SO NOW WILL TAKE TO.
G. GO RIGHT AHEAD CORRECTING FOR
THE NUMBER OF REPORTING FOR A
MID PENINSULA REGIONAL OPEN
SPACE DISTRICT IN SUPPORT OF SB
TWELVE SEVENTEEN YES THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. GIA'S THERE SB TWELVE
EIGHTEEN ALL RIGHT SO WE
CONCLUDED WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
PERSONNEL BONTA POSITION ANYONE
IN THE GALLERY WOULD LIKE TO I
WAS S. TWELVE TWENTY IS. NOT
HELLO. OPPOSITE TWELVE THE NOT.
THANK YOU MAY CHAIR IF YOU WISH
SPEAK OUT OF S. TWELVE SEVENTEEN
PLEASE PRESS THEN ZERO AT THE
TIME HE JUST ONE MOMENT. NINE
ONE FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
. YEAH HELLO THIS IS SYLVIA FOR
OUR AND THEY HAVE TO CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY IS. WE'RE
CURRENTLY IN PRINT BUT WE'VE
BEEN PART OF THAT DISCUSSION
THAT'S BEEN TAKING PLACE AND
LOOK FORWARD TO THE FUTURE
CONVERSATION. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR THERE ARE NO FURTHER LINES
IN OPPOSITION YOU MAKE. OKAY
THANK YOU HAVE CONCLUDED SUPPORT
IN OPPOSITION SO NOW WE'LL TAKE
IT BACK TO THE DICE ANY MEMBERS
WHO WOULD LIKE TO JUST. JENSEN
BERMAN. I WANT TO THANK THE
SENATE AMOUNT FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD I MEAN THAT
RHETORICALLY AND LITERALLY- I
PLUGGED THE- PURPOSES AND GOALS
OF THIS BILL. I DO HAVE CONCERNS
ABOUT. ANOTHER OF BUREAUCRACY.
I'M NOT SURE THIS IS ALWAYS
EFFECTIVE. I HOPE CENTER- THAT.
BEING AT EARNING MY AS THIS BILL
MOVES FOR ALSO THE BILL TO. I
JUST WANTED TO MY CONCERNS
CREATING ANOTHER. YOUR TO T. R.
BECAUSE AT SOME POINT KNOW WHEN
WE HAVE SARS AND WHATNOT- IT
DOES THAT KIND OF BIG. A THE
QUESTION OF HOW MUCH IS TOO BUT
WITH APPRECIATE THE GOAL VOTE
FOR THE STATE. THANK YOU SO AN-
NO OTHER MAKES ALLEN WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE SENATOR DIGITAL
QUEST. L. SENATOR NEWMAN WILL A
BILL SO ALAN CLOSE YEAH. THANK
YOU THANK YOU TO THE SAN AFTER I
MEAN IT'S OUR HOPE THERE THAT
THROUGH THIS **** WILL BE WILL.
BRACKUS HAVE A OF. GREEK BOTH
THE- FOLKS YOU MAY. AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT HAVE COME TOGETHER
ON. AND SO WE AVOID THIS STUFF
ALL TOGETHER AND GET. THE
PROGRAMS IMPLEMENTED SO- I VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE THE COMMENT
APPRECIATE THAT FOR THIS
COMMITTEE. IT IS A WORK ADDRESS
. SPECTRUM THANK YOU SENATOR
ALAN SO WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR NEWMAN MISTER CHIEF
CONSULTANT CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. THE MOST. S. AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SENATORS GONZALEZ
HI GONZALEZ I BATES. IT'S NO
HELEN HI HELEN I ARCHULETA
ARCHULETA HI BECKER. BAKER
QUOTATION CORTESE II DOLLY
THOUGHT. LIMON MCGUIRE MCGUIRE
AYE MELENDEZ IN IN HIGH NEWMAN
NEWMAN I RUBIO SKINNER WHITE
HOUSE SKI WILK. EIGHT ONE EIGHT
ONE LEAVE THE BILL I'M COUGHING
SENATOR ALAN SO WE'LL MOVE ONTO
YOUR NEXT BILL FILE ITEM
THIRTEEN WHICH IS SB. TWELVE
FIFTY EIGHT. RICHARD MEMBERS FOR
THE BILL WELL LET ME JUST WITH
THIS BILL SIR BY THINKING THE
COMMITTEE STAFF AND STAKEHOLDERS
FOR THEIR ENGAGED ON THIS BILL.
I WE'RE GONNA BE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS.
WILL THE DRESS THAT THE OPPOSITE
IS. I'M CALIFORNIA'S AMBITIOUS
GOAL IN ARKANSAS EFFORTS TO THE
THREATS POSED BY CLIMATE CHANGE
IN INCLUDING REDUCING GHG
EMISSIONS THROUGH STATEWIDE UP
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES BY TWENTY
THIRTY FIVE IN ACQUIRING ALL.
HONEST COFFEE BEER AMID. SOME OF
. THE BECAUSE WE ALREADY HAVE A
LAID OUT- THE CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM TO SEE.
HE WAS CREATED BY THE
LEGISLATURE IN. WELL A MINUTE
OPTION OF NEWT. TO ACCELERATE
THE SHIFT AWAY FROM NON
RENEWABLE ENERGY SOURCES IN THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR WHICH WE
KNOW OF COURSE IS THE- LARGEST
SOURCE OF GHG AND- AT THE PUMP.
PRICES THE BEST IS TO PROVIDE
GRANT FROM SAID UNIVERSALLY TO
THE CRISIS. A ZERO EMISSION
AUTONOMOUS RIGHT YOUR SERVICES
ARE AN EMERGING INDUSTRY THAT
CAN HELP ACHIEVE ELECTRIC
VEHICLE GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION
TARGETS BY EXPANDING PUBLIC
ACCESS TO ZERO EMISSION
TRANSPORTATION. MS LIKE SEE.
COMEDY'S NEW TECH. IN EVALUATING
THEIR ASK ADVOCACY AND HELPING
THE STATE NEED ELECTRICAL
ACTIVITIES AND TARGET SO THIS
BILL WILL UPDATE- CDP
ELIGIBILITY CRITERIA TO INCLUDE
ZERO EMISSION THE INFRASTRUCTURE
AND REFUELING PROJECT QUOTE. FOR
DUTY VIET AS THIS IS SOMETHING
WANT TO JUST. MAKE SURE THAT
FOLKS WHO HAVE- CAN ABOUT
DISPLACED. A LIGHT DUTY CALLS ON
TO ALLOW THE SIGNAL THE
CONSIDERATION FOR FUNDING. I
THIS ELIGIBLE EXPENSE WILL AND
AFTER PUBLIC I TO CLING
TRANSPORTATION WILL BROADEN THE
STATE'S ELECTRIC VEHICLE
CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE- ITSELF
WE'VE GOT- FOLKS FROM CREWS WHO
ARE HERE TO TESTIFY THEY ARE
CONSTRUCTING ONE THE COUNTRY'S
LARGEST SELECT. CULTURE MUSIC
UNION PURPOSE. ACTIONS ARE IN
THIS ONGOING JOBS THE MAIN OF
CHARGE STATIONS AND I'LL SAY
ALVARADO FROM CRUISES HERE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
MISTER A- THE FLORIDA MARKHAM.
THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS MY
NAME'S SELL RODHAM HERE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF AN ALL ELECTRIC
AUTONOMOUS VEHICLE FLEET AT CALL
CRUZ IT'S A TRANSPORT CENTER
BUILT OFF THE EIGHT CRUISES
PROUD TO BE THE ONLY A THOMAS
VEHICLE COMPANY OPERATING IN ALL
ELECTRIC 100% THE NEW POWERFULLY
FOR HIS. WE ARE. ABOUT SEE IF-
MORE SUSTAINABLE. EQUITABLE TO.
FUTURE THAT CAN BENEFIT OUR
COMMUNITIES. THEY'RE BUILT OFF
THE EIGHT I WILL HELP ADVANCE
OUR CLIMATE GOALS BY ALLOWING
ZERO MISSION FLEETS TO BE
ELIGIBLE FOR CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM FUNDING.
LATE IT FOR ECUADOR. FEATURE BY
ALLOWING ANYONE TO TAKE A GREEN
RIDE REGARDLESS IF YOU HAVE
ACCESS TO ELECTRIC VEHICLE OR A
CHARGER. SEVEN AFRICAN
INVESTMENT THE BUILD OUT WITH
ZERO EMISSION FLEETS BUT WE NEED
MORE THE CLEAN TRANSPORTATION
PROGRAM HAS PROVEN TO BE AN
EXCELLENT WAY TO ADVANCE GREEN
OF SUCTION CALIFORNIA GRATING
GREEN YOU JOBS AND HELPING US
WORK TOWARDS OUR CLIMATE GOALS.
THIS BILL. BILL LEGISLATION
PASSED INTO LAW LAST YEAR WITH
THE SUPPORT LABOR ENVIRONMENTAL
LEADERS NAVY LEADERS REQUIRING
THOMAS VEHICLES TO BE ZERO
EMISSIONS BY TWENTY THIRTY. WE
BELIEVE PROVIDING RESOURCES TO
EXPAND CLEAN ENERGY FOR
TRANSPORTATION PURPOSES WILL
HAVE A POSITIVE BENEFIT UNDER
DRESSING VEHICLE EMISSIONS.
WORKING TOGETHER ON CLIMATE
GOALS AT BALLY'S WAS IMPORTANT
GET PAYING GREEN JOBS FOR THESE
REASONS I RESPECTFULLY ASK HER
AYE VOTE. CHEMIST PRODUCT- IT SO
NOW WE'LL MOVE ON TO ANYONE ELSE
IN THE GALLERY WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB TWELVE
FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE. HI WE ANY
TALK ON BEHALF OF TECHNET IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU. LET'S GET A MILE AND A HALF
OF THE ELECTRIC VEHICLE CHARGING
ASSOCIATION SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT CASEY NINE SO
WE'LL MOVE IT BACK TO THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE AND I'LL
HAVE TO REMIND FOLKS AGAIN. JUST
NUMBER. EIGHT FOUR TWO NINE ONE
SIX THREE SIX FOUR.
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF SB TWELVE FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE.
THANK YOU MANAGE LIKE TESTIFYING
IN SUPPORT OF SB TWELVE FIFTY
EIGHT THIS PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS. OKAY JUST A MOMENT FOR
FIRST PERSON. FINE TUNE NINETEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HOW DID ARE
BOUGHT FROM THAT DEFENDER
FUTURES AND STRONG SUPPORTER OF
THE SHOW THEIR- I JUST BROKE.
WHAT THE LIKE TO EMPHASIZE THE
PART WHERE WE HAVE OTHER KINDS
OF PEOPLE THANK YOU SIR WE'RE
JUST NAME AN ORGAN. AT TIME IN
SUPPORT OF SB. TWELVE EIGHT.
MODERATE WE HAVE A EXIT COMING
PLEASE THANK YOU. THANK YOU MY
ONE THREE PLEASE AHEAD. HELLO
THIS IS JUSTIN LEBLANC OF THE
SAMPLE TRANSIT ELDORADO. AT THE
OTHER OUT OF COUNTY AND-
STRONGLY SUPPORT- THIS BILL AS
IT WILL EXTEND TRANSPORTATION TO
RURAL PART OF CALIFORNIA. NO
OTHER LINES IN SUPPORT OF SB
TWELVE FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU AND I BELIEVE.
OPPOSITION AS REMOVE THEMSELVES
BUT I BELIEVE SHANE GUSMAN IS
HERE'S WELL TO DISCUSS ANY
ADDITIONAL CONCERNS BUT- THIS
CLASS YES THANK YOU I'M MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE SHANE DAWSON ON
BEHALF CALIFORNIA TEAMSTERS
PUBLIC AFFAIRS COUNCIL. THANK YA
THE COULD ANSWER AND THEY HAVE
BUILDERS WILL WITH THE AMENDMENT
WE ARE NOT NEW TO OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU MISTER. ALL RIGHT.
WHEN L. TWO OF THOSE AT TWELVE
EIGHT PLEASE. SEE NONE SO MOVED
TO THE TELECOM LINE MODERATOR
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN. TO BE TWELVE DEEP. THANK YOU
CAN CHAIRED TESTIFYING OPPOSITE
OF TWO FIFTY A THIS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. THERE ARE NO LINES IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE CONTINUE OKAY
THANK YOU AND WE'LL MOVE IT BACK
I S. ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FIRST TIME. RIGHT C. NINE TO-
AGAIN WE HAVE TAKEN THE
AMENDMENT TO REMOVE AND DELETE
THE LINE AUTONOMOUS FROM PAGE
SIX LINE- SO THANK YOU FOR THAT
AS A BACKER. OF THE BILL. CENTER
BACK IN. MISTER CHIEF BUTTON CAN
YOU CALL ROLL AND THEN WILL MR
ALLEN TO. PROVIDE CLOSE COMMENTS
. REMEMBER YOU THANK YOU THAT
OUR ALLY MY APOLOGIES MISTER
CONSULTANT HELLO. THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AMEND AND RE TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROACH. SENATORS
GONZALEZ INSULTS HI BATES. H. R.
ALLEN ALL RIGHT ALAN HI
ARCHULETA. ARCHULETA I BAKER.
BAKER I CORTESE CORTE I DOLLY.
DOT LIMON MCGUIRE MCGUIRE AYE
MELENDEZ MAN. NEWMAN NEWMAN AYE
RUBIO SKINNER BY CASKEY WILK.
IT'S ABOUT OKAY EIGHT ZERO LEAVE
THE BILL ON CALL WILL GO ON TO A
FILE ITEM FOURTEEN SB FOURTEEN
EIGHTY TWO ALSO SENATOR AL.
SORRY PERSONALLY ELSE HI- I'M TO
THIS BILL REQUIRES MULTI FAMILY
RESIDENCES IN CALIFORNIA AT THE
TIME OF CONSTRUCTION. TO PROVIDE
ELECTRIC VEHICLE READY CHARGING
ACCESS. NOT CHARGING STATION BUT
ACCESS FOR EVERY HOUSING UNIT
THAT HAS PARKING SO THE
COMMITTEE HOUSES WHICH IS
EXCELLENT- APPLE IS OUT THE
GOVERNOR IS ISSUE. THESE
PLEDGING PHASE OUT THE SET.
INTER COMBUSTION VEHICLES BY
TWENTY THIRTY FIVE YEARS WHERE.
ARE TO BE HIGHER STAY. HAS 7%
THE V. CHARGING FOR OF THE CAL
ENERGY AS IT WILL TO SUPPORT
THIS TREND THIS. POWERING UP
HOME AS THE CHEAPEST MOST
CONVENIENT. MOST RELIABLE FOR
DEALING AN EEVEE BUT THOSE
BENEFITS ARE FAILING TO REACH
COMMUNITIES THAT NEED THEM THE
MOST. OF YOUR FOLKS YOU HAVE A
SINGLE FAMILY HOME HAVE A PLUG
IN THEIR GARAGE OR DRIVEWAY THEY
CAN IN. ALL RIGHT THIS BEFORE
BEING LIVE IN IN- MULTIPLE UNITS
NOT OFTEN TO UP. READ IT IN CON
AN APARTMENT AFTER THEY'VE BEEN
CONSTRUCTED. BONTA MUCH MORE.
THAN INSTALLING READY CHARGE
TIME OF THE CONSTRUCTION. OF THE
NEWLY UPDATED TWENTY TWO CAL
GREEN BUILDING CODE REQUIRES
EEVEE CHARGER ACT 4100% OF. ONLY
FORTY PER CENT OF NEW MOST FOR.
BASES OFTEN DISPROPORTIONATE
INCOME COMMUNITIES WITH POOR
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. OUR STATE
HAS A LOT OF WORK. ABOUT HEARING
THIS COMMITTEE TO MAKE EASY
CHARGING TRULY AVAILABLE TO
CALIFORNIA FROM ALL WALKS OF
LIFE AND I BELIEVE ONE KEY IS
MAKING AT HOME CHARGING ACCESS
FOR A- THIS IS. AN IMPORTANT
THAT IS LET ME KIND OF INTO THAT
AS IT IF A NEW SIXTY COM A PER
SOME OF THE V. TO ONLY FORTY OF
SPACES I RECALL PERRIN CODE
BECAUSE THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS
TO WE ESTIMATED THIS YOU STILL.
X. HOW 2% OF. CHARGING A WILL
BECAUSE ONLY TEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS ONLY POINT ZERO THREE OF
THE OVER. RETROFITTING THE
BUILDING LOW HOW WOULD CAUSE
UPWARDS OF HALF AN YEARS. THE
TWO THIS BILL DOESN'T REQUIRE
CHARGING STATION IT JUST
REQUIRES WE- DOWN THE GO SEX FOR
FOLKS TO BE ABLE TO ACT.
CHARGING IN A FEW BUT IF WE WERE
ARE TO FOR. WHICH UP. WE'VE GOT
WITH. THIS PICTURE IS BEING
BUILT INTO A NEW BUILDINGTHAT
ARE BEING. I'M NOW WE'VE BEEN IN
TOUCH WITH A FOLKS REYES CAN
ABOUT THE BILL AND WE'RE-
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH THEM
AS WE FOR. COMMON GROUND. ENABLE
THE FOR. BUT THREE IS THAT WERE
FOCUSED ON. YOU CAN. YOU
DEFINING HI THE PER EVEY RAY
CHARGING ACCESS DOES NOT
OBLIGATE A LANDLORD OR BUILDING
MANAGER TO PAY FOR THE
ELECTRICITY TO CHARGE ANY
RESIDENTS VEHICLE THAT'S OF
COURSE IT'S OF GREAT CONCERN TO
THE APARTMENT HONORED- AND
LANDLORDS AND THEN FINALLY
NUMBER THREE ENSURING THE
LEGISLATION'S WORKABLE INSTANCES
WHERE PARKING SPACES ARE NOT PRE
ASSIGNED TO RESIDENCES THAT VERY
VERY IMPORTANT AND REYES. BY
FOLKS IN THE IN THE BUILDING-
INDUSTRY AND- THE NECESSARY COST
EFFECTIVE POLICY THAT WILL HELP
US REACH OUR GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION TARGETS. DEMOCRATISE
MATIZ ACCESS TV CHARGING. AND
DONE. WITH ME- TODAY IS LINDA
HUTCHINS KNOWLES FROM- ACT
TERROR AS- A CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM AND THEN
BY PHONE WE HAVE SPEND. THIESSEN
WHO'S THE FOUNDER AND CO LEAD OF
YOU CHARGING FOR ALL COALITION.
ALLEN TOUCH ANGLES. AFTER
SENATORS THANK YOU TO CENTER
ALLEN FOR CHAMPION EVEN EQUITY
BY OFFERING THIS BILL ON BEHALF
OF THAT TERRA AND THE EASY
CHARGING ACCESS FOR ALL
COALITION PRO CO SPONSORS THAT
SB FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO I URGE
YOU TO SUPPORT THIS BILL THIS
PURPOSE IS TO PROVIDE RESIDENTS
OF NEW APARTMENTS AND CONDOS THE
SAME ACCESS TO AT HOME PURGING
THAT NEW SINGLE FAMILY HOMES
HAVE ENJOYED SINCE TWENTY
FIFTEEN. HERE'S A TRUE STORY IN
TWENTY NINETEEN REBEKAH LUCKY
PURCHASED A LEAF SINCE HER
APARTMENT BLOCKS CHARGING SHE
DROPPED AN EXTENSION CORD TO THE
GROUND BELOW TO CHARGE AT THE
CURB WHEN THE MANAGER DEAN THE
COURT IT THIRD SHE RESORTED TO
PUBLIC CHARGING BUT IT PROVED A
COUPLE QUOTE. I THINK IN OUR TO
CHARGES THE DAY BREAKER FOR OUR
FAMILY THE KIDS IN THE PLANO
PARKING SPACE. THIRD S. CHART
EXTREMELY HIGH FOR A BETTER
RETURN HER EEVEE RESUME DRY A
GAS CAR THE STORY OF THE FACT
THAT LACK OF ACCESS AFFORDABLE
SAFE AND CONVENIENT. PUTS EV'S
OUT OF REACH OF MOST RESIDENTS
OF APARTMENTS AND CONDOS
ENSURING THEY GET SUCH ACCESS IS
VITAL FOR EQUITY AND TO IT REACH
OUR CLIMATE GOALS. BY TWENTY
THIRTY FIVE AUG NEW CAR SORT OF
THE STATE MUST BE ZERO EMISSIONS
SO IT MAKES LITTLE SENSE TO
BUILD NEW HOUSING WITH OBSOLETE
PARKING SPACES THAT CAN'T CHARGE
THOSE FEES. AND THE PUT OTHER
AGENCIES LIKE CARBON THE CC ON
THE HOOK FOR USING BILLIONS OF
TAXPAYER DOLLARS TO REPEAT THE
SAME BUILDINGS AND JUST A FEW
YEARS. CALIFORNIA MUST STOP
DIGGING THE HOLE DEEPER NOW AND
BUILD BUILDINGS THAT ALIGN WITH
OUR EASY ADOPTION GOALS. WE
CAN'T AFFORD TO WAIT FOR THE
INCREMENTAL COLD PROCESS THE
CODE UPDATE PROCESS TO CATCH UP
. USE THEM I'M A- PRETTY SOME
ATHLETES. THE CLIMATE DAY A
MEMBER. WE MUST STOP BUILDING
HOUSING NOW THIS. WE MUST START
BUILDING HOUSING NOW THAT'S
PREPARED FOR THE CLEAN MOBILITY
FUTURE RATHER THAN STUCK IN THE
FOSSIL FUEL PASSED. AND A FINAL
WORD ABOUT EQUITY. THE MAJORITY
OF MULTI FAMILY RESIDENTS ARE
PEOPLE OF COLOR IN COMMUNITIES
HEAVILY BURDENED BY AIR
POLLUTION. FOR TOO LONG THE CAL
GREENE CO HAS PERPETUATED
INFRASTRUCTURE RACISM. LUCKY
MANY BLACK AND BROWN RESIDENTS
OUT OF THE EASY REVOLUTION.
VOTING AGAINST OUR ABILITY TO
VOTE LEAVE 6270% OF RESIDENTS OF
NEW MORE FAMILY HOUSING. WITHOUT
ACCESS. DOUBLE C. LEVEL OUT
CHARGING. PLEASE SUPPORT EQUITY
EMITTING CLEANER YOU ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. FOURTEEN EIGHTY
TWO YOU. MOVE ON. TO THE CO HOST
MY- FOR MISTER SMITH. AT THE SAN
EVEY CHARGING FOR A- I AM
SEVENTY SENATE MENTION HERE WITH
EIGHTEEN YEARS OF ELECTRIC
VEHICLE EXPERIENCE THAT HE
JEANNIE AND IT'S ALL CLEAN
ENERGY AND MY OWN IN THE
CONSULTING FIRM. COALITION IS
GETTING TO EXPANDING ACCESS EASY
CHARGING MINIMIZING COSTS THE
COMPLEXITY BUILDERS RESIDENTS
AND THOSE WHO OPERATE THESE
BUILDINGS. WE DID NOT ARE.
THANKS FOR IN CALIFORNIA BUT ANY
FLAMES THIS BILL IS A COST
PROHIBITIVE MANDATE IS
INACCURATE. THERE ARE SEVERAL
PROVISIONS THAT ACTUALLY KEEPS
BUILDING COSTS AS LOW AS
POSSIBLE. FIRST CHOIR THAT EVERY
PARKING SPACE IN A MULTI FAMILY
COMPLEX BE WIRED FOR EACH
CHARGING INSTEAD TO PROVIDE THAT
EVERY NEW UNITS WITH PARKING HAS
ACCESS TO ONE HE BEAT READY
PARKING SPACE FOR EXAMPLE IF A
ONE HUNDRED YEAR COMPLEX HAS TWO
HUNDRED PARKING SPACES ONLY A
GREAT ALLOW PATIENTS ALL.
HUNDRED THE BILL MINIMIZE BILL
COMPLEX IN COST. HOW GREENS READ
THE V. D. THIS SIMPLY LOW POWER
. LEVEL TWO ET READY- THE BILL
REDUCES OPERATIONAL BY
ENCOURAGING RUNNING THE WIRING
YEAH EACH UNIT METER RATHER THAN
THE COMMON HERE THIS ELIMINATES
THE NEED FOR OVERSIGHT BY
APARTMENT MANAGEMENT. WHAT THE
H. AWAY WHILE ENABLING RESIDENTS
ACCESS TO THEIR UTILITIES LOW
WITH ELECTRIC RATES. AN EXPERT
REVIEWED ECONOMIC ANALYSIS
DETERMINED THAT THIS BILL WILL
ONLY INCREASE NEW BUILD COSTS
BY. ZERO POINT ZERO THREE
PERCENT. BROKERAGE PROJECTED
THAT BETWEEN TWENTY THREE. THANK
THE FIVE NOT THOUSAND BRAND NEW
UNIT WILL REQUIRE RECTOR
PHILIPPINE AND UTILITY PROVIDED
COST ONE POINT FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS FORCES ONLY TWENTY SEVEN
MILLION TO WIRE THEM THE TIME UP
IN THE- FINALLY. JUSTICE OTHER
STATES FOLLOW OUR LEADERSHIP
THIS BILL WILL FURTHER
ACCELERATE EVEN ADOPTION
BOOSTING OUR LARGEST EXPORT
ELECTRIC VEHICLES WHILE
PROVIDING ADDITIONAL EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES HERE IN CALIFORNIA
. WEISS DURING OUR RESOURCES OUR
PEOPLE AND FOR THE BOTH THE
MULTI FAMILY RESIDENTS APPROVE
SB FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO TODAY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
US SO NOW WE'LL MOVE TO THE
GALLERY FOR ANYONE WHO'D LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO- ABIGAIL
MILE ON BEHALF OF THE ELECTRIC
VEHICLE CHARGING ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT LOOKING FORWARD WORKING
WITH AUTHORS. YES THANK YOU.
HELLO INSTANCE CYNTHIA SALAD AND
I'M WITH INDIVISIBLE CALIFORNIA
STATE STRONG. INDIVISIBLE
SACRAMENTO GREEN TEAM AND
SEGMENTAL ELECTRIC VEHICLE
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU
THANK YOU. BE SHY SB FOURTEEN
EIGHTY TWO. MY NAME IS MARK
SEVEN FROM SACRAMENTO ELECTRIC
VEHICLE ASSOCIATION AND WE ARE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB FOURTEEN
EIGHTY TWO FOR EVEY EQUITY.
THANK YOU. HELLO I AM GUY HALL A
MEMBER OF THE NATIONAL ELECTRIC
VEHICLE ASSOCIATION BOARD-
HUNDRED CHAPTERS STRONG AND FELT
ACROSS THE COUNTRY WERE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF FOURTEEN IF
YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU ANYONE
ELSE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
CASEY NINE TO A MODERATOR CAN WE
TAKE IT BACK TO THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE FOR ANYONE
WHO'D LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF SB FOURTEEN EIGHTY TO PLEASE
. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. IF YOU
WISH TESTIFIED IN SUPPORT OF S.
B. OR- B. TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
. THANK YOU CHAIR NUMBERS THEN
FOR A LARGE- WITH PLYMOUTH AND
TRANSPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU-LINE TO FORTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THE FUNDS ARE GOING TO
GET WITH CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL VOTERS IN SUPPORT
. THANK YOU LINE TO FORTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS THE
MISSILE WITH AT MOST FINANCIAL
CONCERNS SUPPORT. THANK YOU LINE
ONE NINETY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD
. OKAY MY NAME IS THE BREAKING
HEAR ME. I GUESS WE CAN'T GET.
HI MY NAME IS VICTORIA AND SAN
DIEGO AND I'M IN FROM SUPPORT SB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO THIRTY BE
EQUITY. EIGHT INVIOLABLE
APARTMENT THANK. NINE TWO
NINETEEN GO AHEAD. YES FOR
EXAMPLE RIGHT EXPERIMENT USES AN
ACCIDENTS EUROPE TO CONSIDER IS
A STRONG FOR THIS BILL. THANK
YOU LINE ONE TWENTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THIS IS ADRIAN OF THE
VENTURA THE WORDS FROM SUPPORT
OF BILL. THANK YOU THANK YOU
THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
BILL MURPHY WITH ELDERS CLIMATE
ACTION NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER SO THE CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER ALSO SPEAKING ON BEHALF
OF CLIMATE REALITY PROJECT
SILICON VALLEY CHAPTER IN STRONG
SUPPORT WE THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
THIS BILL. THANK YOU LINE TO DO
IS GO AHEAD. NINE TWO HUNDRED
AND TEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
CORDYLINE TWO THIRTY TO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THIS IS MARK GELLER
VICE PRESIDENT THE PLUG IN
AMERICA WE ARE IN VERY STRONG
SUPPORT AT THE FORTY EIGHTY TWO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU OF MINE
CHIU FORTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
. ALL NOBODY ONLY OPEN AND I'M
REPRESENTING WALLY BAY AREA ALSO. INSURABLE CHANGE MORE AND
WE'RE ALSO IT STROKES OF
FOURTEEN TWO. THANK YOU LINE ONE
OH TWO GO A- HELLO. YES WE CAN
HEAR YOU. MY NAME IS DERRICK
JOHNSON OF THE SENIOR MANAGER OF
POLICY AND EXTERNAL RELATIONS
BROUGHT CAROL EXPRESSING OUR
STRONG SUPPORT FOR. SB FOURTEEN
EIGHTEEN FORTY BACK WITH. THANK
YOU NINE TO THIRTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO I'M REBECA LIST
YOU ONBEHALF OF THREE FIFTY
SILICON VALLEY IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF SB FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO FOR
EASY EQUITY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
LINE ONE SEVENTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS JUSTIN
LEBLANC OF SUSTAINABLE TRENTON
ELDORADO I AM IN SUPPORT OF SB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO FOR ACCESS
TO RURAL COMMUNITIES IN
pCALIFORNIA UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES. THANK YOU LINE CHIU
FORTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS
IS- REBECCA MILLIGAN ON BEHALF
OF THE BERKELEY CLIMATE ACTION
COALITION AND WE ARE CALLING FOR
THANK YOU. YOUR LINE ONE EIGHTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS LAURA SIMPSON
REPRESENTING THREE FIFTY
HUMBOLDT AND WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL AND WE THINK
THE OFFER FOR PUTTING THE FOR.
THE NINE TO THIRTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS GABBY
EVAN MOORE AND I'M A RESIDENT OF
SAN MATTEO IS ALSO A STUDENT AT
COLLEGE NOW AND I AM IN STRONG
SUPPORTER OF SB ONE FOUR EIGHT
YOU FOR EACH THE ACTIVITY. THANK
YOU. YOUR MIND TO THIRTY. PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS MICHELLE
AND I LIVE WITH THE VALLEY IN
THE INLAND EMPIRE REGION OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA ANNENBERG IN
STRONG SUPPORT SB FOURTEEN
EIGHTY TWO FORTY EIGHT FORTY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU LET ONE
NINETEEN SEVEN GO A- HI MY NAME
IS THAT REALLY CHAU I'M THE
PRESIDENT OF THE CENTRAL COAST
ELECTRIC VEHICLE ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING THE FIVE COUNTIES
ALONG CENTRAL COAST I AM STILL.
EIGHTY TWO WE HAVE WATCHED THE
PRICE THE VEHICLES COME DOWN AS
THE RANGE GOES UP THE ONLY THING
THAT'S THE BARRIER NOW IS
CHARGING. THANK YOU THANK YOU
THANK YOU LINE TO FIFTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS LI OR
MILKEN GARTNER AND I WAS
CALIFORNIA INTERSTATE POWER AND
LIGHT THE OVER SEVEN HUNDRED
MEMBER CONGREGATIONS ACROSS THE
STATE WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF SB FOURTEEN EIGHTY EIGHTY
TWO. QUITTING THANK YOU. THANK
YOU LINE TO FORTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD.
THANK YOU FORTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YOU WERE GOING TO GO TO
LINE ONE NINETEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS LAURIE-
WITH THE THREE FIFTY BAY AREA
ACTION AND WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB FOURTEEN EIGHTY
TWO THANK YOU. THANK YOU LINE
ONE STEP BEFORE PLEASE GO AHEAD
. HI THIS IS CRYSTAL REASONABLE
WITH THE BAY AREA CLEAN AIR
COALITION IN SUPPORT OF SB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU LINE TO FIFTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS TANYA MAR WOULD AND FROM
MOUNTAIN VIEW CALIFORNIA I AM
INSTRUCTED QUIRK-SILVA SB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO FOR E.
EQUITY. THANK YOU THANK YOU
FORTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS COLLEEN SHIELDS I'M WITH
SANTA CRUZ CLIMATE ACTION
NETWORK SEVENTEEN HUNDRED PEOPLE
AND WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
S. B. FOURTEEN H. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU LINE Q. FIFTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS MY CARBON ON BEHALF OF
SCHNEIDER ELECTRIC IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THANK YOU
LINE TO FIFTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GEN WORN ON BEHALF OF THE
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY INTERFAITH
CLIMATE ACTION IN SUPPORT OF SB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO. THANK YOU
LINE TO FIFTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE TO FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. REPORTER LINE TO SIXTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
DEBBIE MY TELEPHONE REPRESENTING
FINANCIAL INTERFAITH CLIMATE
ACTION BY TWO DOZEN
CONGREGATIONS FROM SAN MATTEO
DOWN TO WELL AS STRONGLY
SUPPORTING SB. FOURTEEN EIGHTY
TWO THANK YOU. THANK YOU LINE Q.
SIX THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME'S CHRISTOPHER WILLIS I LIVE
IN SEINFELD AND I AM CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT AT S. B. FOURTEEN
EIGHTY TWO. THANK YOU LIKE TWO
FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS ERIN
REASON. OAKLAND CALIFORNIA AND
I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF- THREE
FIFTY EAST BAY IN STRONG SUPPORT
FOR SB FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO FOR
EVEY EQUITY. THANK YOU NINE TO
SIXTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
MY NAME IS CRYSTAL HERNANDEZ I
AM A GROWING COLLEGE STUDENTS
AND- A FELLOW IN TURN OCT TERRA-
I AM IN STRONG SUPPORTER OF THIS
BILL THANK YOU. FISH THANK YOU
TWO SIXTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI SHOWING MEMBERS THIS IS IGOR
TRACK OF. I CAN'T. OUR PROCESS
SHARE THE ALPINE DEMOCRATIC
INCREMENTAL COSTS FOR. HAVE BEEN
INDIVIDUAL TODAY HE FIVE OR-
YEAH YOU KNOW FAMILY COMPLEX
DOMINANT CHARGING I. AFTER WE
ARE THE BILL IN YOUR- SYSTEM
THINKING ONLINE TO SIX FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY IS KIM
MULLIN WITH THE- HERE TO FOLLOW
THOSE GREEN YOU CAN STRONG BUT
IT AT THE FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO.
THANK IN MODERATOR HELPING WE
LEFT AND QUEUE THIS TIME. THIRTY
MORE OKAY GREAT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU I SIXTIES PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES THIS IS WILL BRING HER ON
BEHALF OF THREE FIFTY SACRAMENTO
AND WE ALSO SUPPORT SB FOURTEEN
EIGHTY TWO. GREAT THANK YOU
MODERATOR IS THERE ANYONE ELSE
LEFT IN THE QUEUE. THERE IS ONE
OTHER OKAY GREAT. THANK FIFTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THERE
ARE NO OTHER LINES IN THE QUEUE
PLEASE CONTINUE OKAY THANK YOU-
SO WE'VE CONCLUDED- WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF SB FOURTEEN EIGHTY
TWO SO MOVE ON TO SB FOURTEEN
EIGHTY TWO IN OPPOSITION ANYONE
IN THE GALLERY WHO'D LIKE TO
OPPOSE THE BILL AT THIS TIME. C.
NONE A MODERATOR WILL TAKE IT
BACK TO YOU FOR ANYONE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO- REGISTER THEIR
TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION TO SB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TO PLEASE. THANK
YOU IF YOU'D LIKE. S. T.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TO PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. WE'LL GO TO LINE
TWO FORTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU FORTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. CAN YOU HEAR ME WE CAN
HEAR YOU. THANK YOU MY NAME IS
LAURIE AND BARBER AND I'M
ACTUALLY SPEAKING IN SUPPORT I
THINK THEY HAVE HAD A GLITCH ON
MY PHONE OR I DIDN'T GET A
NUMBER OKAY BUT I MY NAME IS
LAURIE AND I LIVE IN KENTUCKY
CALIFORNIA AND MULTI FAMILY
HOUSING AND I YOU CAN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE- THANK. MUCH MUCH
. OF ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION
TO SB FOURTEEN EIGHTY TO PLEASE
. HELLO NINE ONE FIFTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON THAT WILL BE- FERRARI
ON BEHALF CALIFORNIA BUILDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION WE ARE ALL
THAT HAVE HAVING CONVERSATIONS
WITH THE AUTHOR AND THE FUNCTORS
NOPE THE WORK THROUGH THOSE.
THANK YOU. GREAT THANK YOU NINE
FOUR. ONE OH FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON TURN
MEMBERS REGARDING ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING
OFFICIALS RESPECT OPPOSITION
THERE ARE THE FOURTEEN EIGHTY
TWO THANK YOU. Q. AND ONE TWENTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. MEMBERS
WRECKED AT THE HEIGHT ON THE
CALIFORNIA BUSINESS PROPERTIES
POSITION ALSO AND ALSO
OPPOSITION ALLYING WITH
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC BUILDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MAN I'M SURE THERE ARE
NO FURTHER LINES IN OPPOSITION
YOU MAY CONTINUE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MODERATOR. BUT IT SUPPORT
IN OPPOSITE WILL TAKE DISCUSSION
BACK TO MEMBERS SENATOR NEWMAN
AND SENATOR BAKER. I THANK
MANAGER SO. GEN AROUND THIS IS A
GOOD BILL- AND IDA LOVE TO BE TO
CO- I HAVE I HAVE LIVED THIS
MORE THAN ONCE WRITER YOU DON'T
AND TO YOUR POINT IT IS
IMMENSELY LESS EXPENSIVE- TO DO
THIS RIGHT AT THE OUTSET THEN
TRIED TO RETROFIT. SOMETHING
WITH FORTY WILL POWER FOR AN
EASY. AND SO IT SEEMS TO ME. TO
THE EXTENT THAT YOU'VE MADE
CLEAR THIS IS FOR NEW CONSTRUCT. I AM NOT. RECOGNITION MOREOVER
IT'S JUST ABOUT THE Y. ET ARE
INFECTIOUS- THROUGH UNIFORM
CODES YOU WANT OF SAVING- BUT
PEOPLE A WHOLE BUNCH OF MONEY
INCLUDING BUILDERS INCLUDING.
COMMUNITIES BOB COMMEND YOU FOR
IT WILL BE A DISCARDED THANK YOU
. FOR THE SENATE RACE SENATOR
BAKER IN THE LOGON TO SENATOR
ARE TO LET AND SENATOR RUBIO.
THANK YOU YEAH I JUST WANT I
BELIEVE THIS BILL IS A CRITICAL
PART OF BOTH OUR CLEAN ENERGY
AGENDA AND OUR EQUITY. AGENDA
FOR ALL THE REASONS MENTIONED
MAKES TO DO THIS. NOW THE CHEC
SHE'S BEEN WORKING TOWARDS. WE
DON'T HAVE I'M WAIT. EVERY UNIT
BUILT NOW WITH CHARGE- IS GONNA
COST DOWN THE ROAD. AND IS KIND
BE HARMFUL TO ACHIEVING OUR CALL
SO THAT WE CAN LIVE BECAUSE
THERE'S NOT I'D LIKE TO BE ADDED
A SCORE. AND MOVED WHEN THE TIME
IS APPROPRIATE. THANK YOU
SENATOR BAKER SENATOR. YES THANK
YOU MEDICARE- I AM GOING TO-
SUPPORT THE BILL WITH THE
UNDERSTANDING THAT. I WILL LOOK
AT IT AGIN ON THE FLOOR. AND I
COMMEND THE AUTHOR. TO BE ABLE
TO WORK WITH THE APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION. OF GREATER LOS
ANGELES TO WORK WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS. AND BUILDING INDUSTRY.
AND THE SENATOR HAS A HISTORY.
OF WORKING ON THE FIFTY YARD
LINE. AND I APPRECIATE THAT. AND
I SEE THAT WE'RE ALMOST THERE.
AND I AM HOPING. WITH THE
AMENDMENTS THAT- I FORESEE. WILL
BE ABLE TO GO FORWARD WITH THE-
AS WE- ON THE- JUST. THERE WE-
MANY IN THE TOP AND I THAT SO
THAT PROVED THAT EVEN THAT I
KNOW WORKED WITH THE OPPOSITE TO
GET THIS OVER LOOK FOR TO PASS
IT ON THE SENATE BUT I DO
RESERVE THE RIGHT AND I THANK
YOU FOR. THANK AT RG LET US
UNDER. CHAIR I ALSO AND I THINK
THE AUTHOR WE'VE HAD EXTENSIVE
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THIS AND I
DO AGREE WITH THE INTENT OF THE
BILL AND SUPPORT THE GOAL OF THE
BILL BUT I DO HAVE CONCERNS AS
IT PERTAINS TO THE EQUITY WE'RE
TRYING TO SELL. SEVEN EQUITY
ISSUE AND I'M- YOUR WE'RE GOING
TO CREATE ANOTHER. TO AS WE'RE
TRYING TO SOLVE ONE. IN
PARTICULAR YOU KNOW I KNOW THAT
THE- COMMITTEE. ANALYSIS TALKED
ABOUT. AT LEAST COSTLY WAY OF
DOING IT ACCORDING TO THE
ANALYSIS IT'S STATES THAT
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS AS- THE
DEVELOPMENT OF LEVEL THREE FAST
CHARGING. EIGHT EIGHT LESS
EXPENSIVE OPTIONS THE REQUIRED
LEVEL TWO CHARGING AT EVERY
PARKING SPACE THAT COMMITTEE
ANOTHER SUGGESTS RETROFITTING A
FEW LEVEL. CHARTERS ABBOTT MUCH
COST. I KNOW THE AUTHOR STATED
THE COST AND IT SEEMS MINIMAL
BUT- NOT TOO LONG COME
COMMUNITIES. THAT MAY BE SUBJECT
BETWEEN THEM HAVING ACCESS. RB
LEFT OUT ALTOGETHER SO AGAIN I
WANT TO SURE THAT WE NOT TRYING
TO SOLVE EQUITY ISSUE INCREASE
ANOTHER. ALL BUT ALSO- I JUST
YOU KNOW AND I KNOW HE'S BEEN
WORKING REALLY HARD SO I DO
APPRECIATE THE OUT THERE WORKING
WITH THE OPPOSITION AND I KNOW
HE WILL CONTINUE TO DO SO- BUT
AGAIN IT'S- YOU KNOW WITH A
LITTLE BIT AS A TEAM. I'M NOT
SURPRISED BAD I THINK IT'S A
GOOD I THINK THE INTENT IS YOU
KNOW THERE. BATTLE IF YOU WERE
JUST CONSIDER A LITTLE. JUST
EXPLORING THE PA. OF LESS.
CHARGING STATIONS BUT A LITTLE
BIT MORE POWERFUL THE LEVEL
THREE. I JUST WOULD BE MY HOUSE
BUT THINK I WILL SUPPORT IT
TODAY. MENTORS ONE. YES SENATOR
RUBIO HE'S GOING TO RESPOND AND
THEN WE HAVE SENATOR CRITICAL
READ AT MY I APPRECIATE THAT
PRESERVE THE COME A GREAT DEAL
AND I YOU KNOW I THINK
ULTIMATELY WHAT I REALLY WANT TO
DO IS TO DO A DEEP DIVE- I
BELIEVE THE WAY THE NOZZLES
WRITTEN IT'S IT MAY BE LESS
EXPENSIVE. WHAT WE NEED GET. GET
DOWN TO THE FAX OF WHAT THE COST
COMPARISONS ARE AND WHAT THE FTC
IS SO THAT WE REALLY CAN MAKE
SURE THAT- WE WERE WERE ABLE TO
HAVE ALL THE- INFORMATION AT OUR
HANDS. THIS PROFIT. AND SO I
WOULD LOVE TO WORK WITH YOUR
OFFICE IN THAT AND THAT THE
COMMITTEES. STAFF TO REALLY GET
TO THE BOTTOM OF THE DATA THAT
WE HAVE SO WE CAN REALLY MAKE A
WISE DECISION WHEN IT COMES TO
THE BALANCE. I WOULD LEVEL WITH
OF A THREE. I APPRECIATE THAT.
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU SENATOR
RUBIO CENTER CORTESE. YES- THINK
MANAGER IN INTO THE AUTHOR OF
I'M GOING TO BE SUPPORTING IT MY
COLLEAGUES IN THE SUPPORTING THE
BILL- IT SEEMS TO ME THAT.
RELATIVE TO THE INDUSTRY WHICH
IS BASICALLY THE OPPOSITION- FOR
ALL INTENTS AND PURPOSES- DO
NEEDS TO BE SOME PROCESS FOR
THEM- ALTERNATELY TO WORK WITH-
THE AGENCIES STATE AGENCIES THAT
ARE- OR OR WILL BE INVOLVED IN
YOU KNOW IN EITHER UPDATING
CODER OR BUILDING REQUIREMENTS
AND I'M SURE THE AUTHORS TAKING
THAT INTO ACCOUNT AND THAT'S
PROBABLY PART OF THE ON GOING TO
. SHOULD BE. A NO BRAINER FOR
THE INDUSTRY I CAN'T THINK OF. A
CIRCUMSTANCE WHERE MULTI FAMILY
RESIDENTIAL WOULD HAVE TO TWO
FORTY CIRCUITS COMING INTO IT.
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT COMES IN OFF
THE MAIN POWER NO I MEAN REALLY
WHAT WE CALL ONE TWENTY ISSUES.
TO FORTY SPLIT RIGHT- SO SOME OF
IT IS YOU KNOW I THINK
REAFFIRMING WE KNOW. SHOULD
CODES SO NOBODY'S KNOW THAT
SLIPS BY WITH OTHER PARTS OF IT
ARE- I THINK OR- FOR MORE
PURPORTED TO BE MORE PRACTICAL
CONCERNS BY THE INDUSTRY BECAUSE
OF. A DESIGNS AND YEAH AND OTHER
SITE CONSIDERATIONS I REMEMBER.
THE BUILDING MULTI FAMILY
PACKAGE- MY PRIOR EXISTENCE
IMPORTING THE SIDEWALKS BEFORE
WE FIGURED OUT WHERE PEOPLE WANT
TO WALK AND- IT WAS SO IT WAS
SORT OF A MISTAKE IF SOMEBODY
CAME UP LATER IN SAID- YOU KNOW
YOU YOU WANT TO WAIT BEFORE. YOU
WALK IN DETAILS UNTIL YOU KNOW
EXACTLY WHERE HE SAID SHE WHERE
YOUR CUSTOMERS WANT TO GO SO I'M
SURE THOSE ARE SOME OF THE- IN
SOME OF THE TENSION PURPOSE THE
OPPOSITION'S PEOPLE RIGHT NOW
WORRIED THAT- YEAH I DON'T
AGENCY SOMEBODY'S GOING TO COME
IN. YOU KNOW SORT OF A BICYCLE
ALL I'M IN AND I THINK IT'S VERY
AVOIDABLE IN THE VERY WORKABLE-
TO MAKE SURE THEY HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO. TO HAVE THAT
KIND OF- INPUT. YOU KNOW TO SORT
OF FINISH THE BILL OFF SO AGAIN
I'M VERY SUPPORTIVE OBVIOUSLY
GREAT I JUST TALK ABOUT
OPPOSITION LAWYER. AN
OUTSTANDING THE- PORT- MANY OF
THEM FROM THE BAY AREA AND- FREE
SHEARED PRESHEAF HEARING THAT-
AND- THAT'S ALL IT THAT'S ALL I
REALLY WANT TO GET ON THE RECORD
THANK YOU YEAH. KEYCENTER
QUICKLY ACC NO OTHER MIKES UP US
THE- MOVE THE BILL BY SENATOR
NEWMAN I ALSO WANT TO THANK YOU
SENATORALAN FOR YOUR WORK AND
I'LL CONTINUE AS- I MENTIONED
BEFORE WITH THE OPPOSITION- AND-
YOU KNOW THIS IS AGAIN A BIG
ISSUE IF YOU WANT TO HIT OUR
GOALS WE NEED TO ENSURE THAT
WE'RE- ASSIST. IT'S PAST- IN A
GO NOW. IS SENATOR BY REVISED.
BUT I JUST WANTED TO OFFER THE
COMMENTS APOLOGIZE I DIDN'T WANT
TO THROW COLD WATER ON AFTER.
THIS BUT- BUT I I'M NOT GONNA BE
ABLE TO SUPPORT IT TODAY BUT I
WANT TO APPLAUD YOUR EFFORTS ARE
MADE TO REDUCE THE COST. OF TO
TWO. BILLION THE- REPUBLICAN
CAUCUS REALLY REYES A VERY
IMPORTANT POINT IN TERMS OF
OPPOSITION WHERE THERE'S A
POTENTIAL INCREASE ELECTRIC
RATES BECAUSE YOU'RE GONNA HAVE
TO UPGRADE THE LOCAL- JUST USE A
NETWORK TO SELL THEM THOSE COSTS
ARE ALWAYS FUN TO THE RATE
PAYERS AND WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
BEING STATIONS AND FAMILY.
THOUGH THE WILL BE AREAS WHERE
THEY FLOWING. FOUNDER THAT THAT
IS THE KIND AND I JUST ASKED YOU
TO TAKE A LOOK AT THAT GOING
FORWARD AND WHAT THAT WOULD.
KNOW THE YOUR LIMIT AND THEN BUT
THAT IS THE POTENTIAL. AFFECT
RATEPAYERS WITH THE INSULATION I
THINK THOUGH FOR BIG DEFEAT TO
THE SHE- BE UP THIS STREET FOR.
FORWARD SUPPORT BUILT. YEAH I
COURSE THE MINNESOTA REALLY JUST
MEANS IT MORE. LOWER INCOME
PEOPLE HAVE ACCESS TO A IN THEIR
GARAGE. SO. YEAH I MEAN SO IF
THE QUESTION IS COMES TO ME THAT
THE BROADER QUESTION IS WE
CLEARLY NEED MORE TRANSMISSION
CAPACITY. I TO MEET OUR ELECTRIC
BILLS WRIT LARGE IS NO QUESTION
ABOUT THAT AND THAT WILL TAKE
INVESTMENT EFFECT WE WERE
TALKING ABOUT AND SENATE
DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS TODAY THAT
THAT'S GONNA BE. PART OF THE
BUDGET- BUT- BUT IT BUT IT WILL
SAVE ME FROM AN EQUITY
PERSPECTIVE THIS ACTUALLY IS
ULTIMATELY ABOUT MAKING SURE.
THAT A LOT OF FOLKS- I TAKE FOR
GRANTED THAT I CAN. HAVE AG
ALLEGES LEXICAL ACCESS IN MY
GARAGE IS THE SITE NOT A REALITY
FOR THIS. BUT LARGE NUMBER OF
LOWER NCOME PEOPLE AND SO
THAT'S REALLY WHAT THIS IS ABOUT
MAKING SURE THAT THEY HAVE
ACCESS IN THEIR GARAGE
ELECTRICITY I. DISAGREED ALL THE
THIS IS. THE SOUTH. PEOPLE ARE
NOT YOU THERE'S BEEN A PAPER.
AND OUT OF THE ISSUE WITH THE-
ALL OF THE- CHARGING. STATION
THAT THROUGHOUT OUR- THIRTY NO
RATE. ARE GOING TO GET BE PAYING
FOR THAT LOWER THE- OF WEAKER
HAVE. THERE'S NEVER BEEN A
REALLY AND I. OF THAT AND I
THINK THOSE THINGS GET LOST. IN
THE GOAL OF LIFE THAT OF HAVING
A OBJECTIVES TO MEET THOSE GOALS
FOR. OBJECTIVE TAKING INTO
CONSIDERATION. THE COST OF THAT
ARE. YOU KNOW- IT HERITAGE. IN
INCREASING THE TRANSPORTATION
NETWORK FOR ELECTRICITY YES I'M
JUST SAYING WE HAVE TO PAY
ATTENTION TO THAT. AND IT WILL
BE A SPIT. OUT GREAT. YEAH WHEN
IT HAS HE TO WHAT IT IS. IT'S
THAT WE'RE WORKING ON RIGHT NOW
WITHIN THE TWO THE TO KEEP ONES
TO BE HONEST OUR THAT ISSUE
RIGHT TO HOW DO YOU WHO PAYS
RIGHT SO WHAT WHAT SORT OF
MECHANISM TO HAVE IN PLACE. TO
YOUR EQUITY WHEN IT COMES TO THE
PERSON WHO'S USING ELECTRICITY
TO PAY FOR ELECTRICITY- AND THEN
THE OTHER ONE HAS TO DO WITH PRE
PRE ASSIGNED PARKING SPACES
WHICH I GUESS IS IN A RELATED
RIGHT I MEAN HOW HOW DO YOU MAKE
SURE THAT- YOU CREATE A SYSTEM
OF COURSE YOU KNOW FOR SO MANY
OF US I MEAN IT I MEAN H. A.
WHERE. WE ALL PAY COLLECTIVELY
WATER SO THERE'S NO YOU KNOW
WHOEVER USE A LOT OF WATER IS
SICKLY AFTER WEST WEEK THE BILL
ON IT ARE YOU. SO THIS IS THIS
IS THE POINT AND IN I REALLY
INVITE ANYONE. HOW WE WRITE THIS
IN A WAY THAT WILL. MAKE IT FAIR
FOR EVERYBODY- I PLEASE HELP US
BECAUSE THIS IS THIS IS ONE OF
THE ONE OF THE KEY STICKING
POINTS WE'RE TRYING TO WORK
THROUGH WITH INDUSTRY. GOT Q.
VICE CHAIR BATES SEE NO OTHER
MIKES UP WE DO HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR NEWMAN MISTER CHIEF
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
. THE MOTION IS DUE PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SENATORS GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ I BATES. BATES NO ALLEN
AYE ALLEN AYE HOW TO LETTER OR
TWO LETTERS HI BAKER. BAKER I
CORTESE CORTESE I. DALI. DOT DOT
HI LIMÓN BEFORE MCGUIRE.
MELENDEZ MEN NEWMAN NEWMAN AYE
RUBIO RUBIO AYE SKINNER AYE
CASKEY WILK. THANK YOU MEMBERS
THANK YOU EIGHT ONE. THANK YOU
WILL LEAVE THE BILL ON CALL. ALL
RIGHT AND NEXT WE'LL MOVE ON TO
FILE ITEM SIXTEEN SENATOR
ARCHULETA SB TWELVE FORTY NINE
SENATOR YOU MAY BEGIN THANK YOU
THANK YOU MANAGER- IN THE- WHICH
IS THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS THANK
YOU SO MUCH. FOR YOUR PATIENCE
HAS BEEN A LONG DAY. TO
APPRECIATE. WHICH AGAIN TODAY
I'M PRESENTED SENATE BILL TWELVE
FORTY NINE WHICH SEEKS TO
MODERNIZE THE NON GOVERNMENTAL
CHARGE KNOWN AS THE DOCUMENT
PROCESSING CHARGE THAT AUTO A
REAL DEALERSHIPS MAY COLLECT IN
ORDER. OVER THEIR PAST. APRIL
ARM TO COMPLETE VEHICLE SALES AT
LEAST TRANSACTIONS. CALIFORNIA
DEALERSHIPS PROVIDE A ONE STOP
SHOP FOR CONSUMER SERVICES
INCLUDING DMV TRANSACTIONS LOAN
PROCESSING PRIVACY AND FRAUD
PROTECTION CONTRACT- GRANT
ACTIONS AND TRANSLATIONS VEHICLE
TRADE IN SERVICES WAR TO
SERVICES AND OF COURSE MUCH MUCH
MORE. WITHOUT DEALER BASE
DOCUMENT PROCESSING SERVICES
CUSTOMERS WOULD HAVE TO GO
THROUGH SEVERAL SIGNIFICANT
STEPS ON THEIR OWN TO PROCESS A
COMPLETE BILL BIRCH. OR LEASE
RENT INCLUDING INTEREST
DEPARTMENT MOTOR VEHICLES TO
COMPLETE MULTIPLE STEPS GOING TO
AND FROM THE BANK- SHOP. EACH ON
THE ROAD VS PARTY RIGHTS NOPE
PER AVAIL. TO COVER THIS STAFF
TIME AND COST THE TECHNOLOGY AND
EQUIPMENT ASSOCIATED WITH THESE
OBLIGATIONS HERE IN CALIFORNIA
CURRENTLY ALLOWS AUTOMOBILE
DEALERSHIPS TO COLLECT A
STATUTORY MAXIMUM DOCUMENT
PROCESSING CHARGE OF ONLY EIGHTY
FIVE DOLLARS PER TRANSACTION.
THE DOCUMENT PROCESSING CHARGE
LIKE OTHER CHARGERS AND CONSUMER
CHARGES MUST BE ITEMIZED AND
EXPLICITLY DISCLOSED TO
CONSUMERS PRIOR TO THE PURCHASE
OF THE VEHICLE AND THEY WILL BE.
AND THEY CONTINUED TO BE. THREE
MAXIMUM EIGHTY FIVE DOLLARS IS
BY FAR THE LOWEST DOCUMENT
PROCESSING CHARGE IN THE COUNTRY
AND AMOUNTS TO A FOURTH OF THE
NATIONAL AVERAGE FOR THOSE
WONDERING THE NATIONAL AVERAGES
THE AVERAGE DOCUMENT PROCESSING
CHARGE BEING CHARGED AND ALL
FIFTY STAGE WHICH IS MUCH. MUCH
LOWER THAN CALIFORNIA MUCH
HIGHER THAN CALIFORNIA WHICH
INCLUDES STAGE WITH STATUTORY
CAPS LIKE CALIFORNIA THE STATE
WITH NO CAPS AT ALL I WAS
APPROXIMATELY THREE HUNDRED
SEVENTY FIVE DOLLARS PER- THE
REQUESTED WE'RE MAKING WILL BE-
A LITTLE HIGHER AT A HUNDRED
SEVENTY FIVE DOLLARS WE'VE
SHARED THAT INFORMATION WITH THE
CHAIR AND SHE'S AGREED TO.
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT IT IS NOT TO.
IS DOABLE TWELVE FORTY NINE
WOULD BEGIN IN TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR AND OVER A SIX YEAR PERIOD
MODERNIZE THE NON GOVERNMENTAL
CHARGE THAT OUR DEALERSHIPS MAY
COLLECT WHEN SELLING OR LEASING
A VEHICLE TO ENSURE THAT THE
DEALERSHIPS AND THEIR EMPLOYEES
CAN OVER THEIR COSTS THAT
CONTINUE PROVIDING IMPORTANT
SERVICES FOR CONSUMERS AT THE
TIME OF THE OF THE VEHICLE
PURCHASE NOW I UNDERSTAND THAT
YOU WANT. THE SIMPLER APPROACH
BY PUTTING CALIFORNIA IN LINE
WITH THE STATE'S LIKE NEW YORK
AT IS WE HAVE. I'M WILLING TO
ACCEPT AND THAT I WOULD PUT
CALIFORNIA FROM. AFAR FOR LOWEST
RATE TO A NATIONAL. AVERAGE
BELOW THE AVERAGE ACTUALLY AND
WE WILL CONTINUE THE PROGRESS AT
WITH ME TODAY AND TESTIFY ON
BEHALF OF THIS IMPORTANT BILL IS
ANTHONY SAMPSON ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA NEW CAR DEALERS
ASSOCIATION. BOB SMITH EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE GREATER LOS
ANGELES CAR DEALERS ASSOCIATION.
AND MADAM CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOATS- AT THE TIME THANK
YOU CENTER ARCHULETA MISTER
SIMPSON. BUT AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS ANTHONY SAMPSON
THE SAMPSON ADVISORS ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA NEW CAR
DEALERS ASSOCIATION CNC DA IS
PLEASED TO SPONSOR SB TWELVE
FORTY NINE. AND WE APPRECIATE
SENATOR ARE TO LET IS HARD WORK
ON THE MEASURE AS WELL AS THAT
CHAIRWOMAN COMMITTEE STAFF
ENGAGEMENT TO DATE. SENATE
ARCHULETA DID AN EXCELLENT JOB
SUMMARIZING THE BILL SO I JUST
LIKE TO FOCUS ON A FEW POINTS.
IT'S RECOVERING CLASS THIS
FUNDAMENTAL ANY BUSINESS THAT BE
A LOCAL MONPA SHOPS. OR A LARGER
BUSINESS MANY BUSINESSES RECOVER
THEIR COSTS BY IMPOSING VARIOUS
CHARGES THAT GO BY DIFFERENT
NAMES CORDIC CONVENIENCE CHARGE
SERVICE CHARGE I SAW
DEPRECIATION CHARGE RECENTLY
ESCROW CHARGE. AND RECENTLY A
LARGE ONLINE RETAILER. ADDED A
FOOD FUEL AND INFLATION CHARGE.
CALL IT WHAT YOU WANT THOSE
CHARGES EXIST SO THAT BUSINESSES
CAN RECOVER THEIR COST OF DOING
BUSINESS WHICH IS STARKLY
SPEAKING INCREASE OVER THE
COURSE OF TIME. AND THAT HAS
CERTAINLY BEEN TRUE OF
INCREASING OUR PATIENTS PLACED
ON NEW CAR DEALERS. BUT WHAT IS
UNIQUE IN THE CONTEXT OF AUTO
DEALERSHIPS IS THAT FOR SEVERAL
DECADES. CALIFORNIA LAW HAS
BACKED DID THAT HAS DESIGNATED
THE DOCUMENT PROCESSING CHARGE A
STATUTORILY CAP CHARGE AS THE
MECHANISM TO COLLECT COSTS. A SO
. SENATOR- ARCH. MENTION TO BE
CLEAR DEALERSHIPS VIEW THE
DOCUMENT PROCESS CHARGE AS THE
EXCLUSIVE MECHANISM THROUGH
WHICH IT CAN RECOVER ITS
DOCUMENT PROCESSING COSTS. SO
WHILE BUSINESSES OF ALL TYPES
CONTINUE TO IMPOSE NEW OR
INCREASED CHARGES AND FEES TO
COVER THEIR COSTS. AUTO
DEALERSHIPS MUST CONTINUE TO
COME BACK TO THE LEGISLATURE TO
DO SO. SECOND THE COMEDIAN ELSE
TALKED A BIT ABOUT VEHICLE
PRICING SO I'D LIKE TO JUST
ADDRESS THAT ISSUE HEAD ON.
CONSUMER PRICES ARE HIGH ACROSS
THE BOARD RANGING FROM CONSUMER
GOODS THAT YOU BUY AT TARGET. TO
FOOD THAT YOU BUY AT THE GROCERY
STORE SUPPLYING KATE SUPPLY
CHAIN CONSTRAINTS IN
INFLATIONARY FACTORS COUPLED
WITH HIGH DEMAND FOR VEHICLES
AND NOT ENOUGH INVENTORY. IS
RESULTING IN HIGHER PRICES BUT
VEHICLE PRICING LIKE THE PRICING
OF OTHER CONSUMER GOODS IS
CYCLICAL AND JUST BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC VEHICLE PRICES WERE
BELOW THE MSRP. FROM TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN TO TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY ONE CONSUMERS PAID ABOUT
TWENTY THREE HUNDRED IS BELOW
THE MANUFACTURE TO. RETAIL PRICE
ON AVERAGE WILL GO ON AGAIN.
AIN'S CONSTANT AND WHAT IS A
SEPARATE ISSUE FROM ICAL PRICING
IS THE FACT THAT AUTO DEALERSHIP
OBLIGATIONS CONTINUE TO
INCREASE. AND THE DOCUMENT
PROCESSING CHARGE HAS NOT KEPT
PACE ALONG WITH IT. AND ALL OF
AND BY JUST NOTING. THAT WE ARE
CERTAINLY NOT VERY TO THE BILL
IMPRINT WE'VE AGAIN REITERATE
THE SENATOR'S COMMENTS WE SPOKE
INTO THE CHARITY COMMITTEE. AND
APPRECIATE AGAIN YOUR ENGAGEMENT
LOOK FORWAD TO WORKING WITH YOU
ON ANY REMAINING ISSUES AFTER
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER. THANK YOU AND OUR NEXT
WE HAVE MISTER BOB SMITH.
GREATER LOS ANGELES NEW CAR
DEALERS ASSOCIATION ON THE
COASTLINE. MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
THE FINAL VOTE. NEED TO FIX A
BROKEN RECORD LIKE FOR BOTH HE
SAYS LOOK TO SCHEDULE COMPRISED
THE PROJECT MOTOR VEHICLE
DEALERSHIPS LOCATED WITHIN THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY AREA COMBINED
THE DEALERSHIP SUPPORT OVER.
THIRTY ONE THOUSAND FULL TIME
WORKERS IN THE REGION. PLEASE TO
SPEAK TODAY SUPPORT OF THE V.
TWELVE NINE ONE OF. THE LUXURY
IT SHOW THE- AND THE COMMITTEES
THAT YOUR HARD WORK ON THIS
MEASURE. OKAY DEALERS AND I'M
NOT. THE CARD THE STATE AS WELL
TAKE PRIDE IN THE WE DO FOR.
CONSUMERS MY FAMILY IS DEAL TO
CALIFORNIA OVER ONE HUNDRED
YEARS HE BEGAT THE COR WE SHOULD
SEPARATE FIFTY. TWENTY WHY
DEALERSHIPS INCLUDE DODGE BOTH
FOR AUDI. FIAT THANK YOU WE HAVE
BEEN AND TOYOTA WELL HARD TELL
WHAT THE BEHIND SCENES THE
VEHICLE BACK. PEOPLE SHOULD NINE
FORTY. THAT ABOUT OF SERVICES
FOR CUSTOMERS THAT PROVIDE THE
SERVICES TO CONSUMERS WILL NEED
TO GO TO THE DMV AFTER
PURCHASING OR LEASING A VEHICLE
IT PROVIDES DOCUMENT TRANSLATION
SERVICES. TO HELP ARRANGE
VEHICLE FINANCING INSPECT THE
VALUE VEHICLE TRADE AND THE
PROVIDE. PROTECT M. FIVE. ALL
THE SERVICES CRITICAL TO A PART
CONSUMER. AT A DEALERSHIP BY
DEALERSHIP ONE CONTINUED PERFORM
SERVICES AND DO WITH THAT TO
ENSURE. AND PROTECT EXPERIENCE
FOR CALIFORNIA MOST. ACCORDING
AT THAT TIME BECAUSE. I'M A
DEALERSHIP OBLIGATIONS HAVE YOU
CAN INCREASE THE DOCTOR FOSTER
CHARGE HAVE NOT KEPT THE AND
DEALERSHIPS ARE NOT A TO WITH
THEIR COSTS WITH THE FROM
INSTRUCTORS. BALLACHULISH WITH
FIVE BEING THE VICTIM OF A
THOUGHT. PROCESSING AND
COMPLIANCE WITH IN THE COUNTRY.
NOT FUTURE ARE ABLE TO IS BY FAR
THE IN THE- I UNDERSTAND THAT
YOU'RE A WOMAN MANY OF THEM
WORKING CLOSELY WITH OUR
PARTNERS WITH IBM THAT'S YOUR I
WOULD LIKE TO REITERATE
APPRECIATION OF ARCHULETA. CHAU
WOMAN. MAY ON BEHALF THE
DEALERSHIP IS THAT YEAH. THANK
YOU MISTER SMITH SO IF CONCLUDED
OUR LEAD WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF
SB TWELVE NINE SO WE'LL TAKE IT
TO THE GALLERY ANYONE WHO IS TO
TELL. AS TWELVE. CASEY NINE I
WILL TAKE IT BACK TO THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE MODERATOR TO
HAVE ANYONE ELSE WHO'D LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB TWELVE
FORTY NINE WE'RE TAKING HIS NAME
AN ORGANIZATION PLEASE. IF YOU
HAVE TO FIND PART OF SB TWELVE
THREE NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
. WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE SIXTY.
AND ALL OF THE MEMBERS OF THE
BAR JUNIOR WE HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA WATERFIX ABUSE THE
VISION WE ARE CALLING FOR THE
NEW CAR DEALERS AND PORT. THANK
YOU. MEZQUITAL LINE. TO SEVENTY
TWO SEVEN ZERO. MADAM CHAIRMAN
OF THE COMMITTEE JOHN MOFFETT ON
BEHALF OF THE ENTERPRISE RENTAL
CAR ENTERPRISE CAR SALES IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THERE'S NO
ONE ELSE IN THE FIELD. THANK YOU
MODERATOR US IN NOW WILL MOVE TO
OPPOSITION THERE'S NO REGISTERED
LEAD OPPOSITION SO WE'LL TAKE IT
TO THE GALLERY ANYONE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO OPPOSE SB TWELVE FORTY
NINE PLEASE. C. NONE OF WILL
TAKE IT BACK TO THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE FOR ANYONE
ELSE WOULD LIKE TO OPPOSE. SB
TWELVE FORTY NINE AT THIS TIME.
IF YOU WERE IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION PRESS ONE ZERO.
MODERATOR IF YOU DON'T HAVE
ANYONE- QUEUED UP TO OPPOSE THEM
WILL CONCLUDE OUR TELECONFERENCE
LINE THERE- WE'LL TAKE IT BACK
TO THE DIETS FOR ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS. THE
VICE CHAIR BATES I'D LIKE TO
THANK YOU SENATOR ARCHULETA FOR
WORKING SO HARD TO GET THE FEET
DOWN FROM WHAT WAS ORIGINALLY.
PROPOSED I AM STILL CONCERNED
ABOUT TO SPEAKING ON NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE DOLLARS OUT
OF. YOU KNOW WITH NO REAL BACK
I'M GOING TO SUPPORT IT TODAY.
THAT WE CAN HAVE A FURTHER
CONVERSATION ABOUT THE
LEGITIMACY OF BECAUSE I'M VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF FEE FOR SERVICE
ESPECIALLY FOR THOSE WHO ARE
PRODUCING GOOD SENSOR. BOB BUT
ALSO BE MINDFUL OF THE CONSUMER
IN ENSURING THAT HE UNDERSTANDS
OUR HE UNDERSTANDS WHAT THIS
ACTUALLY IS FOR AND WITHOUT IT
THEY WOULD. PROTECT THOSE THAT
SOME OF THOSE DOT REALLY
PROVIDES AND I THINK THAT'S
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT. IN OUR OF
OUR CAR SALES IN OUR STATE I
THINK. THIS BILL EITHER ON OUT
TO ENSURE THERE'S CONSUMER
PROTECTION SO WE'LL HAVE A
CONVERSATION ON THAT I WANT TO
LET THEM. YOU KNOW THAT I
APPRECIATE BECAUSE OFF WITH WHO.
WE FOR WHATEVER YOU'VE BEEN
WORKING VERY HARD TO GET A
JUSTIFICATION AND I THINK OUR-
OUR CAR DEALERS HAVE CERTAINLY
BEEN WORKING VERY HARD ON THAT
TOO BECAUSE WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT
WHAT THEY'RE- WHAT. THE EVEN
BEST RECORD. THERE'S A HUGE GAP
THERE I SEE THE DELTA NEEDS YOU
NARROWED BUT WE NEED TO
UNDOCUMENTED. ON THAT SO I WOULD
APPRECIATE THAT GOING FORWARD
YOU'LL HAVE MY SUPPORT TODAY.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
AND AGAIN THE AMENDMENTS- WILL
INCREASE THE DOCUMENT PROCESSING
CHARGE TO ONE SEVENTY FIVE- THIS
IS ACTUALLY- OBTAINED BY- WHEN
LOOKING AT OTHER STATES NEW
YORK- WAS ALSO AT ONE SEVENTY
FIVE IT SEEMED TO BE AN AVERAGE-
AT THAT. SORT OF THE NEXT STEP
ABOUT FIVE THAT WE CURRENT SET
UP RUBIO. THANK YOU AND I'M
CHAIR I ALSO I'M IN TO BE
SUPPORTIVE OF THE BILL I DO
APPRECIATE THE- SENATOR- FROM
OPTICAL RIVERA COMING FORWARD
AND DOT BRING THIS FLORIDA YOU
KNOW I DON'T THINK YOU MENTIONED
IT BUT I THINK THAT FEE HAS NOT
BEEN CHANGED SINCE. CORRECT ME
IF I'M WRONG BUT I THINK IT'S
NINETEEN SIXTY NINE AND- AND WE
DO KNOW THINGS HAVE BECOME A LOT
MORE COSTLY- BUT- IT WAS ALSO
STATED THAT IT WAS THE LOWEST IN
THE COUNTRY AND TO AND I THINK
IT'S A MODEST INCREASE AT BUT I
TO- YOU KNOW IF THERE'S AN
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS SECOND.
THAT TO REMOVE. THERE PAYING
FOR- HELTER IT OVER TO YOU TO
SEE IF THERE'S ANY SAFEGUARDS OR
ANY MANDATE WHERE THEY NEED TO-
OUTLINED WHAT THEY'RE PAYING FOR
THANK YOU. KEEP UP SAID
ARCHULETA WOULD YOU LIKE TO YES
THANK YOU MEDICARE AND OVER
SPECIALLY LIKE TO THANK YOU FOR
HELPING ME WITH THE AMENDMENT.
AND THAT IS ACTUALLY TAKEN THIS
OVER THE TOP AND IT ADDRESSES SO
MANY THINGS THAT WE WOULD HAVE
BEEN- DEBATING BACK AND FORTH
BUT YOUR SUPPORT HAS BEEN
IMMENSE AND I APPRECIATED. AND
THE ONE SEVENTY FIVE AS- MY
SENATOR FROM BALDWIN PARK LEFT
WEDNESDAY IT AND THE SAN GABRIEL
VALLEY HAS STATED IT HAS BEEN
YEARS UPON YEARS UPON YEARS
SINCE THERE'S BEEN AN INCREASE.
AND AS THE BY SHOULDN'T WORK
EQUAL PAY AND IT SHOULD BE NOTED
THAT- A LOT OF WORK AND EFFORT
GOES INTO BY THE DEALERSHIP. AND
THE OTHER THING IT OPENS THE
DOOR EVEN FURTHER FOR
TRANSPARENCY AND SO THE CONSUMER
KNOWS THE TRUCKS ACTION THE COST
IN THE TIME THE EFFORT AND- IN
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT COMES TO
WORKING WITH DMV. SO WITH ALL
THE WORK THAT'S THERE I THINK
THIS IS GOOD BILL AND I'D
CERTAINLY. APPRECIATE YOUR FOR
YOUR SUPPORT. AND AYE URGENT AYE%
VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO
ARCH. AND I BELIEVE WE HAVE A
BIT THE- BILL HAS MOVED BY
SENATOR RUBIO AT THE TIME. THANK
YOU NO OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
AND ARCHULETA ONCE AGAIN I URGE
YOU AND I BOTH THANK YOU THANK
YOU MISTER CHIEF CONSULTANT CAN
YOU. CALL THE MOTION IS DUE PASS
AS AMENDED HE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SENATORS GONZALEZ HI GONZALEZ I.
BATES BATES AYE ALLEN. ARCHULETA
HI ARCHULETA HIGH BECKER. BAKER
ODD CORTESE CORTESE I. DOLLY.
DOT DODD HI LIMÓN MCGUIRE
MELENDEZ MAN. NEWMAN RUBIO HI
RUBIO AYE SKINNER BY CASKEY
WELCOME. SEVEN ZERO OKAY SEVEN
ZERO LEAVE THE BILL ON CALL
THANK YOU CENTER ARCHULETA- NOW
WILL MOVE ON TO YOUR NEXT BILL
FILE ITEM SEVENTEEN SB TWELVE
NINETY ONE. ONCE AGAIN THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS- I AM PLEASED TO SUBMIT.
TO YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
SENATE BILL TWELVE NINETY ONE
WHICH WOULD DIRECT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO ADMINISTRATIVELY
APPROVED HYDROGEN REFUELLING
STATIONS. AS THEY DO CURRENTLY
FOR CHARGING STATIONS AND OF
COURSE THE- THE SPIRIT OF
TODAY'S BEEN- TO LOOK FORWARD TO
THE FUTURE AND I THINK THIS IS
WHAT THIS BILL DOES. IN
CONJUNCTION WITH THE CHARGES
STATE. IN ORDER TO MEET OUR
FUTURE CLEAN TRANSPORTATION
GOALS INCLUDING THE TRANSITION
TO ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE SALES
BY TWENTY THIRTY FIVE THE
AVAILABILITY OF FUELING
INFRASTRUCTURE MUST BE INCREASED
AND IT MIGHT. AND I. COME BACK.
INTO IS LOOKING IN THAT
DIRECTION WE KNOW CONSUMERS WILL
NOT ADOPT ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES
IF THE WRECKER SHOULD FUELING
INFRASTRUCTURE IS NOT WIDELY
AVAILABLE TO INCLUDE ELECTRIC.
TO THAT END SENATE BILL TWELVE
NINETY ONE TO REACH A PATH TO
EASE THE INITIAL PERMITTING
PROCESS FOR HYDROGEN FUELING
STATIONS AND WELL THIS BILL
PRESERVES LOCAL AUTHORITY TO
DENY A PERMIT BASED ON SAFETY
TO. PUBLIC HEALTH THE MEASURE
READ. WILL GOVERNOR A GOVERNMENT
AND OFFICIALS TO DISCLOSE
CONCERNS AND OFFER SOLUTIONS
UNDER THE ENERGY COMMISSION
ACCOUNTABILITY- METRICS IT IS
HYDROGEN IN THE HYDROGEN STATION
PROGRAM THAT MUST BE ALLOWED TO
SECURE PERMITS AND TO DO IT
OPENLY. SO EVERYONE UNDERSTANDS
THE PROCESS AND- THE ISSUES IT
TAKES UP TO EIGHTEEN MONTHS TO
COLLECT DATA AND EVENTUALLY GET
A PERMIT IN TWENTY TWENTY WHEN
THE JOINT CALIFORNIA ENERGY
COMMISSION AND CALIFORNIA
RESEARCHERS REPORT. REPORTED
THAT GETTING A HUNDRED STATIONS
SOMETIMES IT WOULD TAKE- WELL
BEYOND FIVE HUNDRED DAYS SO AS I
MENTIONED IT TAKES TOO LONG THIS
WILL STREAMLINE THE PROCESS THE
CITY ACCOUNT WILL STILL
ADMINISTRATOR APPROVE OR DENY AN
APPLICATION TO INSTALL ELECTRIC
VEHICLE CHARGING STATIONS OR
HYDROGEN FUEL STATIONS- THROUGH
THE ISSUE ISSUANCE A BUILDING
PERMIT. IT IS UP TO THE CITY
COUNTY IT IS UP TO THEM IT IS
LOCAL IN ADDITION A CITY HAS THE
AUTHORITY TO REQUIRE ADDITIONAL
PERMITTING IF NECESSARY. SENATE
BILL TWELVE NINETY ONE INCREASED
PERMITTING REQUIREMENTS WITHOUT
SACRIFICING LOCAL CONTROL WHILE
ENSURING THAT ELECTRIC CHARGING
STATIONS AND HYDROGEN FUEL
STATIONS ARE BEING INSTALLED IN
ORDER TO KEEP PACE WITH THE
STATE'S GOAL OF INCREASING
ELECTRIC. VEHICLE USAGE AND
HYDROGEN FUELING STATIONS WITH
ME HERE TODAY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL IS THERESA
COOK ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA I
DO QUESTION AND FOR THE
INFORMATION GIVEN YOU I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR IBOOK
THANK YOU CENTER CHILL AT A MISS
COOK WELCOME THANK YOU SENATOR
SB TWELVE NINETY ONE IS A MODEST
BERGER TERESA COOK ON BEHALF OF
HEALTH AND.
ACTOR KEUCHEL'S REST ASSURED
THIS BILL DOES NOT ELIMINATE
LOCAL CONTROL TO REQUIRED
DISCRETIONARY PERMIT BUT SENDS A
CLEAR SIGNAL TO CITIES AND
COUNTIES TO WORK COLLABORATIVELY
WITH INDUSTRY TO DEVELOP
ADEQUATE ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE
INFRASTRUCTURE WHICH IS THE
BIGGEST BARRIER TO CONSUMER
ADOPTION WE ARE PLEASED TO
SPONSOR THIS MEASURE AND
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR I.
ABOUT THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISS
COOK. NOW WILL MOVE ON TO ANYONE
ELSE IN THE GALLERY WHO WOULD
LIKE TO SUPPORT SB TWELVE NINETY
ONE. MCGILL'S CARRILLO WITH
WALKER GROUP OF A HALF OF LINDE
PLC IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
MATANCERA COMMITTEE MEMBERS A
CRISP ON BEHALF OF OBERON FUELS
THEIR OCCULT BASED COMPANY THAT-
IS LOCATED IN ABOUT HAS A FIELD-
D. PRODUCES DIMETHYL ETHER. FUEL
DOWN IT IS PROBABLY FACILITIES
FOR TRANSPORTATION FUEL
INCLUDING- AT CONVERTING THAT-
THAT FUEL INTO HYDROGEN OUR
CLIENT HAS A SUPPORT IF AMENDED
POSITION- FULLY SUPPORT THE
INTENT OF THE BILL OF. LAW THE
LEADERSHIP OF THE BILL'S AUTHOR
IN THIS SPACE- WE DO HAVE A
CONCERN WITH REGARDS TO THE-
CURRENT DEFINITION OF HYDROGEN
FUELING STATION THAT IT DOESN'T
ENCOMPASS THE TECHNOLOG. THAT
O'BRIEN IS A READY TO DEPLOY ON
SITE IT STATIONS INFRASTRUCTURES
TO CONVERT WHAT'S KNOWN AS DIEM
IN INTO HYDROGEN WE'VE HAD
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE OFFICE
OFFER AUTHOR OFFICE AS WELL AS
THE SPONSORS WE LOOK FOR TO
REACH IN THIS ISSUE AS A BILL
MOST. THE YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU
ANYONE WHO'D LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SB TWELVE NINETY ONE
AT THIS TIME. RIGHT C. NINE A
MODERATOR WILL TAKE IT BACK TO
THE TELECONFERENCE LINE FOR
ANYONE WHO'D LIKE TO SUPPORT SB
TWELVE NINETY ONE PLACE. THANK
YOU MDAM CHAIR FOR ANYONE WHO'D
LIKE TO SUPPORT SB TWELVE NINETY
ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO.
WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE FIFTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AFTERNOON BUILD
YOUR PROGRAM YOU HAVE TO BEAR
THE FETUS OR- THANK YOU RECORDED
LINE TO SEVENTY ONE PLEASE GO
OUT. AND OKAY POSTED ON THE
LEFT. OKAY MY TWO SEVENTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WILL MOVE ON
TO THE NEXT COMMENT MODERATOR.
THANK YOU I WON SIXTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI JOHN MICHAEL
PARTON REPRESENTING OVER A DOZEN
WRITERS PRODUCERS AND DIRECTORS
PROBLEMS HOLDEN STRONG SUPPORT
SB TWELVE NINETY ONE. THANK YOU
THERE ARE NO FURTHER LINE TO
SUPPORT PLEASE CONTINUE MANAGER
THANK YOU MODERATOR SO NOW WE'LL
MOVE ON TO OPPOSITION WE DO NOT
HAVE ANY REGISTERED OPPOSITION
AT THIS TIME SO AND IN THE
GALLERY IN OPPOSITION TO SB
TWELVE NINETY ONE PLACE. HI
LINDA HUTCHINS KNOWLES ON BEHALF
OF A TERRA. WE ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT THIS BILL BECAUSE WE SEE
THAT THE INDUSTRY HAS MOVED
DECISIVELY IN FAVOR OF
AUTOMOTIVE TECHNOLOGY. AND NOT
FOR HYDROGEN FOR LIGHT DUTY
VEHICLES. THERE ARE MANY REASONS
WHY BATTERY ELECTRIC. ARE MUCH
SUPERIOR TO FUEL VEHICLES FIRST
THEY ARE MUCH MORE EFFICIENT.
ALSO 95% OF THE HYDROGEN
CURRENTLY USED IN FUEL CELL
VEHICLES COMES FROM FOSSIL FUEL
SOURCES THIS IS A COUNTRY TO OUR
CLIMATE GOALS. SECOND BATTERY
ELECTRIC VEHICLES ARE MUCH MORE
ECONOMICAL FOR DRIVERS. THE COST
FOUR TIMES AS MUCH TO FUEL AND
FCV BE LIKE A TOYOTA MIRAI MIRAI
THAN A BATTLE TO VEHICLE LIKE A
TESLA MODEL S. AND THIRD DRIVING
BEVS ARE MUCH MORE PRACTICAL
THAN FC VIS. THERE ARE
APPROXIMATELY FORTY FOUR
HYDROGEN FUEL STATIONS IN
CALIFORNIA I KNOW THIS BILL IS
TRYING TO PUT IT MORE BUT EACH
ONE COST ONE TO TWO MILLION
DOLLARS. WE COULD INSTALL.
1-004-322-0080 SIX ELECTRIC
VEHICLE CHARGERS FOR EVERY
HYDROGEN FUEL PUMP THEY BUILD.
THEIR ALSO DEEMED OF COMPLETED
CONCERNS OF HYDROGEN FILLING
STATIONS IT MAKES NO ECONOMIC
SENSE TO SPEND MILLIONS MORE FOR
HYDROGEN FUEL PUMPS WHICH WILL
BE USED BY A FEW IN UP AT. THE
CONVENIENCE OF HOME. GIVEN THE
DOMINANCE OF BIOCEUTICALS OVER
FUEL CELL VEHICLES IN THIS OF
LATE TO THE MARKET. AND THE
CLEAR CLIMATE ECONOMIC
INCONVENIENCE ADVANTAGES OF
BATHS THE STATE SHOULD NOT
INVEST MORE MONEY IN BUILDING
OUT HYDROGEN FILLING STATIONS.
WE SHOULD INSTEAD FOCUS ON
EXPORTING ACCELERATE EQUITABLE
OPTION ABOUT ELECTRIC VEHICLES
SO WE EXPRESS OUR CONCERN WITH
THIS BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE'LL TAKE THAT AS
LEAD. WITNESS IN OPPOSITION SO
ANYONE ELSE IN THE GALLERY WHO
WOULD LIKE TO OPPOSE BETWEEN
NINETY PLACE. CORM GUY HOLE IN
THE- NATIONAL ELECTRIC VEHICLE
ASSOCIATION. SUPPORTS USE OF
FUEL CELL TECHNOLOGY IN THE
HEAVY DUTY IN MARINA SPACE BUT
THE- BELIEVE IT'S INAPPROPRIATE
IN THE LEAD TO THE- SPACE AND-
AND THEY'RE CONSTANTLY- OPPOSES.
THIS BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SB TWELVE NINETY ONE
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION. TO
THE BILL. OKAY SEE NONE WILL
MOVE TO THE TELECONFERENCE LINE
FOR ANYONE ELSE WHO'D LIKE TO
OPPOSE SB TWELVE NINETY ONE
PLEASE. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR IF
ANYONE WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB TWELVE NINETY
ONE THIS PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE
SEVENTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO THIS IS OFTEN LONG GREEN
GRANT WHILE THE RIVAL. AND I
PULLED THE BILL- FOR REASONS OF.
DATA BEFORE THE INFRASTRUCTURE
IS SO EXPENSIVE IT WILL NEVER
GET IN RURAL COMMUNITIES. AND WE
NEED AFFORDABILITY THANK YOU.
I'M GOING TO LIVE TO SEVENTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I TWO SEVENTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WE'LL GO
TO LINE ONE OH TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. LOOKING EVERY I CAN HEAR
YOU. YEAH DEREK JOHNSON THE
MANAGER OF POLICY AND EXTERNAL
RELATIONS THERE ARE- REITERATING
OUR ORGANIZATION'S CONCERN
OPPOSITION WITH THIS BILL. THERE
ARE NO FURTHER LINES IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE CONTINUE OKAY
THANK YOU WE'VE CONCLUDED
SUPPORT OPPOSITION WILL TAKE IT
BACK TO THE DAYS ANY MEMBERS
HAVE ANY COMMENTS OR CONCERNS
QUESTIONS SB TWELVE NINETY ONE.
EIGHT C. NINE WELL I AM A
SENATOR ARCHULETA. I JUST WANT
TO SAY THANK YOU FOR- WORKING
WITH THE COMMITTEE AND I THINK
YOU'RE OR SUPPORTERS AS WELL FOR
SITTING DOWN WITH ME. I STILL
DIES DO HAVE CONCERNS AND I KNOW
THAT YOU'LL CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH LOCALS AND CONTINUE TO
WORK- TO ADDRESS THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING WHICH I THINK IS
BEEN BROUGHT UP WHICH IS SAFETY
CONCERNS NO FOR THE COMMUNITIES.
SHOULD THEY COME UP OUT OF THIS
YOU KNOW IN THEIR OWN BACKYARD.
BUT- WILL HAVE TO COULD YOU JUST
SING THAT LOOK FOR THAT AND YOU
KNOW THE AS IS ONGOING
CONVERSATION OF ZERO EMISSION
FUTURE WHAT THIS WHAT THIS LOOKS
LIKE- I KNOW- WE'VE GOT A LOT TO
DISCUSS AS IT PERTAINS TO THESE
YOU KNOW WHETHER IT'S BATTERY
ELECTRIC OR LIGHT DUTY. HYDROGEN
I THINK. I'M NEED TO ENSURE THAT
PROVIDING OPPORTUNITIES FOR ALL
OF THEM AND SEEING WHO CAN GET
TO THE TO THE- TO THE I GUESS
THE FINISH LINE FASTEST BUT MOST
IMPORTANTLY WITH HEALTH AND
SAFETY FIRST AND ENSURING THAT
WERE AND REDUCING EMISSIONS
ESPECIALLY FOR THESE COMMUNITIES
THAT NEED IT THE MOST SO WITH
THAT WILL ENTERTAIN A MOTION ON
SB TWELVE NINETY ONE. SENATOR
CORTESE- MISTER CHIEF CONSULTANT
WILL CALL THE ROLL AND WILL ASK
MISTER- ARE TO LET IT TO ALSO-
CLOSE PLEASE. REFER CLOSING IN
YES MEDICARE AND BY THE WAY THE-
A RESOURCE BOARD SAYS THAT-
HYDROGEN FUEL STATIONS ARE 92%
RENEWABLE. BUT WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT- WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO
HERE A MANAGING A TREASURE CHEST
OF ENERGY AND WE HAVE TO USE
THAT AND OPEN THAT TREASURE
CHEST TO ALLOW EVERYTHING FOR
THE FUTURE WE JUST CAN'T GO
ELECTRIC WE JUST CAN'T GO ONE
WE'VE GOT INCLUDED ALL. IN RIGHT
NOW REMEMBER WHAT I'D MENTION
EACH CITY HAS THE OPPORTUNITY TO
INVESTIGATE THAT MAKE SURE THAT
EVERYTHING THAT THEY DO IT'S
SAFE IT'S PROPER IT'S WITH. SIDE
LINES OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
AND- YES INDEED WE HAVE FORTY TO
FIFTY- FUELING STATIONS WE'RE
LOOKING FOR A HUNDRED WE'RE
LOOKING FOR GOD ALMIGHTY A
THOUSAND WHATEVER IT'S GOING TO
TAKE. TO GIVE THE GENERAL PUBLIC
THE OPTION TO GO WITH ELECTRIC
VEHICLES FUEL CELL ELECTRIC
BATTERY VEHICLES BUT WHATEVER IT
IS WE'VE GOT INCLUDED ALL AND WE
HEARD THAT- HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES-
THEY REALLY THRIVE WELL. WITH
YOURSELF- HYDROGEN BATTERIES
CHAU FROM THE PORCH OF LONG
BEACH YOU'RE SICK WE KNOW THAT
IF WE INCORPORATE FUEL CELL A
HYBRID BATTERIES THAT'S GONNA
ALL ALSO OPEN THE DOOR FOR- ZERO
ADMISSIONS AND SO ON. SO WITH
ISSUE WITH. THIS PARTICULAR BILL
IS TO STREAMLINE THE OPPORTUNE
TO GIVE SO. SELF TO. ALLOW NEW
ERA INFRASTRUCTURE AND THAT TOO
IT IS SO WITH THAT I URGE YOUR
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER
ARCHULETA I'M WE HAVE A AGAIN
THE MOTION BY SENATOR CORTESE
MISTER CHIEF CONSULTANT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS DUE
PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SENATORS GONZALEZ HI GONZALEZ I
BATES. ALAN ARCHULETA ARCHULETA
I BAKER. CORTESE CORTESE I. DALI
DOT DOT AYE LIMÓN MON I MCGUIRE
MELENDEZ MEN NEWMAN. RUBIO RUBIO
HIGH SKINNER WHY CASKEY WILK.
SIX ZERO. THE LONG CALL THANK
YOU SO MUCH SENATOR TO LET UP SO
NOW WE'LL MOVE ON TO- FILE ITEM
MOVE UP TO FILE ITEM FIFTEEN BY
SEN THE MOM THAT IS S. B. TWELVE
THIRTY. THANK YOU KAREN
SENATORS. SB TWELVE THIRTY WILL
STREAMLINE THE VARIOUS PROGRAMS
CALIFORNIA HAS TO INCENTIVIZE
CONSUMERS TO SWITCH TO LOWER
EMISSION VEHICLES WHILE MAKING
THEM MORE ACCESSIBLE TO
CONSUMERS. SPECIFICALLY THIS
BILL WOULD ALLOW PEOPLE FROM
ACROSS THE STATE TO PARTICIPATE
IN THE CLEAN CARS FOR ALL
PROGRAM. REQUIRES CARP TO CREATE
A SINGLE UNIFIED APPLICATION AND
EDUCATION PORTAL. AND OPENS UP
MORE OF THESE PROGRAMS TO
ALTERNATIVE TRANSPORTATION LIKE
E. BIKES OR PUBLIC TRANSIT. IF
THAT WORKS BETTE FOR THE
CONSUMER. IT DEFINITELY THERE
CAN ALSO BE A LONG WAITING
PERIOD BETWEEN A PERSON BUT
BETWEEN THE TIME A PERSON
APPLIES TO ONE OF THESE PROGRAMS
AND WHEN THEY RECEIVE THE
INCENTIVE. UNFORTUNATELY MANY
PEOPLE CANNOT AFFORD. MONTHS NEW
VEHICLE AND WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THIS PROCESS IS NOT A BIG.
GETTING ELECTRIC VEHICLE. WANT
TO MAKE IS PROGRAMS. SAYS TO
LOOK HELLO. I'M NOT. GETTING TO
BE ABLE TO REQUIRE FOR ANY OF
THE- JUST MAKING EASIER FOR
PEOPLE TO ACCESS AND USE. AT
TODAY WITH US WE HAVE BENJAMIN I
KERR THE DIRECTOR OF LET'S GO.
LET'S GREEN CALIFORNIA AND-
CAMILLE TRAVIS. MILLER TRAVIS
FROM THE EGGS THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE DOLLARS WHAT THE
FOUNDATION SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL. THANK YOU SENATOR
LIMON WE HAVE BENJAMIN I COURTS
ON THE COASTLINE FROM LET'S
GREEN CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH YOU'RE GONZALEZ MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS
BENJAMIN I KERR I'M THE DIRECTOR
OF FOR AMERICANS TO DUPLICATE
CALIFORNIA INITIATIVE. WORK CRAP
THE SPONSORS MESTI TWELVE
THIRTY. FIRST ONE EXPRESS OUR
GRATITUDE. CENTER LIMÓN FOR
OFFERING THIS BILL INTO THIS
COMMITTEE FOR YOUR HARD. WORK ON
TRANSPORTATION ISSUES YOU KNOW
EMISSIONS FROM CARS AND TRUCKS.
AFTER DECADES MORNING
CALIFORNIA'S EFFORTS. WITHIN
SAFE AND HEALTHY AIR QUALITY.
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS OUR
ORGANIZATION HAS CONDUCTED
OUTREACH AND EDUCATION. IN LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES TO HELP
INDIVIDUALS. GET INTO CLEAN CARS
. IN THIS WORK WE LEARNED THAT
WHAT CALIFORNIA HAS STRONG. TO
SUPPORT THEIR OWN MISSION BE.
NEWS PER HAVE DONE A LOT OF THE-
INSTEAD PLAN IT IS UNFORTUNATE
DIFFICULT TO NAVIGATE. THERE ARE
MYRIAD PROGRAMS EACH WITH ITS
OWN APPLICATION IN ITS OWN TIME
FOR APPROVAL AND USE. IN
PRACTICE THESE PROGRAMS DON'T
MEET THE NEEDS OF OUR RESIDENTS
BECAUSE A YOU DON'T HAVE THE
EXPENDABLE INCOME TO BUY. NOW
RECEIVE A REBATE LATER AND BE
THEY TEND TO DRIVE YOUR CURRENT
VEHICLE UNTIL IT BREAKS DOWN
WHICH MANS WAITING PERIODS ARE
A PROBLEM BECAUSE WHEN THEY NEED
A NEW VEHICLE. THAT NEEDED
URGENT BY SIMPLIFYING AND
STREAMLINING ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLE INCENTIVES UNDER A ONE
STOP SHOP BUT MAKING THOSE FUNDS
AVAILABLE AT POINT OF SALE. SB
THIRTY GAMES TO ENSURE THESE
PROGRAMS. THAT ARE SERVICE WHO.
WE FOUND A BLACK ACTOR TO
PUBLIC. IN DISADVANTAGED. CREATE
THAT. BARRIER WITH OPTION. AT
THE DISCO A LOCKET THAT.
INFRASTRUCTURE BUILD OUT BLACK
HI THE MAN THIS DYNAMIC BEFORE.
THE SECOND PART OF SB TWELVE
THIRTY ABOUT THE TEMPLATE WHICH
CURRENTLY. AIMS TO ACCELERATE
THE BUILD OUT OF CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE. AND ENSURE THAT
THAT INVESTMENT EQUITABLE AND
SUSTAINABLE. CONCLUSION SB
TWELVE THIRTY CAN HELP ENSURE IS
WE PURSUE OUR ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES. WORKING FAMILIES AND
FROM MY COMMUNITIES FOR FRONT OF
THAT TRANSITION. I BEING ABLE TO
AVAIL THEMSELVES THE STATE
FINANCE SUPPORT. ISSUE ONLY
COMBINED WITH THE WORKFORCE
STANDARDS ALREADY IN PLACE.
ASSEMBLY DEFEAT FORTY ONE CAN
CREATE GOOD PAYING JOBS. AND
GROWTH SKILLED AND TRAINED
WORKFORCE CALIFORNIA WILL NEED
WELL INTO THE FUTURE. I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AND I BONUS
TO TWELVE THIRTY AND I THINK
THIS. COMMITTEE FOR YOUR TIME
AND CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU
MISTER I. AYE NEXT ONE MOVE ON
TO KAMALA CHAVEZ DIVORCE THE
FOUNDING. GOOD AFTERNOON THAT
THE LETTER FOR FUNDING.
DIFFICULT THE THEIR SENATE BILL
TWELVE THIRTY THAT'S A LOT
DIFFERENT THE FOUNDATION IS A
FINTECH PURCELL'S AND ACTIVELY
WORKED THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA'S
CENTRAL VALLEY. NOT A SINGLE ONE
OF THE EIGHT COUNTIES IN THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY CURRENTLY HAVE
THREE LEVELS OF OZONE AND FUND
BUDGET ARTICULATE. THIS IS
ACCORDING TO MONITORING DONE BY
THE CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES
BOARD THESE TOXIC AIR POLLUTANTS
ARE PRODUCED FROM THE TAIL PIPE.
OF TWENTY NINE MILLION CARTONS.
IN OUR STATE. THE TORREY ILLNESS
DEVELOPMENT AND THEN HEALTH
ISSUES HARPER AND SHORTEN MY AND
- IT IS EXTREMELY. THAT ONE IN
SIX CHILDREN AND THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY HAVE AT. THE HIGHEST
LEVEL IN THE STATE THIS IS AN
INTERGENERATIONAL INJUSTICE
SUFFERED PREDOMINATELY BY LOW
INCOME AND COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
CELEBRATING CLEAN CAR CHEN AND
HISTORICALLY OVERLOOKED AREAS
WILL HAVE TREMENDOUS IMPACT
ACCORDING TO THE AMERICAN LUNG
ASSOCIATION A RAPID CLEAN CAR
TRANSITION WHAT PREVENT MORE
THAN FIFTEEN THOUSAND PREMATURE
DEATHS IN CALIFORNIA OVER THE
COMING DECADE WITH MOST OF THE
BENEFITS GOING TO LOW INCOME AND
HIS. OKAY HOLD ON A MOBILE AND
MAY COSTS ARE STRIVE TO IMPROVE
THE LIFE UNDER THE THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA WE BELIEVE SB TWELVE
THIRTY WILL MEANINGFULLY REDUCED
HEALTH AND ECONOMIC BURDEN ARE
COMMUNITIES EFFICIENTLY AND
EFFECTIVELY AND PUT THE STATE ON
A BETTER PATH MEETING OUR
CLIMATE AND CLEAN AIR GOALS WE
THANK SENATE REALLY MON AND THE
COMMITTEE FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON
THE ISSUE. OF WHETHER YES WE
CAN. THANK YOU MISS CHÁVEZ- NOW
WE WILL MOVE TO THE GALLERY FOR
ANYONE ELSE WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY AND SUPPORTIVE SB TWELVE
THIRTY PLEASE. OKAY SEE NONE A
TELECONFERENCE START COME RIGHT
COME RIGHT UP. HE AIN'T KILLED
VANDAM CHAIR A START AT A
MODERATOR I'M BORED AND I JUST
GO BACK TO THE GALLERY HERE WE
HAVE A FEW FOLKS THAT WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SEATTLE I'M SORRY
OTHER MAJOR PUBLIC. SO ACT TERRA
I'M LNDA HUTCHINS KNOWLES
LACTARIUS AND WE SUPPORT THE
INTENT TO THIS BILL WE VERY MUCH
ARE IN FAVOR OF EVEY EQUITY- WE
HAVE SOME IDEAS FOR MAKING IT
EVEN MORE EQUITABLE SO WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH AUTHORED
THE SPONSORSTO ADDRESS THEM.
PERSONALLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
WITH AMENDMENTS AND WE
APPRECIATE VERY MUCH THE INTENT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ANYONE
ELSE LIKE TO COME AT. FORWARD TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB TWELVE
THIRTY. RIGHT C. NINE SO WE'LL
GO BACK TO THE TELECONFERENCE
LINE MODERATOR FOR ANYONE ELSE
WHO'D LIKE TO SUPPORT SB TWELVE
THIRTY PLEASE. THINK OF IT
CHARACTERS LIKE THE SUPPORT SB
TWELVE THIRTY THREE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. FOR A
LINE TO SEVENTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ONE TO THIRTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YES SB MAKING ON
BEHALF OF CLIMATE REALITY
PROJECT SILICON VALLEY AS WELL
AS OTHERS FIND ACTION FOR THE
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT WE
THANK THE AUTHOR. THANK YOU NINE
ONE SEVENTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WHAT THE LAW MEANS
GRANTED THE ELDORADO. HI FOR
YOUR READING- ONE FIVE THE-
SERVER JUST TAKE RANDOM NAME IN
OREGON IT'LL TELL ME AT THIS
HAS. MANY HAVE TO WORK IN THE
ORDER AND HANDLED AREA AND THAT
IT'S A LONG DRIVE THE WE NEED
THAT MUCH INFRASTRUCTURE
COLLECTED PEOPLE THIS WEEK AND
GET ESPECIALLY ACCESS SERVER
MAKING NAME AN ORGANIZATION AT
THIS TIME OF OFTEN WANT TO MAKE
SURE WE'RE BEING FAIR. MODERATOR
CAN WE ENSURE THE NAME AN
ORGANIZATION ON THE PORTAFERRY
HARD TO LIVE. I HAD. THE
FOURTEENTH ZERO EIGHT HOW A
CRUISE PLAN ACTION THEY- OF
THIRTEEN HUNDRED AND WE ARE
STRONG SUPPORT OF BILL BOTH THE
- THING YOU AND I HOPE FOR
CUTTING OFF WE JUST WANT TO SURE
BEING FAIR WE EVERYONE TESTA
HERE IN PORTLAND B. TWELVE
THIRTY PLEASE WE'RE JUST TAKING
NAME AN ORGANIZATION ON THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE AND WE DO
HAVE ONE OTHER FOLKS A PERSON
THAT WOULD. LIKE TO COME UP-
HERE IN THE GALLERY SO WE'LL
TAKE YOU. WANT TO GO BACK TO THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE PLEASE.
CALIFORNIA INDIVISIBLE STATE
STRONG THE- CLIMATE JUSTICE
TEAM. ALSO THE INDIVISIBLE GREEN
TEAM AND SACRAMENTO INDIVISIBLE
AND SEGMENTAL ELECTRIC VEHICLE
ASSOCIATION AND WE'RE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK YOU.
OKAY MODERATOR TO HAVE ANYONE
ELSE QUEUED UP IN SUPPORT OF S.
B. TWELVE THIRTY AT THIS TIME.
YES LINE ONE TWENTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THIS IS ADRIAN COOPER
FROM INDIVISIBLE TO FOR. IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE STOCK.
THANK YOU RYAN ONE FORTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WHEN FORTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. BUT A LINE TO
EIGHTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS
IS THE NETWORK I REPRESENTING AT
BOTH FINANCE WELL WE ARE IN VERY
FROM WORK THE INTENT. THAT IS
THE FIRST INCLUDING GAS I THINK
THINK THAT. MEANT THE WORK IN.
THANK YOU LINE WHY OH TWO GO
AHEAD. OKAY THE BILL JR BOB. OFF
THE ROAD FOR A MOMENT MORE AT
ALL ALSO. RIGHT ARKIN IS THE
WORK- THE BILL AMENDS. THANK YOU
AT LINE TWO SEVENTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS ASSEMBLY
FINGERS I'M CALLING FROM THE
EARTH YES SO WHAT THE SENATE
BILL FIVE THIRTY ON BEHALF OF
BOOKS AND THAT POLLUTION MONEY
FOR THE FAMILY THE BILL AND HE
COLLECTED THAT. THANK YOU LINE
TO TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS A VERY AND YOU
CAN ON BEHALF OF INDIVISIBLE
CALIFORNIA. WE ARE PART OF FIND
IT WILL BRING IN ON OR BEFORE
THE BIG BALL AT THE PROPERTY HAS
BEEN VOTED THE FIRING FELL BY
INDIVISIBLE MEMBERS REPRESENT.
EIGHTY SEVEN WITH A. FIVE EIGHT.
YEAH I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU TO
VOTE I FIND. AT THE OF THE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU
MIND TO SET EIGHT PLEASE AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS LESLIE READ
HARASSMENT- I'M CALLING FROM
URGE A YES VOTE IN SUPPORT THE
SENATE BILL ONE THREE THREE ZERO
ON BEHALF OF A HUNTER VALLEY
PRIDE THE CENTER FOR BIOLOGICAL
DIVERSITY AND PLANET ANSWER.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU LINE Q.
EIGHTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU EIGHTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. IT WILL PUT A LINK TO
SEVENTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ARE THERE CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES
WE CAN HEAR YOU YES. OKAY HI
THERE MY NAME IS THE BEST A LIST
HERE- I AM CALLING ON BEHALF OF
. THREE FIFTY THOUGHT I'M
VALLEY. FROM SUPPORT FOR S. B.
ALL THIRTY. THANK YOU AND I'M
SURE THERE ARE NO FURTHER LINES
IN SUPPORT. SAFETY THANK YOU
MODERATOR- SO WE'LL TAKE T NOW
TO OPPOSITION ANYONE. HAVE ANY
REGISTERED OPPOSITION BUT ANYONE
IN THE GALLERY WHO WOULD LIKE TO
OPPOSE SB TWELVE THIRTY AT THIS
TIME. THIS IS GUY WHOLE
FINANCIAL INTERVIEW BECAUSE OF
SITUATION WE- APPRECIATE AND WE
RECOGNIZE THE TREMENDOUS VALUE
THAT THIS BILL MAY PROVIDE AND-
SUPPORT. PORTAL BUT WE HAVE TO
OPPOSE IT UNTIL WE WORK OUT A
FEW DETAILS WITH THE AUTHORS AND
AFTER WHICH POINT WE HOPE THEN
WE WILL. COME OUT AND SUPPORTED
FOR OF PASSING THANK YOU THANK
YOU SIR. ANYONE ELSE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO- REGISTER OPPOSITION TO
SB TWELVE THIRTY SEE NON
MODERATOR TO HAVE ANYONE ON THE
LINE WHO WOULD LIKE TO OPPOSE SB
TWELVE THIRTY AT THIS TIME. HMM
CHAIR IF YOU'D LIKE TO OPPOSE SB
UL THIRTY AT THIS TIME PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. WE'LL GO TO
LINE TWO SEVENTY ONE BEFOREHAND. THANK YOU SEVENTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. UNDERLINED OKAY
YEAH. YEAH THIS IS THE BOOK FOR
PARTY LINE VOTE I DID SOME
RIDICULOUS AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT OFFICE PEOPLE THIRTY.
THANK YOU FOR LINE. ONE THIRTY
FOUR. THE FIRST. AREA THE
COOLEST PART OF. THANK YOU.
WE'VE GOT SUPPORT FOR ANYONE IN
THE QUEUE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
OPPOSE SB TWELVE THIRTY AT THIS
TIME. IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
OPPOSE S. B. TWELVE THIRTY EAST
PRESS ONE THEN FEAR. THERE ARE
NO LINES IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
CONTINUE MEDICARE. THANK YOU SO
I'VE TAKEN SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION
AT THIS TIME WE'LL TAKE IT BACK
TO THE DICE FOR ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS BY MEMBERS. THE NINE
CAN WE ENTERTAIN A MOTION FOR SB
TWELVE THIRTY. THANK YOU SENATOR
RUBIO AND SENATOR LIMÓN WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU
WE'VE GOT A MOTION BY SENATOR
RUBIO MISTER CHIEF CONSULTANT
CAN YOU PLEASE CALL. THE MOTION
IS DUE PASSES AMENDED AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. SENDERS
GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ I BATES. ALAN
ARCHULETA ARCHULETA II BAKER
CORTESE CORTESE II DOLLY DOT
DODD AYE LAMONT LIMÓN HAI
MCGUIRE MELENDEZ. MAN NEWMAN
NEWMAN AYE RUBIO RUBIO AYE
SKINNER WHAT KASKY WELCOME.
SEVEN ZERO. SEVEN ZERO LEAVE THE
BILL ON CALL THANK YOU SENATOR
LIMÓN AND OUR LAST- ITEM UP ON
FILE ITEM EIGHTEEN SB THIRTEEN
TWENTY NINE BY SENATOR NEWMAN
WELCOME SOME SENATOR NEWMAN.
REVENUE MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS AS
YOU CAN SEE I'VE GOT A BAD BACK
AND I'M WALKING SLOWLY AS
POSSIBLE CORNERS MUCH SYMPATHY
AS POSSIBLE. HOPEFULLY IT WORKED
. THERE YOU GO UGH UGH I'LL DO
IT AGAIN IF ANYBODY WANTS TO DO
. I JUST THOUGHT I JUST HAD A
VERY COOL WHAT YES- MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS- I AM HERE BEFORE
YOU DID ADVOCATE ON BEHALF OF S.
B. THIRTEEN TWENTY NINE. A WHICH
AS AMENDED IN SENATE ENERGY WILL
PROVIDE FUNDING THROUGH THE
CLEAN TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM TO
EXPEDITE. THE BUILD OUT OF A
STATE WIDE PUBLICLY AVAILABLE IN
EQUITY FOCUSED FUEL CELL
ELECTRIC VEHICLE HYGIENE FUELING
NETWORK FOR CALIFORNIA. C. E. C.
FUNDING WOULD BE BASED ON
ASSESSMENT OF INFRASTRUCTURE
NEED IS IDENTIFIED. FOURNIR
RESOURCE. WITH THE OVERALL GOAL
OF REACHING SELF SUFFICIENCY AS
DEFINED BY COURT AT THE EARLIEST
POSSIBLE DATE. AS YOU ARE WELL
AWARE CALIFORNIA HAS NOW FULLY
COMMITTED TO THE AMBITIOUS GOAL
OF MOVING BEYOND GASOLINE
POWERED AUTOMOBILES BY THE YEAR
TWENTY THIRTY FIVE. RESEARCH ON
BY ORGANIZATIONS SUCH AS THE AIR
RESOURCE BOARD AND THE- IN CASE
THAT. CALIFORNIA'S CURRENTLY
MORE THAN THIRTY MILLION
VEHICLES AT A PACE SUFFICIENT TO
MEET THE STATE'S TWENTY THIRTY
FIVE GOALS RELYING EXCLUSIVELY
ON BATTERY ELECTRIC VEHICLES
ALONE WILL NOT BE ENOUGH TO GET
US THERE WHILE BATTERY ELECTRIC
CARS ARE WONDERFUL AND STEADILY
GAINING IN BOTH PROMISE AND
MARKET SHARE THEY ARE
UNFORTUNATELY NOT NECESSARILY
GOOD FOR EVERYONE- NOR APPEALING
TO EVERYBODY PARTICULAR
APARTMENT WHILE SHE MAY NOT HAVE
ACCESS TO CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE- THOSE ARE SOME
OF THE RULES THAT THAT WE HAVE
ADDRESS TODAY. THAT COMMUTERS
DRIVE LONG DISTANCES ARE
DELIVERY DRIVERS ARE RIGHT YOUR
WORKERS WHO DON'T HAVE TIME TO
LOOK FOR A BATTERY TO REACH.
CORROBORATING EVIDENCE A SURVEY
CONDUCTED LAST YEAR BY THE UC
DAVIS INSTITUTE OF
TRANSPORTATION. FOUND THAT
ROUGHLY A FIFTH OF THE FIFTH OF
OWNERS OF BATTERY ELECTRIC
VEHICLES DECIDE TO SWITCH BACK.
TO GASOLINE POWERED CAR ENGINES.
WHEN BUYING THEIR NEXT COURT FOR
A VARIETY OF REASONS. IF IT'S
TRUE THEN THAT WE WON'T BE ABLE
TO MEET EITHER OUR INTERIM OR
ULTIMATE GOALS AROUND ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLE ADOPTION
THROUGH BATTERY ELECTRIC
VEHICLES ALONE. WE NEED TO
CONSIDER HOW BEST TO ENABLE THE
GROWTH AND DEVELOPMENT OF THE
ONLY OTHER COMMERCIALLY
AVAILABLE ZERO EMISSIONS
AUTOMOBILE TECHNOLOGY. THE
HYDROGEN FUEL CELL ELECTRIC
VEHICLE OR FCEV PLATFORM. AS A
MATTER OF POLICY CALIFORNIA
SUPPORT FOR INVESTMENTS IN ZERO
EMISSIONS VEHICLE INFRASTRUCTURE
SUPPOSED TO BE NEUTRAL. AND NOT
ADOPT ANYONE PREFERRED
ALTERNATIVE FUEL OR TECHNOLOGY.
POLICY HOWEVER IS NOT ALWAYS
FULLY TRANSLATED INTO PRACTICE
TO DATE ESPECIALLY IN RECENT
YEARS. PUBLIC INVESTMENTS ARE
PRIORITIZED THE BUILD OUT OF
BATTERY ELECTRIC VEHICLE
CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE. TO THE
DETRIMENT OF HYDROGEN FUELING
INFRASTRUCTURE WHICH IS NOT
ENJOYED A CORRESPONDENT LEVEL OF
SUPPORT. TO THAT POINT
CALIFORNIA'S URRENTLY
ALLOCATING LESS THAN 5% OF TOTAL
FUELING INFRASTRUCTURE SPENDING.
TOWARD THE BUILD OUT OF THE PLAN
STATEWIDE HYDROGEN FUELING
STATION NETWORK- PASSENGER
VEHICLES AND MEDIUM. DUTY TRUCKS
THE ABSENCE OF A COMPLETE
SUFFICIENTLY DISTRIBUTED
STATEWIDE HYDROGEN FUEL WOULD
FUELING NETWORK REPRESENTS A
PRIMARY BARRIER TO THE MARKET
VIABILITY AND WIDESPREAD
CONSUMER ACCEPTANCE. OF A VERY
PROMISING CLASS OF ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES IT ALSO SENDS A
POWERFUL NEGATIVE SIGNAL. TO
AUTOMAKERS CURRENTLY OFFERING
ARE CONSIDERING OFFERING NON
POLLUTING ZERO CARBON FUEL
EFFICIENT AND AFFORDABLE FCEV IN
THE CALIFORNIA AUTOMOBILE
MARKET. FURTHER HI JUNE
INFRASTRUCTURE FUNDING IS
PARTICULAR SMART IN FISCAL
FISCALLY RESPONSIBLE RIGHT NOW
AS MANY OF YOU ARE AWARE
CALIFORNIA WILL BE SUBMITTING A
BID FOR ONE OF THE UP TO FOR
HYGIENE HOW GRANTS. OUT OF AN
EIGHT BILLION DOLLAR ALLOCATION
WITHIN THE RECENTLY PASSED
FEDERAL INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENT AND JOBS ACT NOT ONLY
ARE EARLY INVESTMENTS IN
CALIFORNIA'S NETWORK OF LIGHT
DUTY HARJIT STATIONS ONE OF OUR
BEST SELLING POINTS FOR OUR
BIDS. THE INVESTMENTS WE ARE
SEEKING TODAY WILL COUNT AS
MATCH FUNDS FOR ANY FEDERAL
HYDROGEN HUB WARD. FURTHER FUNNY
TO EXPEDITE HODGES STATION BILL
THAT WILL ENSURE THAT HYDROGEN
FUELING STATIONS ARE WITHIN A
USEFUL RADIUS OF JUST. HOME B.
E. V. SENSE. TO COMMUTE
DISTANCES WORK PATTERNS HOUSING
DENSITY OR LACK OF CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE SB THIRTEEN
TWENTY NINE WILL ENSURE THAT
HYDROGEN AND ITS C. E. THESE ARE
PART. OF CALIFORNIA'S CLIMATE
SOLUTIONS THEREBY PLACING OUR
CLEAN ENERGY GOALS SOUNDLY
WITHIN REACH WITH THE PASSAGE OF
SB THIRTEEN TWENTY NINE. THE
STATE WILL BE ALLOCATING
APPROPRIATE FUNDING TO
ACCELERATE THE BUILD OUT. OF A
COMPREHENSIVE STATEWIDE HARSH
AND FUELING NETWORK BEYOND TWO
HUNDRED STATIONS MOVING TOWARD A
PUBLICLY AVAILABLE FUELING
NETWORK THAT MEETS THE SELF
SUFFICIENTLY THRESH. SELF
SUFFICIENCY THRESHOLD AS LAID
OUT IN THE AIR RESOURCE BOARD'S
TWENTY EIGHTEEN AB EIGHT REPORT.
HYDROGEN IS NOT ONLY A VIABLE
AND ULTIMATELY PROMISING FUEL
OPTION FOR ZERO EMISSIONS
VEHICLES. IT'S A CRITICAL
COMPONENT OF ANY REALISTIC AND
EFFECTIVE PLAN THAT WILL ENABLE
CALIFORNIA. TO MEET ITS OVERALL
ZERO EMISSIONS GOALS IMPORTANTLY
SB THIRTEEN TWENTY NINE ALSO
PROVIDES AT LEAST 60% OF THE
FUNDING SHALL BE USED FOR
PROJECTS. THAT COMPLETELY OR
PARTIALLY BENEFIT DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES. AS THE COMMITTEE'S
RECOMMENDATION SOMERCOTES AND
FIRMLY COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH
THE CHAIR AND OTHERS TO FIND THE
BEST A POSSIBLE APPROACH. AND
REVENUE SOURCES FOR THIS
CRITICAL ZERO EMISSION
TRANSPORTATION INITIATIVE FOR
THESE REASONS I HOPE SUPPORT
THE- HEY I RESPECTFULLY ASKING.
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. DIVIDE OUR
TRIP. IN THE EXACT ADDRESS OF
THE CALIFORNIA HOUSING COALITION
AND BY PHONE TO JACK BRAUER THE
DIRECTOR OF THE NATIONAL FUEL
CELL RESEARCH CENTER AT UC
IRVINE. THANK YOU SENATOR NEWMAN
I JUST WANT TO CLARIFY THAT- YOU
TO TAKE THE AMENDMENTS ADDED A
REQUIREMENT TO ADD EASY FUNDING
BASED ON NEED AS WELL THAT IS
CORRECT MA'AM BATES THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I APPRECIATE YOUR-
COMMENTS- WILL START WITH. TO
RESET COOK- WHO'S HERE IN THE
GALLERY. RIGHT NOW- FROM THE
HYDROGEN CALIFORNIA HYDROGEN
COALITION THANK YOU CHAIR SB
THIRTEEN TWENTY NINE IS INTENDED
TO RIGHT A WRONG IN THE
FINANCING DISCREPANCIES BETWEEN
CHARGING AND HYDROGEN FUELING
INFRASTRUCTURE. OR ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES ARE CLEAR BUT EXECUTING
ON THESE GOALS BY GETTING
DRIVERS TO MAKE THE SWITCH IS
OUR COLLECTIVE CHALLENGE. AS
NOTED BY DR BROWER WHO'S GOING
TO TESTIFY NEXT. FUEL CELL
ELECTRIC VEHICLES BUILT BY OUR
TOP AUTO MANUFACTURERS TOYOTA
HONDA AND HYUNDAI AMONG OTHERS
ARE WELL SUITED TO MEET THE
NEEDS OF THOSE LIVING IN MULTI
FAMILY DWELLINGS. WITHOUT
GARAGES AND PREDICTABLE ACCESS
TO CHARGING AND ARE SUPER
COMMUTERS THAT HAVE REACHED WELL
OVER HALF A MILLION INSIDE IN
CALIFORNIA ALONE. DESPITE THESE
ADVANTAGES LESS THAN THREE POINT
7% OF THE SIX POINT EIGHT
BILLION DOLLARS. IN STATE
FUNDING BEING DIRECTED TOWARDS
ZERO EMISSION INFRASTRUCTURE IS
GOING TOWARD HYDROGEN. I JUST.
HEARD THAT THE PER. BOSS OF
HYDROGEN INFRASTRUCTURE OUR
COMPATIBLE TO CHARGING IN ONE OF
THE UNIQUE THINGS ABOUT HYDROGEN
AS THAT WE ARE ON A PATHWAY TO
SELF SUFFICIENCY. THERE
RESOURCES BOARD FOUND WITH AN
ADDITIONAL THREE HUNDRED MILLION
WE WOULD HAVE A FULLY
FUNCTIONING LIGHT DUTY AND
MEDIUM DUTY. HYDROGEN FUELING
NETWORK SO THIS IS KIND OF AN
EXAMPLE OF AN EMERGING GREEN
TECHNOLOGY THAT IS ABLE TO STAND
ON ITS OWN AND NO LONGER NEED
SUBSIDY. SOMETHING THAT WE HAVE
YET TO FIND WITH A LOT OF OUR
OTHER COMPUTING AND TECHNOLOGY
SO SOMETHING WE'RE VERY EXCITED
OF MARIE VERY PROUD OF. I'M
REALLY WANT TO THANK THE SENATOR
FOR HIS SUPPORT AND HIS
LEADERSHIP ON THIS I'VE YOU KNOW
THIRTEEN TWENTY NINE WILL ENSURE
EVERYONE IN CALIFORNIA. HAS THE
ACCESS AND OPPORTUNITY TO
TRANSITION IT WAS YOUR MISSION
VEHICLE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISS COOK NOW WILL- KICK IT TO
THE TELECONFERENCE LINE MISTER
JACK BRAUER NATIONAL FUEL CELL
RESEARCH CENTER PLEASE. HI JACK
BAUER HERE THANK YOU CARE
GONZALEZ AN HONORABLE MEMBERS OF
THE SENATE AND THANK YOU CENTER
NEWMAN FOR LEADING TO. THE- THE
DEVELOPMENT IT'S IMPORTANT
BUDGET LEGISLATION. OR THEIR OWN
MISSION TRANSPORTATION IN
CALIFORNIA. I AM A PROFESSOR OF
MECHANICAL AND AEROSPACE
ENGINEERING HERE AT UC IRVINE
AND THAT OUR ANALYSES. OF ZERO
EMISSIONS TRANSPORTATION AND THE
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDED TO SUPPORT
SUCH. SHOWS THAT WE WILL NEED TO
INVEST IN BOTH. ELECTRIC
VEHICLES STARTING IN IN HYDROGEN
FUELING INFRASTRUCTURE IN THE
STATE. AS WE HAVE IN THE PAST.
AND WHILE HYDROGEN HAS DISTINCT
ADVANTAGES OVER BATTERY
ESPECIALLY IN HEAVY DUTY
APPLICATIONS. YOU DO IT PASSED
THE FUELING LONG RANGE OF HEAVY
PAYLOAD CAPABILITY. HYDROGEN
WILL ALSO PLAY AN IMPORTANT ROLE
IN REDUCING TO ZERO EMISSIONS IN
THE LIKE THE ACTOR. MOST
IMPORTANTLY. DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES THAT WE TALK ABOUT
ALMOST ALL. ACTION HERE. EARLY
LIMON RENTAL PROPERTY AND NOT
EASILY GARNER AT. ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES OUT HYDROGEN FUELING
INFRASTRUCTURE WHICH SMALL
NUMBERS OF FUELING STATIONS IN
DENSE URBAN ENVIRONMENT AND NEAR
RENTAL PROPERTIES AND- THOUSANDS
OF RENTAL PROPERTIES WHEN ACT
THE FEDERAL. CHARGING AT THE
MOMENT. I PROJECT WILL ALSO BE
REQUIRED TO SERVE A PORTION OF
THE LIGHT DUTY VEHICLE THROUGH
OUT THE STATE WHEN THE OPTION OF
THAT BECOME VERY LARGE THAT IS.
AT WORK IS A HUNDRED PERCENT.
BECAUSE NEIGHBORHOOD ELECTRIC
CIRCUIT. THROUGHOUT THE STATE
CAN HANDLE THEM AND INSPIRATION
HERE IF YOU'RE SIXTY PERCENT.
BUT CANNOT ACCOMMODATE ENTIRE
NEIGHBORHOODS THAT STARTING
WITHOUT A VERY LARGE INVESTMENT
. FINALLY THERE IS SYNERGY
BETWEEN THE FUELING OF MEDIUM
AND HEAVY DUTY CREDIT
APPLICATION AND LIKE THE FEELING
WHICH WHEN COMBINED HAVE THE
GREATEST POTENTIAL TO REDUCE THE
COST OF HYDROGEN FOR CONSUMER. I
WANT TO END WITH THIS STATEMENT
WE MUST URGENTLY ENABLE THAT
HAVE ADOPTION ESPECIALLY IN
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES WHERE
EXPOSURE TO POLLUTION. IS
LEADING THE BEER AND IRREPARABLE
HEALTH IMPACT. I URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT SB THIRTEEN TWENTY NINE
ESPECIALLY FOR THIS PURPOSE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MR OUR- NOW
WILL- COME BACK TO THE GALLERY
FOR ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB
THIRTEEN TWENTY NINE PLEASE COME
FORWARD. MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
JOHN LINGER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FUELS AND CONVENIENCE
ALLIANCE IN SUPPORT. MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS MAC CRIMMINS ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ABOUT A
CONFERENCE OF OPERATING
ENGINEERS WE UNFORTUNATELY
MISSED A LETTER DEADLINE BUT WE
ARE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
VENTURE MEMBERS MIKE MONICA NOW
WE HAVE THE CALIFORNIA STATE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT. MIX GROWTH
WALKER GROUP HERE BEHALF OF
LINDE PLC IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT OF SB
THIRTEEN TWENTY NINE SEEN NONE
SO WE'LL TAKE IT BACK TO THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE FOR ANYONE
ELSE WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SB THIRTEEN TWENTY
NINE PLEASE. THANK YOU MA'AM.
BYE IN SUPPORT OF SB THIRTEEN
TWENTY NINE HE'S PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE'LL GO TO
LINE ONE FIFTY SEVEN IS FOR HEAD
. YES GOOD AFTERNOON THE-
PROGRAM TO HAVE ACTUALLY THE
SUPPORT. THANK YOU LINE ONE
SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
THINK TANK THERE INTERVIEWING
AND YOU MEMBERS OF THE LABOR
LAWS YOU THINK ON BEHALF OF THE
OTHER COMPANY- BUILD OUT OF THAT
EIGHT FIVE FIVE YOU HAD TO GO TO
REPEALING NETWORK YEAH THIRTY
EIGHT OUR PRODUCTION GOALS. AND
IT WORKED FOR THIRTEEN TWENTY
NINE ENTERS COMMITTEE MEMBERS
SUPPORTED. WELL THANK YOU THANK
YOU. THANK YOUR LINE SICK NINE
GO AHEAD. GOT MICHAEL PARK
REPRESENTING ALMOST TWO DOZEN
WRITERS ACTORS PRODUCERS
DIRECTORS A PROVINCE
ENTERTAINMENT AND VERY STRONG
SUPPORT SB THIRTEEN TWENTY NINE
. THANK YOU LINE ONE OH SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GRAYSON BODY
PAINT REPORTER THE HYBRID
CONSOLE DON'T FEEL AND GRAPPELLI
WE ARE IN FRONT SUPPORTER AT THE
THIRTEEN TWENTY NINE AND YOUR-
EIGHT JULY TWO SEVENTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
SEVENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NINE TWO EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU EIGHTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NINE ONE
TWENTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE ONE TWENTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THERE ARE NO OTHER LINES
IN SUPPORT FOR SD THIRTEEN
TWENTY NINE GO AHEAD AND A
FUTURE THANK YOU MODERATOR SO
WE'LL MOVE TO- ANYBODY WHO WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION WE
DON'T HAVE ANY REGISTERED
OPPOSITION- BUT WE DO HAVE
SOMEONE HERE IN THE GALLERY.
PLEASE COME FORWARD. HI I'M
LINDA HUTCHINS KNOWLES ON BEHALF
OF ACTOR ACTION FOR A HEALTHY
CLIMATE WE ARE STRONGLY OPPOSED
TO SB THIRTEEN TWENTY NINE. WE
URGE ALL OF YOU TO PLEASE
QUESTION THE HYDROGEN HYPE. IT'S
A SOLUTION IN SEARCH OF A
PROBLEM. YES THEY MAY BE ZERO
EMISSIONS AT THE PLACE OF THE
CAR BUT CONSIDER WHERE THE
HYDROGEN IS BEING PRODUCED BY
95% OF IT CURRENTLY IS PRODUCED
BY FOSSIL FUELS YOUR DISPLACING
THE POLLUTION TO FRONTLINE
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. THIS IS AN
EQUITABLE IN THE CLIMATE
INJUSTICE. BATTERY ELECTRIC
VEHICLES ARE MUCH LESS CARBON
INTENSIVE AND FAR MORE EFFICIENT
AS A SOURCE OF LIGHT VEHICLE
POWER. THESE COMPANIES ARE
ATTEMPTING TO GREEN WASH THEIR
HYDROGEN WITHOUT CONSIDERING ITS
CARBON INTENSITY. THAT SHOULD BE
THE SOLE METRIC BY WHICH THE
GREEN CREDENTIALS OF HYDROGEN
ARE JUDGED. SECOND HYDROGEN
NEEDS TO BE STORED AND
TRANSPORTED EITHER AS A HIGH
PRESSURE GAS OR THE CRYOGENIC
LIQUID MAKING IT MUCH MORE
HAZARDOUS TO HANDLE. PLEASE DO
NOT PUT THESE FUELING STATIONS
IN IT POPULATION CENTERS THIS IS
A DISASTER WAITING TO HAPPEN.
BECAUSE HYDROGEN MOLECULES ARE
SO MUCH FOR THE NATURAL GAS
METHANE. THEY ARE NOT
APPROPRIATE FOR HYDROGEN BOTH
THE INFRASTRUCTURE FOR NATURAL
GAS AS I PREFER HATER CHEN SO
DIFFERENT MORE EXPENSIVE AND
MORE THE CLOSEST INFRASTRUCTURE
NEEDED FOR HYDROGEN. AS WE KNOW
CHART. BECAUSE CAN BE CITED
ANYWHERE SAFELY ON THE ELECTRIC
GRID. THEY ARE AN ECONOMICAL
SAFE AND WIDESPREAD DISTRIBUTION
SYSTEM ALREADY EXISTS WEST NO
SUCH NETWORK EXIST FOR HYDROGEN
. WE ARE IN A CLIMATE EMERGENCY
WE DO NOT HAVE TIME FOR
EXPENSIVE DISTRACTIONS LIKE
HYDROGEN TECHNOLOGY. ONLY GREEN
TECHNOLOGY IN HYDROGEN IS TRULY
GREEN AND THAT'S MUCH MORE
EXPENSIVE SO PLEASE TAKE THE
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR
THAT PROPOSED IN THIS AND PUT IT
INSTEAD INTO THE BAD CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE. FOR SUPPORTING
THE COSTS FOR BUILDERS TO PUT.
UP CHARGING INTO MULTI FAMILY
HOUSING. MULTI FAMILY HOUSING
RESIDENTS WANT TO BE ABLE TO
CHARGE AT HOME WHERE IT'S MOST
CONVENIENT MOST SAFE AND MORE
SUPPORTABLE SO PLEASE QUESTION
THE HYDROGEN HYPE. VOTING THIS
OF. THE BOAT THANK THAT MOTHERS
LIKE ME WORK INTERRUPTIONS
PRESSURE WITH THE QUEUE THANK
YOU THANK YOU SO TAKE THAT AS
LEAD OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME
ANYONE ELSE IN THE GALLERY WHO
WOULD LIKE TO OPPOSE S. B. AT.
THIRTEEN TWENTY NINE PLEASE COME
FORWARD. SOME GUY HOLD FINANCIAL
LOGIC ALTHOUGH BERMAN THE
MEASURE ELECTRIC VEHICLE
ASSOCIATION- BELIEVE THAT
THERE'S GREAT OPPORTUNITIES FOR
FUEL CELLS AND HYDROGEN. IN THE
HEAVY DUTY OR MARINE
APPLICATIONS BUT THE THAT- THAT
SHIP HAS SAILED IN TERMS OF THE
A LIGHT DUTY. SO WE OPPOSE THIS.
BILL THANK YOU SIR WE'RE JUST
GONNA TAKE NAME AN ORGANIZATION
AT THIS TIME ANYONE ELSE WOULD
LIKE TO OPPOSE SB THIRTEEN
TWENTY NINE. C. NINE SOLD TAKE
IT BACK TO THE TELECONFERENCE
LINE FOR ANYONE WHO'D LIKE TO
OPPOSE SB THIRTEEN TWENTY NINE
PLEASE. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR IF
YOU OF. OPPOSE SB THIRTEEN
TWENTY NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO WE'LL GO TO LINE TWO EIGHTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD- MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS MIKE CARPENTER- I
THINK I GOT IN THE QUEUE LATE
BUT I'M ACTUALLY. HERE TO
SUPPORT. THIRTEEN TWENTY NINE ON
BEHALF OF TOYOTA THANK YOU.
THANK YOU LINE ONE OH TO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU NAME IS
JERICHO THURMOND TERREL
EXPRESSING OUR STRONG OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL. THANK YOU I'M ONE
SEVENTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
WELL THE DROP IN LOVE LONGER
TWENTY FIVE TRANSIT THEY'LL
DORADO AND I OPPOSE THIS BECAUSE
BROWN'S REAL QASSAM HYDROGEN DO
NOT HOLD UP IN THE SNOW COLD
TEMPERATURES. THANK YOU LINE TWO
EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO HELLO WE'RE JUST TAKING
NAME AN ORGANIZATION FOR
OPPOSITION TO SB THIRTEEN TWENTY
NINE PLEASE. HELLO HELLO CAN YOU
PROVIDE YOUR NAME AND
ORGANIZATION PLEASE. MY MEMBERS
OF PUBLIC INPUT ON THE BALLOT
FOR YA I'M TRYING TO BE ON THE
LINE IN THE CUBAN I LOOK UP YOUR
ACCOUNT I PUT ON THE BOARD OF
THIS BILL OKAY I TRIED BUT.
THAT'S OKAY THANK YOU BYE BYE
ABOUT. WE'LL GO AHEAD AND TAKE
THAT THANK YOU AND WILL AGAIN TO
OPPOSITION FOR SB THIRTEEN
TWENTY NINE PLEASE. THERE ARE NO
THERE'S NO FURTHER LINES IN
OPPOSITION FOR SB THIRTEEN
TWENTY NINE YOU MAY PROCEED.
THANK YOU MODERATOR SO IT'S
CONCLUDED SUPPORT NOT XIN WE'VE
GOT A QUESTION OR COMMENT BY
SENATOR MEN- YEAH. AUTHORED THIS
BILL. ACTUALLY I HAVE A TOYOTA
MIRAI AND I KNOW HOW DIFFICULT
IT IS TO EITHER THE MAIN BARRIER
TO OWNING THESE THINGS NOT BRING
THEM IS THE LACK OF FUELING
STATIONS- AND WHILE I APPRECIATE
THE FACT THAT ELECTRIC MAY BE
OUR SALVATION I THINK. IF WE
WANT TO TRULY ADDRESS THE
CLIMATE CRISIS WE HAVE TO BE A
GNOSTIC IN THE INNOVATION THAT
WE CHOSE CHOOSE TO PROMOTE. WE
ADDRESS BY ALL ACCOUNTS HAS
GREAT PROMISE I HAVE THE
PRIVILEGE OF REPRESENTING UC
IRVINE AND TALKING DIRECTLY
DOCTOR JACK BRAUER AND I KNOW
THAT- THERE'S REAL CONCERN ABOUT
THE AMOUNT OF LITHIUM AND COBALT
OUT THERE. ON THIS PLANET WITH
IT'S ENOUGH TO MEET OUR BATTERY
NEEDS- ACROSS THE ROAD OUR
STORAGE NEEDS AYE I THINK
HYDROGEN HAS GREAT PROMISE- WE
BUT IF WE WANT TO PROMOTE THAT
WOULD. GRATION OF SUBSIDIES TO
LECTURE. AND BATTERIES I THINK.
A SMALL SUBSIDY HERE THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS TO PROMOTE A
SERIES OF HYDROGEN CHARGING
STATIONS AROUND THE STATE. TO
TRY TO PROMOTE PICK UP HERE. I
THINK IS A VERY WISE INVESTMENT
AND IT'S JUST CLASSIC PORTFOLIO
INVESTMENT WE CANNOT PUT ALL OUR
EGGS IN ONE BASKET AS WE'RE
TRYING TO FIGHT THE CLIMATE
CRISIS SO. AGAIN PROUD TO BE A
CO AUTHOR THIS BILL WOULD LOOK
TO MOVE THE BUILT IT. AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME AND- YOU KNOW
STRONGLY. I'VE OPENED MY
COLLEAGUES. Q. ORDER SENATE
SENATOR ARE TO LET AND THEN
BACKED SENATOR CRITIC YOU
INTERFERE. I AM SO PROUD OF THIS
BILL I THINK IT BRINGS US FULL
CIRCLE- WITH THE BILLS THAT
I'VE- PUT ON THE TABLE WITH
YOURS. AND THE TESTIMONY WE JUST
HEARD. THIS IS PART OF A FEW. TO
SHARE WITH YOU. CAL STATE LA IN
LOS ANGELES COUNTY. THE ENTIRE
FLEET. OF CARS THEIR ENTIRE
FLEET THERE POLICE CARS. STAFF
CARS ALL RUN- ON HYDROGEN FUEL
CELL BATTERY. AND THEY HAVE THE
STATION THERE. THEY'VE HAD NO
PROBLEMS- WE HAVE THE GENERAL
PUBLIC NOW IS ABLE TO GO TO THAT
FUELING STATION- I KNOW THE
INDUSTRY IS STARTING TO GROW.
AND SAFETY IS ALWAYS NUMBER ONE.
AND I FEEL VERY CONFIDENT. THAT
WITH THE VETTING PROCESS AND
EACH AND EVERY CITY. THROUGHOUT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE'RE
GOING TO SEE. THE HYDROGEN FUEL
CELL BATTERIES AS PART OF THE
EVOLUTION OF. TAKING CARE OF OUR
ENVIRONMENT HITTING THAT GERALD
MISSION. SO I AM BE PROUD TO BE
AN OFF CO AUTHOR ON THIS BILL AS
WELL. AND WITH THAT I WILL GO
AHEAD AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATE ARCHULETA
SENATOR CORTESE. IN THE INTEREST
OF TIME IT WILL BE BRIEF BUT I
WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE- THE
CONCERNS OF- THE OPPOSITION IN
IT IT'S INTERESTING BECAUSE-
SOME OF THAT IS I KNOW- SORT OF
COMING FROM MY OWN COUNTY
GEOGRAPHICALLY SPEAKING- BUT- IN
THIS INTERESTING HAVE BEEN A
COUNTY SUPERVISOR THERE THAT.
THERE'S BEEN SOME SIGNIFICANT.
JIM BY THE COUNTY IN TERMS OF
CRAZY STATIONS FOR FLEET AND SO
FORTH BUT I JUST WANT TO SEE
REGARDLESS OF THE ONGOING DEBATE
ABOUT WHAT'S- BEST. I THINK THE
AMENDMENTS REALLY CREATE A
SITUATION VERY CLEARLY- THE THAT
IS GOING TO BE BASED ON NEED AND
ANALYSIS BY THE AGENCIES IT IT'S
NOT. FORCING US TO MAKE THAT
DECISION NOW IT'S ALLOWING THOSE
DECISIONS TO BE MADE AS
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION ANALYSIS
GATHERED I JUST WANT TO THANK.
THE CHAIR OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
WHEN THE AUTHOR FOR WORKING
TOGETHER TO TRY TO GET. TO THAT
LANDING POINT IN THEY ARE VERY
SUPPORTIVE GIVEN THE NEW
LANGUAGE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
CENTER CORTESE SENATOR ACCOUNT.
MANAGER I'M SORRY I WALKED IN
LIKE ON TV I'M THE AMENDMENTS
WERE TAKEN N. I'M- AS A BUDGET
SUB. SO TO- PICK. IN THE MONEY
THAT IS TO BE DEALT WITH AT A
DIFFERENT DATE. RIGHT AND SO.
SENATOR BECAUSE HE RAN INTO IT
YEAH I RAN INTO HIM IN THE
HALLWAY AND YOU ASKED ME
POLITELY TO STOP PLAYING- BUDGET
SAID TO CHEER. THEM GLAD TO DO
IT SO I WILL SAY I AM DELIVER
THE AGNOSTIC ABOUT THE FUNDS THE
PLACE TO START WITH THE CTP
THERE'S ISSUES AROUND
REAUTHORIZATION WE'RE HAVING A
LARGER CONVERSATION ABOUT THE
USE- AND APPLICATION THE STATE'S
BUDGET SURPLUS- GLAD TO CONTINUE
WORKING ON THAT AND I APPRECIATE
THAT IF WE CAN'T FIGURE OUT
THERE ARE LIMITATIONS. ON THE
CITY FUNDS ARE TIME LIMITED IS
WELL AND WHAT I DON'T WANT TO DO
IS HAVE THIS BE A ZERO SUM
PROPOSITION WITH RESPECT TO
OTHER INVESTMENTS SO TOTALLY
OPEN IT AND LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING. ON THAT ONE AS WE MOVE
FORWARD. OKAY THANK YOU. SENATOR
MELENDEZ. I THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR I JUST WANTED TO-
CONGRATULATE YOU SENATOR NEWMAN
ALL AND- WINNING THE AWARD FOR
USING THE WORD HYDROGEN THE MOST
TIMES IN ONE SINGLE. ILL
PRESENTATION IT IS THE MOST
ABUNDANT ELEMENT. AND
PRONOUNCING IT CORRECTLY I WANT
TO COMMEND YOU ON THAT
CONGRADULATIONS. AND WITH THAT
MADAM CHAIR I WILL YIELD MY
TIME. I THINK SENATOR ARE TO LET
IS LOOKING A LITTLE JEALOUS OVER
THERE SO- BUT NONE THE LESS I TO
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU SENATOR
NEWMAN FOR WORKING WITH OUR
COMMITTEE- CONSULTANTS AND- FOR-
EIGHT. INSURING THAT AGAIN ZERO
EMISSION FUTURE TECHNOLOGY
GNOSTIC ENSURING THAT IT'S NEEDS
BASED AND ALSO ENSURING THAT
WE'RE- LOOKING AT EV'S AND
HYDROGEN FUEL CELL THE SAME WAY-
AND SO I THINK WE'RE GOING TO BE
IN A GOOD PLACE MOVING FORWARD.
WITH THAT- I THINK THE MOTION
WAS MADE BY SENATOR ARCHULETA OR
DID YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS JUST
LOOK. OKAY CENTER TO LET ME THE
MOTION IT I'M SORRY SENATOR MEN
MADE THE MOTION MY APOLOGIES.
EVERYONE'S FIGHTING FOR THE
MOTIONS HERE MISTER CHIEF
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
. I NEVER CLOSED THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED AND RE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. SENATORS
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ HI BATES.
BATES AYE ALLEN. ARCHULETA
ARCHULETA HI BAKER. CORTESE
CORTESE HI DOLLY. DALY I GOT.
THE MOAN AT HER TO DO. LIMÓN I
MCGUIRE MCGUIRE AYE MELENDEZ
MELENDEZ AYE MAN MAN HI NEWMAN
ALL RIGHT NEWMAN AYE RUBIO.
SKINNER SKINNER HI WHAT KASKY.
YOU CAN DO IT MY CASHIER HIGH
WILK. TWELVE NOT. TWELVE ZERO
WELL THANK YOU I'M CALLING
CHAIRED THANK YOU MEMBERS ALL
RIGHTS SO NOW I THINK WE'VE GOT
MOST OF OUR MEMBERS HERE BUT
WILL RUN THROUGH THE- FILE
AGAIN- WE'RE GONNA START WITH
CONSENT ITEM NUMBER ONE WHICH IS
TO REVIVE CONSISTING OF S. NINE
EIGHTY FIVE ONLY AS WE KNOW WE
ALWAYS HAVE TO CONSENT CALENDARS
SO MISTER CHIEF CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON CONSENT.
ITEM NUMBER ONE. CONSENT
CALENDAR NUMBER ONE WHICH IS SB
NINE EIGHTY FIVE THE CHAIR
VOTING I THE VICE CHAIR VOTING
HI. DOLLY KELLY HI MON. LIMON HI
MELENDEZ MELENDEZ AYE SKINNER
SKINNER AYE WHY CASKEY CASKEY HI
WILK. SIXTEEN ZERO SIXTEEN ZERO
A RIGHT OF CONSENT COUNT THE
OKAY THE CONSENT CALENDAR NUMBER
ONE IS ADOPTED CONSENT CALENDAR
NUMBER TWO WHICH CONSISTS OF S.
C. R. NINETY SEVEN AND AS THE R.
NINETY EIGHT. ON CONSENT
CALENDAR NUMBER TWO OF S. C. R.
NINETY SEVEN AND S. C. R. NINETY
EIGHT THE CHAIRMAN THE VICE
CHAIR BOTH VOTING HI. DOLLY
DOLLY I LIMON. LIMON HI
MELENDEZ. MELENDEZ HI SKINNER MY
CASKEY CASKEY I. FIFTEEN ZERO
THE TOP FIFTEEN ZERO THAT IS
ADOPTED THANK YOU- SO WE'LL MOVE
ON TO FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE SB
NINE THIRTY TWO BY SENATOR
PORTANTINO. THE MOTION IS DUE
PASS AS AMENDED AND RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
THE CHAIR VOTING HI THE VICE
CHAIR VOTING NO. HELEN BAKER I
FELT SORRY ALLEN HI BAKER.
CORTESE CORTESE I DOT. MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE MELENDEZ MELENDEZ
NOW RUBIO. SKINNER SKINER HI Y.
CASKEY WHAT WHAT KASKY NO WILK.
NINE FOUR NINE FOUR FOUR OKAY
THE CAPITAL WILL KEEP THE BILL
ON CALL THAT'S FILE ITEM ONE
FILE ITEM THREE SB TEN FIFTEEN
BY SENATOR WESSEL. THE MOTION IS
DUE PASS AS AMENDED AND RE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS THE CHAIR VOTING
HI THE VICE CHIEF NOT VOTING.
BATES BATES NOW ALAN. BAKER HI
ALAN HI BAKER. CORTESE CORTESE I
WHERE MCGUIRE AYE LETTUCE
LETTUCE NO RUBIO. SKINNER
SKINNER HI BY CASKEY. WELCOME
MMHM. OF COURSE. TEN THREE TEN
THREE LEAVE THE BILL ON CALL
NEXT WE'LL MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM
FOR SB ELEVEN SIXTY NINE SENATOR
WESSEL. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AND REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS THE CHAIR VOTING
HI THE VICE CHAIR NOT VOTING.
BATES ALLEN HI ALLEN HI
ARCHULETA MUCH LETTER HI BAKER.
CORTESE CORTESE AYE MCGUIRE
ACQUIRE I MELENDEZ MELENDEZ NO
NEWMAN NEWMAN HI SKINNER- HI Y.
CASKEY BY CASKEY I WOKE.
THIRTEEN ONE THIRTEEN ONE LEAVE
THE BILL ON CALL NEXT FILE ITEM
FIVE SB ELEVEN EIGHTY ONE ALSO
BY SENATOR RUSSELL. THE MOTION
IS DUE PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS THE
CHAIR AND THE VICE CHAIR BOTH
VOTING HI. ALAN HI ALAN I
ARCHULETA. ARCHULETA HI BECKER.
MCGUIRE MCGUIRE AYE MELENDEZ
MELENDEZ AYE NEWMAN NEWMAN AYE
SKINNER SKINNER AYE WHY CASKEY
WHAT KASKY AYE WILK. FIFTEEN
FIFTEEN ZERO THE BILL IS OUT.
OKAY NEXT FILE ITEM SIX SB
ELEVEN NINETY SIX BY SENATOR
UMBERG. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AND REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS THE CHAIR VOTING
HI THE VICE CHAIR NOT VOTING.
BATES. ELEVEN NINETY SIX FILE
ITEM SIX. DOLLY LIMON FIVE CLONE
HIGH MELENDEZ MELENDEZ NO
SKINNER. SKINNER I Y. CASKEY.
TWELVE ONE TWELVE ONE OKAY.
TWELVE ONE AND LEAVE THE BILL ON
CALL THANK YOU S. B. TWELVE
TWENTY SIX FILE ITEM SEVEN BY
SENATOR THAT ALSO. THE MOTION IS
DUE PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS THE
CHAIR VOTING I THE VICE CHAIR
NOT VOTING. BATES BATES NOW.
DALI DALI NOW THE MOST LIMON I
MELENDEZ MELENDEZ NO SKINNER
SKINNER I Y. CASKEY. WILK.
EXACTLY WHY CASKEY I. THIRTEEN
THIRTEEN I KNOW THIRTEEN PEOPLE
THREE THIRTEEN THREE THE BILL IS
OUT MOVE ON NEXT TO S. B.
THIRTEEN FIFTY SIX SENATOR GROW
FILE ITEM EIGHT. THE MOTION IS
DUE PASS AS AMENDED AND RE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS THE CHAIR VOTING
NO THE VICE CHAIR VOTING HI.
ALAN ARCHULETA ARCHULETA NO
BAKER. CORTESE DOT. MELENDEZ HI
POLITICI MEN. NEWMAN RUBIO.
SKINNER SKINNER NOW Y. CASKEY.
WILK. THREE FIVE THREE FIVE WILL
LEAVE THE BILL ON THE CALL. NEXT
WE HAVE THE FILE ITEM ELEVEN SP
NINE ONE SEVEN BY SENATOR BECKER
. THE MOTION IS DUE PASS AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS THE CHAIR AND THE
VICE CHAIR BOTH VOTING HI. COPY. IN A LETTER YES CORRECT. DOT.
LIMON LOW MON I MELENDEZ
MELENDEZ NO RUBIO. SKINNER HI
SKINNER I Y. CASKEY WHAT KASKY
AYE WILK. TWELVE ONE TWELVE ONE
TO LEAVE THE BILL ON THE CALL.
FILE ITEM TWELVE SB TWELVE
SEVENTEEN SENATOR ALAN. THE MOST
IS DO PASS AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS THE
CHAIR VOTING HI THE VICE CHAIR
VOTING NO. DOLLY DOLLY NOW DOT.
LIMON LIMON HI MELENDEZ MELENDEZ
NOW RUBIO. SKINNER FIVE SKINNER
I Y. CASKEY BY CASKEY AYE WILK.
ELEVEN THREE ELEVEN THREE WILL
LEAVE THE BILL ON CALL. ALL
RIGHT FILE ITEM THIRTEEN AS THE
TWELVE FIFTY EIGHT. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS THE CHAIR AND THE
VICE CHAIR BOTH VOTING HI. DOLLY
ALII DOT. LIMON LIMON HI
MELENDEZ MELENDEZ AYE MIN AYE
MIN AYE RUBIO. SKINNER. YES
THAT'S CORRECT SKINNER HI MY
COUNTY MY CASKEY AYE WILK.
FOURTEEN ZERO FOURTEEN ZERO IT
LOOKS LIKE THAT BILL IS OUT BUT
WE WILL LEAVE IT ON CALL. OF
FILE ITEM FOURTEEN SB FOURTEEN
EIGHTY TWO SENATOR ALAN. THE
MOTION IS DUE PASS AND RE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS THE CHAIR VOTING
HI THE VICE CHAIR VOTING NOW.
DOLLY. DOLLY NO AMOUNT LIMÓN AYE
MCGUIRE MCGUIRE AYE MELENDEZ.
MELINDA'S NO MEN MEN AYE SKINNER
SKINNER HI Y. CASKEY CASKEY AYE
WILK. THIRTEEN THREE THIRTEEN
THREE THE BILL IS OUT SO MOVE ON
TO S. B. TWELVE THIRTY FILE ITEM
FIFTEEN BY SENATOR LIMON. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED AND
RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS THE CHAIR VOTING
HI THE VICE CHAIR NOT VOTING.
BATES ALLEN HI ELLEN HI. BAKER
DALI DALI I MCGUIRE HI WHERE
LANDIS. MAN MAN I SKINNER
SKINNER I BUY KOWSKI BY CASKEY
AYE WILK. THIRTEEN ZERO THIRTEEN
ZERO LIFT WILL LEAVE THE BILL ON
CALL. FILE ITEM SIXTEEN SB
TWELVE FORTY NINE SENATOR
ARCHULETA. THE MOTION IS DUE
PASS AS AMENDED AND RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
THE CHAIR AND THE VICE CHAIR
BOTH VOTING AYE. ALLEN THIS IS
ACTUALLY. HI ELLEN HI DOLLY.
LIMON. LIMON HI MCGUIRE MCGUIRE
HI MELENDEZ. MAN MAN HI NEWMAN
NEWMAN AYE SKINNER SKINNER AYE
WHY CASKEY. AYE CASKEY AYE WILK. I'M SORRY HI MELENDEZ I.
FIFTEEN ZERO FIFTEEN ZERO THE
BILL IS OUT. OKAY NEXT WE HAVE
CENTER ARCHER LET AS WELL FILE
ITEM SEVENTEEN AS THE TWELVE
NINETY ONE. IS DO PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS THE CHAIR VOTING
I'D THE VICE CHAIR NOT VOTING.
BATES ALLEN HI ALAN I BAKER.
DOLLY MCGUIRE MCGUIRE AYE
MELENDEZ WINDOWS I MEN MEN I
NEWMAN NEWMAN AYE SKINNER
SKINNER I BUY CASKEY. MAKOWSKI I
WILK. THIRTEEN ZERO THIRTEEN
ZERO LEAVE THE BILL ON CALL LAST
ITEM BY ITEM EIGHTEEN SB
THIRTEEN TWENTY NINE SENATOR
NEWMAN. THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS THE
CHAIR AND THE VICE CHAIR BOTH
VOTING HI. ALLEN. BAKER. DOT
DODD HIGH. RUBIO WILK. THIRTEEN
ZERO THIRTEEN ZERO LEAVE THE
BILL ON THE CALL OKAY GREAT-
THANK YOU WE BILLS- WE HAVE
THREE BILLS NEED AT ON TUESDAY.
OKAY OKAY. MAKE ME A TWENTY FIVE
OUR- YEAH BY THE END OF THE-
WHAT'S. WHAT VEHICLE ONE. FIVE
YEAH. THE LAST ONE WHAT WE'RE
GOING TO GO THROUGH IT AGAIN ALL
RIGHT FOR SENATOR DODD WILL GO
THROUGH FILE ITEM ELEVEN SB NINE
ONE SEVEN SENATOR BACKER.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS THE CHAIR THE
VICE CHAIR BOTH VOTING HI. DOLLY
DODD HI DODD I. RUBIO WILK.
THIRTEEN ONE OKAY THAT'S
THIRTEEN ONE. FILE ITEM TWELVE
SB TWELVE SEVENTEEN SENATOR ALAN
. THE MOTION IS DUE PASS AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS THE CHAIR VOTING
I THE VICE CHAIR VOTING NO. DOT
BY DOT I. RUBIO WILK. TWELVE
THREE TWELVE THREE. RIGHT FILE
ITEM THIRTEEN SB TWELVE FIFTY
EIGHT SENATOR ALAN. THE MOTION
IS DUE PASS AS AMENDED AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS THE CHAIR AND THE
VICE CHAIR BOTH VOTING HI DOT BY
DOT HIGH. RUBIO WILK. FIFTEEN
ZERO FIFTEEN ZERO OKAY THANK YOU
SENATOR. AND WE'LL WAIT FOR A
COUPLE OTHER MEMBERS TO COME
BACK FROM THEIR COMMITTEES AND
WILL FINISH THE ROLE- IN THE
FILE. THANK YOU.
AND ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA GO
AHEAD AND CALL THE ROLL FOR
SENATOR RUBIO AND WE'VE GOT FILE
ITEM ONE SB NINE THIRTY TWO. THE
MOTION IS DUE PASS AS AMENDED
ANDRE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS THE CHAIR VOTING
I'D THE VICE CHAIR VOTING NO.
DODD. RUBIO RUBIO AYE WILK. TEN
FOR TEN FOR THESE DOTS NOT
COMING BACK THE BILL TO IT YEAH
OKAY TEN FORCE OF THE BILL IS
OUT ON SB NINE THIRTY TWO
PORTANTINO. YEAH ALL RIGHT WE'LL
MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM THREE SB
TEN FIFTEEN SENATOR WESSEL. THE
MOTION IS DUE PASS AS AMENDED
AND RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS THE CHAIR VOTING
I'D THE VICE CHAIR VOTING NO.
BAKER RUBIO. RUBIO I BY CAL SKI
WILK. 11-3 OKAY 11-3 WAIT FOR
SENATOR BAKER- FILE ITEM EIGHT
SB THIRTEEN FIFTY SIX CENTER
GROVE. THE MOTION IS DUE PASS AS
AMENDED AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS THE
CHAIR VOTING NO THE VICE CHAIR
VOTING HI. ALAN BAKER CORTESE
DODD MAN NEWMAN RUBIO BY CAL SKI
WILK. THREE FIVE. THREE FIVE-
NEXT FILE ITEM ELEVEN SB NINE
ONE SEVEN SENATOR BAKER. THE
MOTION IS DUE PASS AND RE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS THE CHAIR AND THE
VICE CHAIR VOTING HI. DOLLY
RUBIO RUBIO AYE WILK. FORTY ONE
FOURTEEN ONE THE BILL IS OUT.
RIGHT FILE ITEM TWELVE SB TWELVE
SEVENTEEN SENATOR ALAN. THE
MOTIONS DO PASS AND REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
THE CHAIR VOTING HI THE VICE
CHAIR VOTING NO. RUBIO. RUBIO HI
WILK. THIRTY THREE THIRTY THREE
THE BILL IS OUT FILE ITEM
THIRTEEN SB TWELVE FIFTY EIGHT
SENATOR ALAN. THE MOTION IS DUE
PASS AS AMENDED AND RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
THE CHAIR AND THE VICE CHAIR
VOTING HI. RUBIO RUBIO AYE WILK
. SIXTEEN ZERO SIXTEEN ZERO THE
BILL IS OUT FILE ITEM EIGHTEEN
SB THIRTEEN TWENTY NINE SENATOR
NEWMAN. THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS THE
CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR BOTH VOTING
HI. ALAN BAKER REPLY. SO THE-
I'D BETTER HIGH. RUBIO WAS THAT
THERE WAS. SB THIRTEEN TWENTY
NINE THIRTEEN TWENTY NINE FILE
ITEM- I SET UP FROM SAN ON THAT
ONE. DECANA VOTING FOR- RUBIO
RUBIO I WILK. FIVE FOURTEEN ZERO
FOURTEEN ZERO THE BILL IS.
OUTPOLLED OVER HOLDING THE BELT
OKAY. ALLEN HE'S LIKE A DECK-
THEN- THE NEW YOUR DOCTOR OKAY
THE BILL IS OUT FOURTEEN OUT ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU ALL RIGHT WE'LL
GO BACK THROUGH THE ROLE I THINK
WE'LL FIGURE OUT WHAT- SENATOR
PACKARD. THE SECOND CHECK WE'LL
REASSESS YOU.
SO. WHERE.
OKAY WE'LL GO THROUGH THE FILE I
FILE ONE MORE TIME FOR SENATOR
BACK PERSONAL START WITH FILE
ITEM THREE SB TEN FIFTEEN
SENATOR WITH. MOTIONS DO PASSES
AMENDED AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS THE
CHAIR VOTING I THE VICE CHAIR
VOTING NO. BAKER HI THE KERR I.
BY CASKEY WILK. TWELVE THREE
TWELVE THREE THE BILL IS OUT
NEXT FILE ITEM FOR SB ELEVEN
SIXTY NINE SENATOR WITH SELF.
THE MOST IS DO PASS AND REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS THE CHAIR VOTING
BY THE VICE CHAIR NOT VOTING.
BATES BAKER HI BAKER I. WILK.
FORTY ONE FOURTEEN ONE THE BILL
IS OUT FILE ITEM FIVE SB ELEVEN
EIGHTY ONE SENATOR WESSEL. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AND WE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS THE CHAIR AND THE
VICE CHAIR BOTH VOTING HI BAKER.
HI I WILK. SIXTEEN ZERO SIXTEEN
ZERO THE BILL IS OUT FILE ITEM
EIGHT SB THIRTEEN FIFTY SIX
CENTER GROVE. THE MOST IS DO
PASS AS AMENDED AND RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTE ON APPROPRIATIONS
THE CHAIR VOTING NO THE VICE
CHAIR VOTING HI. ALAN BAKER.
NUMBER CORTESE DODD MAN. NEWMAN
RUBIO BY CAL SKI WILK. THREE
FIVE THREE FIVE THE BILL IS NOT
OUT BILL FAILS- S. B. NINE ONE
SEVEN FILE ITEM ELEVEN SENATOR
BACKER. YEAH HE'S HE'S ONLY ON
THE HISTORY ON THAT ONE OKAY.
JEEZ ALL RIGHT S. B. TWELVE
THIRTY FILE ITEM FIFTEEN CENTER
LIMON. THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED. AND WE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS THAT
YOUR VOTING HI THE VICE CHAIR
NOT VOTING. BATES BAKER HI BAKER
I. MELENDEZ WILK. FOURTEEN ZERO
FOURTEEN ZERO THE BILL IS OUT
RIGHT S. B. TWELVE NINETY ONE
FILE ITEM SEVENTEEN SENATOR
ARCHULETA. THE MOTION IS DUE
PASS AND WE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS THE
JEOPARDY I THE VICE CHAIR NOT
VOTING. BATES BAKER. HI BAKER HI
DOLLY. WILK. FOURTEEN ZERO
FOURTEEN ZERO THE BILL IS OUT
GREATS THAT CONCLUDES OUR FOR
THE LAST.YEAH.
OKAY SO AFTER JUST A FEW. OF THE
OTHER. REPUBLICAN CALLED. OKAY
THIS MISTER CHIEF CONSULTANT CAN
YOU CALL THE ROLL ONE LAST TIME
PLEASE. ON S. B. ELEVEN NINETY
SIX THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS THE CHAIR VOTING
I THE VICE CHAIR NOT VOTING.
BATES DOLLY BY CAL SKI WILK.
TWELVE ONE. YEAH GREAT SO THAT
CONCLUDES OUR FILE ITEM ON OUR
AGENDA AT THIS TIME. AND IT
LOOKS LIKE- WE ARE CONCLUDED AND
SO WHEN I THINK EVERYONE WHO FOR
PARTICIPATING AND THIS US SENATE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE IS
FINALLY ADJOURNED THANK YOU. BUT. YEAH YEAH YEAH.